goldman sachs from 2000 to 2002 good
morning
good morning paul what do you think of
this nomination of henry paulsen for
treasury
um well i think two things one is that
uh henry or hank paulson as he's known
as a very smart very capable very strong
personality
and on the other hand it's it's not
clear to me that what we need as a
country on the ground is more wall
street in washington
explain for us your work experience with
uh mr paulson uh when was it what kind
of work did you all do together and what
impressions did you come away with from
your time with him
well um i didn't work directly for hank
obviously he was at the very top of the
firm i came in as a managing director in
early 2000
after spending about seven years
overseas in banking for bear stearns and
at goldman i was
in charge of a group that worked a lot
with
various institutions corporations major
uh other banks in terms of looking at
their balance sheets and figuring out
what what sort of worked for um those
companies in terms of uh their
profitability
mr paulston was i was the ceo and
chairman of the firm at the time
and during the time i was there
the firm actually started its path along
the lines of becoming less of what's a
kind of traditional investment bank
working with mergers and acquisitions
and getting hard fee
uh to do that and much more of sort of a
trading firm which it's uh become today
which is that it basically makes a lot
of money on on the risk that it takes um
the meetings that i had been in where mr
paulson was was present or running them
um as well as um
a christmas party or so uh were meetings
in which she was you know very strong
very capable very stern you know i'd say
very cold but uh uh
stern um where where basically he was in
command he was in command to detail he
was command of the room he was in
command of the aura and um i think
that's something that
you know president bush
needs on one hand and on the other hand
i think it's a kind of disconnected
personality from what i think we need as
a country um to really bring up
the the general domestic economy and and
the people that work within it we want
to invite the viewers to phone in with
their questions and comments for our
guest on the paulson nomination if
you're a supporter of president bush
here's your number 202-737001
if you're a supporter of democrats at
737-002 and for others 202
628-0205 our guest up in new york is
nomi prinz a former managing director at
goldman sachs now works as a senior
fellow at demos it's a public policy
research and advocacy organization up in
new york and
nomie prinze you wrote an article
recently for the nation
magazine online folks can read that
through our website at c-span.org and
wanted you to elaborate for the audience
and for us
on a point that you made in the piece
we'll read part of it first you wrote
that what struck me
first upon news of paulson's possible
appointment was that he's too smart to
take on this task with bush's approval
ratings for his economic policies
hovering at around 40 percent
then i got it paulson is bush's last
hurrah and his last chance uh what do
you what do you mean
well i mean that in taking someone with
the kind of financial credibility
and success that
mr paulson has had on wall street
in a situation where the policies of the
bush administration from an economic
standpoint have been completely
miserable we're in a situation where
our country has the largest national
debt that is money we owe other
countries in the world that we have ever
had in our history we have a tremendous
deficit our trade and balance is is at
an all-time high meaning it costs us
more to buy imports that are coming from
overseas it costs other countries less
to buy our stuff which makes what we do
less valuable to us as citizens in the
country so there's a lot of things that
this administration has just simply
messed up in terms of managing its its
budget and when you look at someone like
paulson you have someone again who's
powerful who's smart who's been seen to
be credible in the field in which he's
been in on wall street and has been
successful in that field
coming in to lend some credibility to
these policies which which have gone
just so deeply wrong for the general
economy before we get to uh calls for
our guest uh we'll take a look at the
business week
magazine from uh recently mr risk goes
to washington it's a a major piece here
beginning on page 46 it has a picture of
hank paulson of goldman sachs on the
cover and inside naomi prince they write
michael mandel writes the piece and
he writes that what he'll bring to
treasury and to washington is a more
sophisticated understanding of risk and
return than his two immediate
predecessors had as treasury secretary
he'll be perfectly positioned to explain
to senators and citizens alike the true
consequences of various policy choices
in such vital areas as free trade where
avoiding risk means falling further
behind what's your reaction
um i i think it's sort of a skewed way
of looking at it because i i don't think
what the american economy and people
need is is more
risk with respect to the budget you know
you look at you look at what the what
the budget is it's not just
international trade and if you even do
look at international trade you're
looking at the fact that the dollar is
so weak and the dollar is so weak
because we have so much debt you know
you bring it back to sort of personal
situations and in anyone's home if you
owe a lot of money to anybody you're not
a good bet and so when you look at
international trade policy you have to
start with the fact that as a country
we're in that poor position so the fact
that someone you know can take risk and
as i said before goldman in in recent
years has taken tremendous amounts of
risks um in its own uh balance sheet in
its own behavior as a company so
absolutely polson has presided over that
that situation goldman's done very very
very well on wall street and their stock
has done very very well under his
leadership but but that's not what you
need and it's also a deflection from the
issue of actually managing domestic
economy so so we have situations where
uh we need to figure out how to how to
curtail our domestic debt our the the
deficit for which um it's extremely high
the interest on our debt alone
uh is twenty seven thousand dollars uh
a year to every individual in this
country you know so so
risk isn't what you need what you
actually need to some kind of control
before we get to calls uh
nomie prinz how important is treasury
secretary how influential
um well recently um with the two
predecessors particularly jon snow the
the major task of the treasury secretary
has been to um going back to the theme i
was mentioning before has been to go to
congress sort of every year and ask for
a trillion dollars more in in debt or
our ability to sort of print money which
is which is borrowed overseas invite by
some um
indiv
investors here in this country but but
the treasury secretary has
enormous influence um
and particularly if it is a strong
individual we saw you know with robert
rubin and the clinton administration
tremendous influence on economic policy
coming from that office
and tremendous influence on banking
policy
and to that extent we've had a bit less
of that because there's been this sort
of catch-up because of the policy
decisions that have come from the
administration that have been sort of
blessed in congress and that have
really largely been
pushed along by by the treasury
secretary position i think right now it
has the potential to be a stronger voice
um and particularly with with pulse and
as a stronger voice um but you know
you're talking about someone's in
control of how much money we print what
what our foreign
standing is with respect to our trade
you know who's in control of 12 12
bureaus um in washington including the
irs you're talking about an influential
powerful decision it's it's it's the
person in control of the money first
call for nomie prinz former managing
director at goldman sachs st louis
thanks for waiting hi there good morning
how are you fine how you doing i'm
calling um
i understand you know about the paulson
nomination and the way that i see things
that bush and his administration have
done they have put people in positions
to cover up their indiscretions
i feel like waffle woods was put over
the world bank to hide their money
transfers for all the money that's been
stolen from this country they have put
people in positions to cover their
backsides it stands to reason you don't
spend 60 million dollars to get a job
that only pays 400 000 a year
people invest money to get a return and
i feel like they've gotten more than
their 60 million in return
on over the trillions that they have
struggled and i don't hear you all
saying anything about the fact that bush
and his cronies are going into the
archives changing our history all the
way back to 1950.
thanks nomie prinz up in new york
um well you know you bring up a good
point the the the way in which things
have worked uh you talk about 1950 i
mean right after world war ii let's look
at how the money that comes into
congress uh into our budget works you
know you had a situation for example
where the corporations in this country
paid um more than half of the amount
that is the federal budget today you
have a situation where that that number
is down to seven percent uh and
obviously therefore individuals are are
paying more of that burden at the same
time the bush administration has pushed
through tax cuts to ostensibly make that
look better when in fact those tax cuts
have put more of a burden on the overall
budget meaning more debt meaning more
deficit meaning less funding for other
programs that that most average
americans rely on uh you know like
student aid like medicare like medicaid
um and and you know had had that sort of
benefit more of the wealthier in the
country whereas the average person in
the country has gotten about 600 bucks
of that which has been eaten up
completely by those increases in in
university costs and health care costs
um in in scare sort of situations
relative to social security which this
administration has borrowed borrowed 700
billion dollars from so so absolutely uh
there's a lot of mismanagement and you
know and sort of moving and shading
lines within the budget that this
administration has presided over more of
the words of uh nomi prince in the
nation magazine uh what's good for
goldman sachs isn't necessarily good for
middle america she writes therein lies
the conflict of a man whose entire
career has been predicated on
successfully promoting corporate welfare
over public interest the hearings at uh
10 o'clock eastern time this morning on
c-span 3 in lafayette california you're
up now good morning
good morning and it's an honor to be on
uh hello nomi um i just want to flush
out some of your philosophy i like you
was
somewhat surprised and impressed that
possibly take this post and i don't want
to look at it in such a cynical way that
other people do i think we're honored to
have a service but my question to you is
there is really no linkage between tax
rates
and tax receipts that flow into
washington dc
and if you really look at the total pie
of what people are paying in taxes after
the tax revision
the top 10 percent are actually paying a
higher loan than they were before uh
president bush's tax cuts were
implemented so i'm curious and as a
percentage of our
as our gdp our deficit's actually
shrinking so i want to i'm trying to
figure out your frustration with are you
against supply-side economics do you
want higher tax rates on the individual
and i just want to thank you for your
time and listen to your input thank you
thanks for that i i i'm not advocating
blanket tax increases um and yes there's
a little bit of um
there has been more receipts coming in
and from the wealthy but there's also
been breaks um coming into them from
from on an individual basis and breaks
coming in from different parts of
of their own tax returns whether they be
dividend tax cuts or or
um
or any sort of thing on stock side
whether that you know in in their
positions as running corporations to
what extent corporations have been
playing paying less taxes and less
receipts into the government so so so i
agree the tax situation has a lot of
components to it but but the fact is if
you look at the
average gain that the average american
has received out of the tax cuts it it's
very it's been very minimal and and i
think that's that's one of the issues
and i i i am for managing the budget in
such a way i think that helps
more of of the average american person
not necessarily increasing taxes blankly
i i would advocate increasing taxes for
corporations and putting more
regulations on some of the ways in which
they they spend their money in terms of
helping to create jobs and other things
like that
but
i think there there is a direct
relationship because when when you when
you look at the deficits yes it's down a
little bit over the last year but but
it's still a large number and more than
that and i think i mentioned a bit more
in the beginning is is the debt it is
the money we owe it is the money we
borrowed from the social security trust
fund or the administration has um it's
the fact that we're more
on the hook for a foreign to foreign
governments for the fact that they own
our debt they basically supply us with
the credit line to function as a country
and i think that
generally is a really precarious
position which has just been borne out
by the fact that um our capacity to buy
things as as a nation is actually
reduced by by the policies of this
administration the san diego union
tribune wrote a recent editorial about
the paulson nomination they write in
part to be sure the president needs help
lifting his poll numbers a crippled
political leader is bad for the nation
but paulson's new job is all about
substance and the union tribune goes on
to say that paulson fits right in
beginning with his outspoken support of
the bush tax cuts along with greenspan
paulson understands that cutting
government spending is the correct
answer to reducing the 300 billion
federal deficit taxes already are
creeping toward historic highs as
middle-class families boost their
incomes
lancaster pennsylvania you're on with
nomi prince good morning hey good
morning i got to tell you i'm on the
treadmill every day watching washington
journal it helps get my heart rate up
almost as much as your guests and your
callers
to the last caller when he says the debt
is reduced he means the budget deficit
the federal deficit currently at 8.4
trillion dollars is a new record uh
budget deficits three records so far in
the last four years under this
administration
and federal tax revenues are up this
year but however they set uh they were
actually went the other way the last
three years first time since the
depression
my question is uh naomi uh normally i
appreciate your perspective uh the job
that you had i'm wondering if
you can add any perspective to this
position that mr paulson takes
uh since nobody really wanted this job
and they've been searching for quite a
while
if and this isn't particular to mr
paulson but if there are
legal aspects for him taking this job
that mean it's a pretty big payday for
him if he gets
uh some sort of consideration for stock
options that kind of thing
um i don't know if you know what i mean
but i'm wondering if there isn't some
it's not a payback i mean every every
secretary would get it but uh if there
is some sort of uh quid pro quo here uh
nomi prince begin with just the basics
of all that how much goldman sachs stock
does mr paulson have and what does he
have to do with it right now
um well based on their last proxy
statement i believe he owns 4.8 million
shares of which 3.2
or so million are active shares meaning
they're not restricted by the the
rules of goldman sachs as an institution
which is that when they issue shares um
generally as part of compensation to to
their employees um a lot of them are are
called rsu's are restricted
stock units which means that they're not
actually in play um they're sort of
there to be redeemed at some later date
depending on how much was um offered and
in which year and sort of what the
percentages are for that amount and that
also includes a set of stock options so
uh what
paulson has said or his spokespeople
have said is that he will be selling
that 3.2 million
shares which um are about worth about
460 or 400 or 70 or so million dollars
um again a little bit of a disconnect to
the average salary of the average
america or the average you know personal
net wealth but um
and then and then the rest as i
understand goldman's rules um from
having been there and read them is is
that would be uh restricted um so not
necessarily for sale
let's go to syracuse new york good
morning to you
hi how you doing fine how are you um i'd
just like to point out uh mrs gnomie
here that uh it was bill clinton that uh
put nafta in gannon in 1993.
uh here here i believe that uh she's
blaming bush for clinton's mistakes
also in 1996 we came out they came out
with something called the wto
this trade deal is killing this country
period
he's created another
that just called the
trade deficit
along with the amount of money that
the clinton administration spent
during his administration he's
basically doubled our national bet so
he's done more damage just about as much
damage
as where it started with jimmy carter
so you know i mean to sit there and
blame bush is kind of ridiculous if you
look at our stock market it's up to 11
000 i mean the democrats were doing
cartwheels
uh
with the stock market saying how great
the economy was all through the 90s
uh
i'll tell you we've been benedict arnold
here and all of our manufacturing jobs
are gone overseas thank you caller get
the point let's hear from our guest up
in new york
um no you bring up some a lot of points
in in what you just said i think
um
i think i am blaming the bush
administration for for their mistakes
and and i agree with you that the
clinton administration made made
separate mistakes um and part of them
was in how world trade was done and part
of it was in a lot of 1996 um
deregulation of our industries from
banking to telecommunications to to
energy which created a situation where
um it's not necessarily clear all the
time within a company what they're what
they're actually doing where they're
operating how those tax receipts are are
coming in and all sorts of different
things that became harder to track as
they became sort of less regulated and
more
uh globally spanning so so i so i i
don't um
discount how that ball was set in motion
in terms of where you take it though the
the deficit was actually a surplus when
when clinton left the office um
and and now it is is a deficit but but
again more than that is is is the amount
of borrowing um that we've done and in
terms of
that
i think that the administration has been
this administration has been reckless
with in in a much more dire way for
average americans in anything from
uh
general lifestyle to to jobs uh than the
clinton administration left off with but
but not to not to exclude um them for
their
role in um in that and in robert rubin's
role at the time for being treasury
secretary under a sort of massive
corporate deregulation and and and
different changes in trade that happened
our guest worked for goldman sachs from
2000 to 2002 she's a former managing
director educated at uh state university
new york at purchase has a bachelor's
degree in mathematics also a master's in
statistics and operations research from
nyu new york university she has known me
prince and you got a book coming out in
a couple months what's it called what's
it about
um well it's it's afropol the topic
we're talking about this morning it's
called jacked um how conservatives are
picking your pocket whether you voted
for them or not
um and what i did for the book was
actually travel around the country i
kind of got out of new york got out of
washington
where we also spent a lot of time
talking to each other
and
traveled around the country through the
coast through the middle part of the
country visiting auto workers in detroit
spending time on the mississippi gulf
and in new orleans looking at what
government has done or not done since
hurricane katrina
you know talking to everyone from truck
drivers to single moms to jazz singers
to senior citizens and kind of getting
an idea of what
people were thinking regardless of
political affiliation about how their
wallets have been affected and sort of
the cards in them that represent you
know credit cards for their for debt and
national debt driver's license and oil
prices uh social security cards health
insurance and and get a sense for their
own stories um which was actually very
very much more interesting i think than
simply uh looking at it from a
statistical level actually hearing it in
their words
and it was it was a very interesting
experience and that book is going to be
coming out in early september call now
from laplace louisiana welcome to the
program uh how you doing you are a
breath of fresh air i am so glad they
have you on tv
somebody who is willing to speak the
truth to power and not afraid to speak
the truth about the situation of our u.s
economy i mean everybody
just like the gentleman um priya said
that bush picks people that benefits his
his
um
his administration but nobody is taking
in account that if i ran my home the way
this like you just said a few minutes
ago if i ran my home my husband would
would divorce me because of the debt if
i went out and just spent like i had no
tomorrow my husband and my sons would
get rid of me thanks nomi prinz when you
look to today's hearing uh by the
finance committee uh what will you be
looking for what will be the most
important
questions or or answers that uh mr
paulson will have to give
well i think that the debt is going to
be a big question in terms of how he
would manage it what he would do with it
and i don't actually know um
that there is a good answer so i'd be
very interested in what he has to say
about that i mean he has advocated for
tax cuts which i'm sure will be
on the table and again tax cuts
that
take from other places in the budget
that i think are more useful to
the average person in america
i think he will spend a lot of time
talking about china and and the foreign
trade imbalance issue which i think
a lot of the press has picked up on
which i believe to be a little
deflective of again the issues of the
domestic economy which which are more
pressing particularly up through into
the elections for us i think there might
be some questions or one or so about uh
the nature of social security i mean
he's been uh bush has been an advocate
obviously for privatizing
or basically placing the burden of
social security and that that extra
insurance on to individuals away from
the government i think that might be a
question that's brought up
i think you're going to hear though a
lot of
focus
from his major supporters in the finance
committee on international trade i would
assume and again that's a little bit
deflective but that is uh one of his
fortes ten o'clock c-span three live the
hearing of the senate finance committee
on the confirmation of henry paulsen to
be treasury secretary will uh also tape
it to you a little bit later tonight on
one of the networks new york city iran
with nomi prinz now hi
good morning i'd like to ask a guest uh
you're working at goldman sachs is
usually the dream job of someone in her
chosen profession i was wondering what
were the reasons for her departure and
what role mr paulson
played in her leaving because it seems
she certainly has an axe to grind thanks
know me prince
um i i i left because i wanted to do
something else with my life um mr
paulson was not at all related to to my
reason for leaving my reason for leaving
had a lot to do with
uh you know a lot of personal things
everything from leaving right after uh 9
11 and being down in the wall street
area on that day to realizing you know
life is what we make of it and i i
wanted to do other things i had been at
goldman and on wall street for a number
of years and and i i wanted to sort of
break free of that uh environment so a
lot of it was a personal decision
um
i i still think goldman's a well-run
company i think polson's an intelligent
man i i just having done what i'm doing
on the outside and and talking more to
people and looking at what the effects
of
wall street and sort of the policies
that help it have have
done to an average american i i just
feel like
um
i want to take the time in my life and
have been to to sort of look at that
more critically uh in general moving on
to minneapolis for nomi prinz hello
there hello good morning thank you for
taking my call
uh i i guess i have a couple of quick
questions although i think that your
guests already sort of touched on it my
first question is
i'd like to get a better sense of
the role
that the treasury secretary plays in the
formulation trade policy my sense has
always been
that it's uh our trade representative
who has kind of most
um authority and power
and although obviously as you said
treasury secretary has a lot of
influence
um and my second question is
what the effect would be of this
nomination on kind of the direction of
our global trade talks right now with
the doha round my sense is that we're
not getting what we want with countries
like brazil stepping up and challenging
us
and i guess i'm wondering as to whether
you see us moving more quickly towards
bilateral trade talks
with uh his nomination thank you very
much thanks
um thanks yeah i mean in terms of of the
position and again um there is a
substantial amount of this role that
that is uh international trade
ambassador and looking at international
policy as well as the component that
that is part of the job as as a public
uh servant
so to speak in washington of focusing on
on the domestic economy and in our
policies here
um
i think there will be again a focus of
him i mean in terms of making uh
brazil behave differently i don't
actually think that's going to happen in
terms of you know the china uh block uh
you didn't mention it now but but in
terms of of that component i think
he has a strong relationship with with
that government and and with their
central banks um it's not clear to me
how much
he probably had more of an ability to
influence it in terms of of deals with
with goldman and from the wall street
position that he might actually have as
as the treasury secretary given again
the fact that we're going into any talks
as a country uh in a very weak position
given how much we owe uh the rest of the
world do you know uh nomi prinz what mr
paulson's position might be or or
on this swift financial program this uh
story that's broken in the new york
times in the last week about the
terror tracking program of finances
now in terms of the bank accounts yeah
um
i i he's publicly come out and said
anything i would imagine his position
would be that um and again coming from
who's put him in power and what his
politics have been is that you know
terror and terrorism is is an issue and
that if we need to open bank accounts um
as a government to find information that
could capture terrorists that's
something that we would need to do as a
country
i would imagine that he would maintain
that that line and he knows exactly how
much information can be gleaned off bank
accounts whether for terrorist capturing
or any other
purposes so again i imagine he would he
would support that
last call for our guest uh town just
outside buffalo cheektowaga new york
good morning
oh good morning um yeah miss prince out
before you
before
after you leave today what i recommend
you do is to sue the university of new
york at purchase
and nyu
i you have showed a glittering ignorance
of economic anything
you are blaming tax cuts which have
increased
money to the treasury you took
mathematics
how in the world can you stand there
advocate higher taxes that's what you're
doing if you're saying raise the taxes
to where they were before you're just
advocating it now what i also want to
point out and this is what liberals and
you are a liberal you do believe in
redistribution of wealth i how in the
world can you go and advocate taxing
companies when companies aren't
individuals they are entities and when
you have to pay taxes and you must know
that on a sheet of doing on a cost
analysis of doing business one of the
factors that you have to factor in is
the cost of taxes which are not really
paid by companies necessarily they're
just passed on to consumers
and so i would really
i would like to know who gave you your
job because i need a job and apparently
the qualifications are not that
stringent to become a managing director
at goldman sachs thanks let's get a
final thought from our guest on all this
know me prince
um
i you know that that that is your
opinion i i uh i'm advocating for
a redistribution
of the way in which wealth is is created
absolutely if that makes me a liberal
i'm a liberal i'm i'm fine you know that
is true but i think the numbers bear the
fact that
the tax cuts and various other
expenditures of this government actually
have contributed directly to um to
having less money for other programs
that actually probably um i don't know
what your job is
you'll probably help you as an
individual more than you you actually
may
appreciate
or
or or or look at in that manner our
guest step in new york city has been
nomi prinz managing director from 2000
to 2002 at goldman sachs we appreciate
your time this morning
thank you we uh have an hour left in
this tuesday edition of the washington
journal we'll be out at nine o'clock
eastern time because the u.s house is
coming in coming up in just a couple
minutes senator orrin hatch republican
from utah sponsor of the flag
desecration amendment up for debate
again today and
coming up next book tv presents
afterwards an hour-long discussion
between a guest host and the author of a
new book this week nomi prinz former
managing director at goldman sachs and
current senior fellow at demos talks
about her book it takes a pillage behind
the bailouts bonuses and backroom deals
from washington to wall street
she discusses the book with senator
bernie sanders of vermont mr sanders who
was a u.s congressman for 16 years
before moving to the senate is the
author of the memoir outsider in the
house
[Music]
let me begin by thanking csman for the
opportunity to be interviewing
nomie prinz who is the author of it
takes a pillage behind the bailouts
bonuses and back room deals from
washington to wall street
when i was in the house
for 16 years i served on the financial
services committee so i have some
familiarity with this issue and needless
to say i have been
actively involved in it in the last
three years in the senate
nomi thank you very much for being with
us today well thank you very much and
thank you for for taking the time to to
be here as well today senator tell me
let's begin uh
uh with a little bit of background about
you where were you born
and
what happened in your life
to to end up to have you end up on wall
street and write the books that you've
written
well i i was born in upstate new york
and in poughkeepsie right outside of
vassar college
where my father had at one point been a
professor and then he was working in
research at ibm there it was very much
an ibm town
at the time and we were very much a
mathematical type of family a lot of
work with numbers from from a very very
young age and i ultimately wound up
going to a state school
to suny purchase a little closer to new
york city getting closer to wall street
to some extent where i studied
mathematics and i minored in music but
my father said math is really the way to
get a decent living and and you know
find a job and as it turned out that was
that was true because ultimately that
was what was being hired on wall street
at the time a lot of
math and engineering and computer
science were really the degrees that the
street was looking for and so what i
really just wanted to do is move to new
york
as you do when you graduate college and
um i wound up getting my first job at
chase manhattan bank before it was part
of jp morgan chase um when i graduated
actually before i graduated even when i
was i was 19 i sort of did a transition
yes i was and then i started um they're
doing a lot of uh analysis and sort of
computer work and numerical work on what
was wrong with you why when others are
partying and having a great time did you
end up on work i was way too serious
i was the oldest child in the family and
i think that might have had something to
do with it that sort of sense of
responsibility and financial
independence and everything else i think
i somehow wound up over there and i i
figured
i was only going to be there for a year
or two and sort of work in musical
theater or something else in new york
instead and as it turned out i wound up
staying there
a very long time through a number of
different firms and i think it just
became
just
easy to some extent with all of the
hardness that comes with wall street and
within wall street firms
you did make enough money to pay rent in
new york city and everything else
nothing like the kinds of sums that are
being made today but certainly enough to
to live on your own well let me ask you
this i mean you write your book
in a sense
as as being in the belly of the beast so
to speak you were there
so what impact on your views on your
life views about wall street uh
occurred as a result of your working for
goldman sachs how many years did you
work for goldman sachs i was the goldman
sachs for two years it was the end of my
career on wall street i actually ejected
myself from wall street after having
been at goldman sachs stearns you worked
in as well and bear stearns as well i
was over in london actually for bear
stearns i ran an analytics group there
for seven years so that was really the
crux of a lot of the work i was doing on
wall street and internationally and then
i came to goldman so
what impact did your experience on wall
street have
on your views what did you learn you
were on the inside most of us are not on
the inside yeah one of the things you
know on the inside and you learn on the
inside is there is such a tremendously
competitive environment which there
aren't a lot of other places but but in
wall street it's almost like you come in
every single day and the higher you move
up in a firm the more this is the case
every single day
trying to figure out how much credit you
can take for a particular trade if you
can beat someone on another desk or in
another area of the firm you actually
race to the offices of senior management
in order to be able to tell them what
you did to take part in a certain uh
deal or a transaction and very much
becomes this this immediate
type of an environment where if you
don't do that you you don't succeed and
if you're someone who who wants to try
and succeed you sort of get involved in
this game and i ultimately found that
very distasteful and really quite empty
but but the environment is is very much
like that it's very um intense from a
gamesmanship and a power sort of play as
well as it's really like a military
strategy almost every day going in it's
literally from whose name you put on an
email first to whose office you go into
first to who you tell about a certain
trade before someone else knows sounds
like the united states congress
but but let me ask you let me ask you a
question i think that is on the minds of
millions of americans
right now we are in the most serious
economic decline since the great
depression
if you add up the number of people who
are unemployed underemployed and given
up looking for work 17 of the american
adult workforce
is in that position it is a disaster
people have lost their homes they've
lost their savings they lost their
pensions
all because in my view at least of the
greed of the people on wall street now
one of the first questions i want to ask
you is some people say well nobody could
have predicted this my god it just came
out of the blue it was just amazing
totally unpredictable how do you respond
to that it was absolutely predictable
for a lot of reasons one is that that
mentality in the street
the reason this crisis happened was
because um there was a desire to find
products and to create assets within
wall street that made money and they
don't really care it doesn't matter to
wall street firms what those assets are
it turned out that they created assets
out of a small amount of subprime loans
and when i say a small amount i look at
it like it's an upside down pyramid
where at the bottom point you have
subprime loans and 1.4 trillion of those
were issued during 2002 to 2007. but
what wall street does is it takes them
and it creates new securities this whole
other band of securities um and from
those it can make fees it can make
trading commissions and a lot of other
profits they made 300 billion dollars
just on creating securities out of these
loans not on even trading them back and
forth just on the sheer creation of
these securities during those same years
and then what they do is they take those
securities they borrow against them to
create new ones and to merge and to
acquire and to trade and to speculate so
it all goes upward that's why this whole
thing fell down it wasn't that the
subprime loans got wrong it was that all
of the securities and trading on top of
them
toppled over you know what
i think most people kind of scratch that
and when they
went to school we learned about
economics you see somebody starts a
business and maybe they
maybe they sell automobiles and maybe
they sell clocks maybe they sell shoes
maybe they manufacture these things so
here's my really tough question for you
what the hell do they do
on wall street what do they make what do
they produce well they they produce
assets that only have value because they
choose to say that they have value there
there is
my life for your life in my kids lives
it absolutely doesn't and and that's a
really good um analysis of the street
that wall street exists and particularly
investment banks and the most
speculative components of banks exist
purely to create to engineer that's what
they talk it's engineering assets it's
not engineering a train track it's not
engineering a building it's engineering
something that only has value because
they say it does and and it it gets its
value from from that i i have a
quote in my book which is great from the
senior partner at goldman sachs who left
the firm to actually go to morgan
stanley and it was quite senior there
who said it's one of the only
finance is one of the only arts that's
basically or science is created
predicated on the creation of absolutely
nothing and it's only by pushing that
nothing for something throughout the
system because people continue to buy it
that this continues to churn and you
create these sort of upside down
pyramids of risk and assets that don't
truly have intrinsic value so at a time
when our manufacturing capability is
declining
we lost millions of good manufacturing
jobs our infrastructure is in major dis
repair we desperately need scientists to
help us deal with illnesses
uh etc etc we're seeing some of the best
minds in the country going into a sphere
of activity which produces virtually
nothing that is useful to the ordinary
person it is not useful to the ordinary
person it is purely the amount of profit
if you look at a company like goldman
sachs a top-tier investment firm
they pay almost 50 of their profits out
in bonuses in in another in any type of
production company or even retail
company the amount of money that's paid
in terms of compensation is maybe 20 or
22 percent so all of that extra fluff
all of that extra profit that's really
just about moving transactions really
moving money back and forth goes
directly into
these extravagant bonuses and
extravagant compensation structures it
doesn't go out anymore it doesn't even
pretend to go out anywhere it stays
right there and it looks to me like
we're developing two separate worlds
yeah and and i i can't remember the
figure i think it was like something
like 40 of the profits in america are
now being made on wall street
which is rather an extraordinary number
it's an extraordinary of course in in in
new york city it's it's an even greater
proportion of what what revenue comes
into the city and it it's an obscene
number because it's really not
predicated on on the creation of
anything we're still talking about
assets that pretend to have value and
that are rated to have value there's all
these other agencies that work with wall
street like the rating agencies like s p
and like moody's and they come in they
basically stamp value by
deciding that these assets are worth a
certain amount or that they have a
certain quality attached to them they
call it triple a and if you call
something aaa it sounds really good and
investors buy it and pension funds buy
it and states buy it and individuals
hear about it from their local bankers
and and so basically this infiltrates
the entire system
i remember i'm a member of the budget
committee now uh and we had uh hank
paulson in a couple of years ago and i
said
mr paulson back in my state of vermont
around this country the middle class is
in a whole lot of trouble people are
really struggling people
losing their jobs their income is going
down there's a growing gap between the
very rich and everybody else
what's your sense of the economy and he
said oh the economy is doing really good
and year after year and this is really
astounding and a bit aggravating year
after year we heard from the bush
administration that from their
perspective the economy was doing great
now
explain to me how they could believe the
economy was doing great when the middle
class was collapsing and we were getting
closer and closer and closer to the edge
of a major global financial crisis
because for them it was great and that's
the problem now 2006 was the record year
of bonuses on wall street 2006. now
between 2006 and 2007 foreclosures in
this country just between march 2006 and
march 2007 foreclosures increased by 47
percent so it isn't like there was an
information coming in that would
indicate there was a tremendous problem
brewing and it's not like someone like
uh treasury secretary at the time hank
paulson who had been a ceo of goldman
sachs and understands numbers could not
have seen that but the fact is goldman
and other firms were paying out record
bonuses that year because they were
manufacturing as things were getting
weaker and they knew this they were
manufacturing an even greater amount of
these assets because they sort of wanted
to turn it all in and sort of take
profits as much as they could as soon as
they could because they actually knew
things weren't going to continue to stay
wall street knew there was a less
trading going on in some of these which
is why they were created more these
ultimately these toxic assets because
wall street knew that the game might be
up and so they pay themselves well they
created these assets and paulson should
have known this the fed should have
known this because on the other side of
all of this was declining
loans
was increasing foreclosures increasing
defaults this was real data yeah i got
to tell you from my end of the street so
to speak
sitting in the congress and hearing
these guys talk
it's like they were living in another
world
where you had bernanke himself who now
chairman of the fed who for a while was
the major economic advisor to the
president
i didn't hear anything coming from these
guys to say wait a second
we got to do something because we don't
act we may have the collapse of finance
in the united states and around the
world where were they at this point well
let's say i don't think they were
looking at this date or if they were
they were choosing to to ignore it or to
act optimistic because that served a
political agenda because you don't you
don't want to be the party in power when
the crisis happens so if you can sort of
push it along and sort of will it to not
happen and sort of give this and this is
how i look at it from the outside but
give an optimistic spin on things even
with negative data coming in you can
sort of push it on to to really the next
guy or the next administration or the
next federal business almost got out he
almost got it
few months if if it happened just in the
beginning of 2009 it would have changed
but the reality was all this stuff was
brewing
talk about for a moment uh this whole
business of deregulation my
understanding is that during a ten year
period
uh wall street spent uh about five
billion dollars
uh pressuring uh congress through
lobbying efforts through campaign
contributions to deregulated away with
glass-steagall
etc etc
what impact did all of that deregulation
allowing these mergers to take place
have on the ensuing financial uh
collapse well the repeal of
glass-steagall was really the catalyst
for what ultimately became a decade
later the collapse and and actually what
even became a few years later some enron
and worldcom and the other scandals that
we like to forget about because they
were all predicated on the idea of
merging and acquiring and banking
institutions becoming not just bigger
which they were doing there was a record
merger spree as well
leading into the repeal of
glass-steagall which which happened
almost a year ago today on november 12
1999 was when glass-steagall was
repealed and i voted against them and
you know i bought it against the let me
let me make the record clear well not
only did you vote against it i think you
also said that all the things that would
happen to consumers to mergers all of
that being a bit facetious but it did
happen yeah i mean all of the warning
signs
unfortunately came into fruition and the
reason for that
is that when banks merge and when
concentration changes so that the more
powerful ones have more deposits and
control more loans and control more
actual capital
they can churn it they can trade it they
can speculate with it because it is
there
and so
that's what ultimately caused the crisis
is that you had extra capital and extra
access to to consumers that you could
use real money and real loans and real
assets and turn them into something that
ultimately became a crisis all right now
i'm gonna
move you a little bit
and ask you a question here's an
interesting question
during those years when i was a member
of the financial services committee
every alan greenspan would come out and
after everybody rolled out the red
carpet and
god had walked into the chamber there
um and you cannot believe believe me
there was and and greenspan gave forth
his libertarian philosophy that the best
thing that we can possibly do is do away
with all government regulation and we
allow these guys on wall street to do
anything they want somehow this wealth
they're going to do all the right things
and it's going to create great wealth
for all the americans some of us of
course did not believe it but
unfortunately a majority
of the people believed in now here's my
political question for you which is
interesting and i think maybe says a
whole lot about our political system
the president who originally appointed
alan greenspan was the first president
bush
and he was reappointed now and the first
president bush was considered to be
maybe a center-right type of politician
he was reappointed and you know
greenspan is an extreme right-wing guy
by a liberal democrat named bill clinton
then you had some years later mr
bernanke is appointed by kind of a
right-wing republican named george w
bush
and
a liberal democrat wants to reappoint
him
what's going on people i generally
believe that there's a difference in
opinion between
a first bush and a clinton and a second
bush and an obama how does this happen
well first of all there hasn't been
really a change in any of the
regulations that come onto the financial
world between
any any of those two administration
changes unfortunately we hope there will
be back that one up let me back that one
up because she's raising a very
interesting point and maybe i speak as
an independent here who's not a democrat
or republican but what you're
essentially saying that while there are
differences obviously every day between
democrats and republicans are these kind
of key financial issues about how we
deal with wall street and who's head of
the fed that does not seem to be a heck
of a lot of difference is that kind of
what you're suggesting it seems like one
of the the least partisan things in in
washington because if if you look at
just the sheer regulations that were
passed the continuation of fed chairman
under under the changes from republican
to democrat both times um there isn't a
tremendous amount of difference in fact
there's more financial deregulation done
under clinton than there was underneath
and the first secretary of the treasury
then secretary of the treasury
yes who happened to have also been a
co-ceo at one point of goldman sachs
which is a whole other issue this
revolving door from wall street and it
so happens from goldman sachs into the
presidency um whether or not there is a
democrat or a republican paulson was
also it
polson who was when i was there he would
he was he was my boss
yes he was head of goldman sachs became
treasury secretary he was a republican
under bush ii who was a republican but
bob rubin of course was a democrat under
clinton who was a democrat but they were
both for the same deregulation um you
could have almost interchanged them at
any point in time
and gotten the same result let's throw
in tim geithner where was tim in the
midst of all this well well tim of
course well if we talk about where he
was in terms of the ballot and
everything else he was head of the new
york fed which had a very tight
relationship with wall street it is
through the new york fed that first of
all most of the bailout money came but
also historically that has had the
tightest relationship and a revolving
board door between the board of the new
york fed and leaders from wall street
right now for example jamie dimon has a
senior position on the board of the new
york fed he runs a large large bank
jpmorgan chase he succeeded sandy weil
who was running citigroup which was you
know so there's this constant revolving
door and so if you're running if you're
president of the new york fed uh you
have perhaps the closer relationship to
wall street than almost the chairman of
the fed you know that even a ben
bernanke would have while we're on the
fed
jump into the fed let me
let me um mention something to you
uh last year
i had
ben bernanke came before the budget
committee
and
this is during the whole bailout process
and so forth and as you know and i want
to get into this at some length
at the very least we know that the fed
lent out
over two trillion dollars in zero
interest loans
to financial institutions so i said to
uh chairman bernanke i said you know can
you tell the american people
who got the money it's you know you're
putting their money at risk
most of us would like to know you know
some degree of transplant who got the
money and he said it was pretty amazing
he said
i'm not going to tell you
two trillion dollars of money and you're
not going to tell the american people
by the time that day was over we had
introduced legislation to make him tell
us and but how
talk a little bit about that how can
a head of the fed
say with a straight face i'm not going
to tell the american people with two
trillion dollars of their money at risk
has gone
yeah i know it it was astonishing
because i think at the same um moment or
a few minutes later he said it would
actually be counterproductive right to
tell people and i remember the word
counterproductive as a how do you
possibly get to that term and i guess
the reasoning
besides the fact there's a whole lot of
banks who don't want that information
disclosed because that would indicate
how weak they actually truly are even
with the bailout and with the subsidies
from the federal government and i think
bernanke was basically using that face
and trying to somehow justify it by
saying well if people knew if people
actually knew how weak their banks might
be we would have this catastrophic run
on the banks it would be breadlines 1933
all over again and the world would
totally collapse as we know it and i
think that whether he believes that or
not because
i i personally think that had we
disclosed this information from the
get-go from before the bailout became as
expensive as it became because banks
didn't know what each other held no one
trusted anyone and that's why credit
tightened up had we actually had full
disclosure of books back then of assets
back then of what the fed might have
been looking at back then we could have
avoided spending a whole lot of money in
this bailout but i think by the time he
got to that moment he was so entrenched
in the idea that if anyone knows what
actually went on it would create and it
would it would create a lot of anger but
that i think was probably his actual
worry but he's what he acted as if his
worry was is that it would create a run
on no that's exactly what he did say uh
but i i think and by the way we took
that
concept of the need for transparency at
the fed to the floor of the senate
during the um
budget uh discussion and we won in a
bipartisan vote because i think it's
very hard for the average member of the
senate or the average american to say
excuse me you're putting two trillion
dollars of my money at risk and you're
not telling me who got it
maybe we need a 1-800 number everybody
in america can get zero interest loans
and you don't have what do you think
exactly if everyone gets zero interest
loans we'd have a very different america
but i'll tell you to one thing just on
the back of that the new york fed
actually is extending more money than
and had more open plans to the banking
system than the fed fed we're talking
about the 2 trillion on the feds book
ultimately there was about 6 trillion
worth of facilities created much of
which went through the new york fed's
book and they don't necessarily
aggregate them all so there's a lot of
other stuff that's not even near being
looked at and who knows about this stuff
you know some of it is it's
it's quasi public not not what
collateral has been posted and what
banks have received how much money that
we we are trying you are trying to to
get to the bottom of that information
but when those facilities were open when
when they were created it wasn't like
there was a big media press release but
there is information that you can kind
of see through the you know digging
through the websites and i did that i
mean you can do it and you can write a
book most of us probably no you can't do
it normally there's nowhere you can go
on the fed website or the treasury
website and to say yeah what did you
spend where did you spend it how much is
it worth now when is it coming back
there is no report that exists like that
all right now let me ask you i'm going
to put you on the spot you ready
all right
based on his record uh as head of the
new york fed and now uh
well let me get to bernanke uh do you
think
president obama
brought forth bernanke to be reappointed
to be ahead of the fed do you think that
was a good decision
i think bernanke made a lot of mistakes
during this this whole crisis leading up
to it in terms of of not looking at the
information that other people could have
looked at and that there were economists
telling him about but more than that
more than that the fed has the ability
to reject mergers the fed has the
ability to deny applications for banks
like goldman sachs that are investment
banks and morgan stanley to become bank
holding companies which makes them more
publicly
accessible to the fed in terms of
receiving funds or receiving any sort of
subsidies or perks from the fed it's
it's the fed's job
um to be prudent about that and when ben
bernanke was in that seat he didn't say
for a moment we shouldn't have a merger
between merrill lynch and bank of
america he didn't say we shouldn't have
a merger between wells fargo macovia he
didn't say why are we backing bear
stearns assets
in order to have them merge into
jpmorgan chase he didn't say any of that
he didn't say wait a minute goldman
sachs you know what you can't become a
bank because you have too much risk and
we don't want the government's money to
back your risk he was in the position to
do that that was one of his jobs and he
didn't do that so i believe by not doing
that he's actually shoved a really big
second coming of the crisis
maybe delayed a little bit but but
created a much less stable landscape
than we even had before
last year's crisis
so you're not one of those folks to say
thank god because of that decisive
action and the bailout man i we are over
the hump now good times are coming you
don't accept that right now there are
some good times coming for some banks
because they have federal capital that
they can use to go back into taking
risky positions and trading and their
stock is up and their profits are up and
their bonuses are up but in actuality
there's more risk and there's more
consolidation and there's more power
amongst a fewer group of banks than
there was before the crisis so was there
a crisis averted i think it was delayed
that that that's the way i look at it i
think there are other decisions that
could have been made last fall that
wouldn't have involved putting trillions
of dollars of public capital
behind that banking system without
changing dramatically the landscape of
that backing of that banking system
as we speak
president obama has indicated that those
financial institutions that were bailed
out uh he's going to cut back very
substantially on the kind of ceo
compensation but the other financial
institutions like goldman sachs they're
running as quickly as they can back to
before the crisis
tell me about hutzpah if you like how do
a group of people who cause this
terrible crisis and suffering for tens
of millions of people in this country
after getting bailed out by the
taxpayers of this country go back to
huge compensation packages and bonuses
go back to exactly where they came from
how do they do that they feel incredibly
ridiculously entitled to doing that they
go back to their offices you know great
crisis averted let's go and make money
which they are goldman sachs is on track
to make 23 billion dollars in bonuses
that year that's a couple more
a couple more billion dollars than they
made in the year before the crisis
they're actually doing better than they
were before um and it's it's really this
this mentality of what we do here is
intense and it's important and it's this
moment and it's this trade and it's this
transaction and what happens on the
outside it's their fault it's their
fault for not being us you know it's you
know again as an elected official people
sometimes criticize appropriately
appropriately people in congress living
in a uh inside the beltway mentality not
knowing what's going on i could tell you
that in my state of vermont all over
this country there is fury there is rage
against these people and apparently
they're not interested they they don't
care because nothing has happened to
them
you know you know that the rage and the
righteous rage of the of the public
doesn't affect what they get paid and it
hasn't affected how they operate um they
said at their last quarterly earnings
limit they are going to continue to do
what they do they they're very open
about it they're not even trying to
necessarily hide this information on
that note uh we're going to take a break
with nomie prinz whose excellent book it
takes some pillage
uh explains i think to a lot of people
what has happened in the last year and
what's likely to happen in the future
we'll be back in a minute
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with nomie prinz and
senator bernie sanders in just a moment
book tv sunday three new books by and
about sarah palin including a book
signing with the former vice
presidential candidate and alaskan
governor the weekly standards matthew
continetti on the persecution of sarah
palin and reporters scott conroy and
shoshanna walsh on sarah from alaska
stephen gillen details the transfer of
power following the kennedy
assassination and lbj's first hours as
president
and the u.s financial crisis on
afterwards nomi prinz former managing
director of goldman sachs on it takes a
pillage she's interviewed by vermont
senator bernie sanders
find the entire schedule online at
booktv.org
including our four day holiday book tv
weekend starting thanksgiving morning
afterwards with nomie prinz and senator
bernie sanders continues
we're continuing our discussion with
normally prince who's the author of it
takes a
pillage
normally it seems to i think many
americans that we're living
uh in a in a
world deeply divided a nation deeply
divided you got a wall street up there
you went you used the phrase a sense of
entitlement these guys make hundreds of
millions a year occasionally a
billionaire you got hedge funds
operating they're doing that thing
and meanwhile you have the rest of the
country which has seen in many instances
really deep declines in people's
standard of living increase in poverty
people losing their health insurance so
you've got wall street what we call main
street
um
what's the connection
between
the two why does wall street get bailed
out and get richer while people on main
street lose their jobs and their health
insurance and get poorer what's that
about how do we turn that around i think
for one thing wall street has a tighter
connection to certain people in
washington and much more money to lobby
and everything else and so there's
there's a more there's more of a sense
of keeping what they have and and
getting more there's no such thing as an
ethical wall street right now there's no
such thing as we're going to stop
ourselves from making as much money as
we possibly can because that is there
let me introduce you just to mention
this thing which to me is kind of
astounding but that's the way it is you
would you might have thought
that the people on wall street who
caused this severe economic crisis
that's one of them one of these guys
might have gone on tv and said you know
americans i'm really sorry our greed got
away from us and i know all of the
suffering that we've caused i'm sorry
and we're going to change your way i
haven't heard that no there's no
contrition there's no awareness there's
no connectivity to the rest of of the
country because honestly the people that
really run these firms have almost no
contact
like literally they just don't have a
lot of contact with with real
individuals but the result of of the
crisis that we all saw last year in the
bailout and just the decision to open a
lot of federal funding and subsidies and
guarantees and cheap loans and
everything to wall street as if that
would somehow trickle down to the rest
of main street
it almost had the opposite effect it
kind of it kind of fortified uh the
standing people in wall street and the
banks that survived to kind of continue
to do what they're doing i mean let me
talk to you to say that what you said is
exactly true the line i voted i should
be clear i voted against the ballot but
um the line was this is not a bailout
for wall street this is a bailout for
main street and we're working day and
night to save main street but you don't
agree with that assertion well not only
did i agree with it back then as you
didn't but i also don't agree with any
of the numbers that we have shown that
that have legitimately indicated that
this hasn't been the case credit did not
loosen in fact when the bailout was when
tarp was passed and that was only one
component of the bailout in the
emergency economic stabilization act
there was a little teeny piece of that
act that also allowed the fed to pay out
more interest on reserve money that the
banks were keeping with the fed so while
the banks are getting money they're
actually incentivized to not do anything
with it while the treasury secretary and
others are saying that this will somehow
loosen credit for the american people it
didn't credit is tighter now
and as a result unemployment is higher
now there's a direct correlation between
credit i'm not talking about crazy
credit and you know people sort of
running up but basically the idea of
credit for small businesses for medium
businesses for individuals because once
those companies can't make payroll they
close they fire people they don't have
pot they have nowhere else to go and and
also out of this crisis the smaller
banks are continuing to fail in sizable
numbers we've had 99 closures just this
year of smaller banks while the bigger
banks are getting all of this capital so
even in the banking system there's
there's a wider gap and those smaller
banks feed a lot of the smaller loans
and the smaller businesses and the
individuals so there's this total knock
on effect not down effect really of the
bottom part of the country and that's
why foreclosures are now at a record
quarter again not last year this year or
at a record quarter this year there's
more defaults this year there's more
delinquencies this year people are
struggling more this is after the
bailout a year after
yes and unemployment national
unemployment was 5.8
preceding that period of the crisis last
fall and now it is almost 10 percent and
that doesn't even include the fact that
in most cities in urban areas 139
different urban areas have double digit
unemployment from 15
15 before the crisis so not only has
this crisis not held main street it's
actually hurt main street so the bailout
has hurt main street
all right
um what do we do
uh
what do we do
to create financial institutions that
are part of the united states of america
that don't live behind a wall of greed
and selfishness and irresponsibility and
illegal behavior what do we do to
have financial institutions play a role
in providing credit so that
entrepreneurs and business people can
create real goods and services and
create meaningful jobs
what would you suggest that we do well
first of all we have to look at the
money that was given to the system and
because we didn't put the government
didn't put any strings attached to it we
actually have to start to attach some
strings and say you know what you said
you needed this
you said you were going to lose some
credit you didn't here's what you
actually need to do you need to take a
proportion of your capital and there's
all this discussion now and there should
be about banks having more capital so
that they can actually control their
risk so the government doesn't have to
come in and subsidize it but at the same
time i think some of that should be
divided out and more capital should be
given to those small businesses and more
capital should be made available and
renegotiation should be much easier
what's happening now is that not only is
credit not loosened but if someone wants
to renegotiate a home that's about to be
foreclosed upon and renegotiate their
mortgage you can't get you can't get
anyone on the phone the process is so
exhausting and so cumbersome and
documents get lost because there's just
no accountability along the way remember
these little loans
became these many assets and so up here
you can't even find where the actual
deed was to a property and i think you
need to basically take a look at that
and make institutions more accountable
and there's a good reason to do that now
because they are sitting on capital
funding there's almost more of a reason
now to come in and say okay look you had
yours now here's what you need to do
ah use the word accountability on wall
street that is a four-letter word
they don't like accountability but it
will never come
openly
lloyd blank finds leo goldman he's not
going to like come to washington be like
you know what
we're paying out 23 billion bonuses this
year
i'm going to cut that i'm going to just
cut it down to a measly 15 billion and
i'm going to give the rest of that money
into some fund that's going to help
small businesses or some fund that's
going to give credit or or or advisors
or pay for them to help people
renegotiate their mortgages i'm going to
do that because i feel bad that will
never happen
and and so it needs to be legislated
somehow it needs to be legislation and
particularly because they've had public
assistance almost it's almost it should
be easier now
to ask more of wall street given that it
has received so much more from
standpoint of the federal government
even than it was beforehand right
um and i'll tell you one of the things
as a senator i hear a lot about people
can unders literally can't understand
how they're bailing out these financial
institutions and then they end up paying
25 or 30 percent interest rates
on their
credit cards
which in the old days used to be
considered usury
but now is just the cost of their own
business
it's it's it's the fees on credit cards
it's these arbitrary fees that get
slapped on checking accounts and savings
accounts even in all sorts of things
because now
it's really a byproduct of
glass-steagall appeal to some extent to
go back a little bit explain for a
moment i'm not sure all of the viewers
know what glass-steagall was about what
the repeal meant okay well in 1929 we
had a tremendous stock market crash in
in the united states which was followed
by the great depression and in 1933 um
when fdr was the president when he came
in basically 1932 but in 1933
took office in the first couple days
what he did was he closed the banks
because it was noted that it was the
bank's fault it wasn't like people
spontaneously stopped paying it was that
credit tightened even back then
speculation was rampant even back then
products were were being created with
nothing inside of them back then the
same sorts of things were happening and
that was because banks could take the
deposits of consumers the deposits of
the population and borrow against them
it's called leverage on wall street in
order to speculate and trade and they
did and so what glass-steagall was about
was saying you know what you cannot have
a financial institution that both has
the right and the access to population
deposits and makes loans to the
population and have them use that to bet
and gamble and speculate that that just
doesn't make any sense in particular the
federal government cannot possibly
be able to back all of that risk it does
it's all kind of a black box and so what
glass-steagall does what it separated
banks out it said you know what if you
want to be a bank and you want to deal
with customers and you can get those
deposits your commercial bank you go
over here we will back you and the fdic
was created at the same time in order to
back the deposits of consumers and of of
individuals in the united states
investment banks you know you are on
your own you can do whatever you want
well maybe not totally whatever although
that has been what happened but you can
you can speculate you can trade you can
do whatever but you know what you we
don't have your back we're not gonna
back that risk the taxpayers are not
gonna bail you out when you fail right
and that was just so logical and the
fdic won't be there um to to back you or
to insure your debt which is kind of
what they're doing now with goldman
sachs and morgan stanley it just it just
won't happen because it makes no sense
because then we came to the 80s and the
90s and people like alan greenspan and
bob rubin proceeded to tell the congress
why that was
last week was just a terrible
destructive idea yeah from 1995 before
four years before it were appealed i
remember robert rubin was talking about
this notion that we couldn't be
competitive as a nation if our banks
weren't allowed to do whatever it is
they do that the 1933 glass-steagall act
was antiquated it was old it didn't work
in today's modern world of finance and
you just can't constrict these because
we're going to be at a loss actually the
united states will actually decline in
sort of financial supremacy if we are
not going to allow our banks to do what
all the other banks are doing so the
congress against my vote repealed
glass-steagall what was the immediate
result of that the immediate result was
a wave of mergers there were mergers
that actually preceded glass-steagall
such as city group and travelers there
was an idea where insurance companies
could be apart now commercial banks and
investment banks could be a part of
commercial banks and everything started
merging together so there was a first
wave of mergers that happened right
after glass-steagall and lobbying that
year actually went down because laughing
was up the year before lobby money went
down so that was that was a small
temporary respite on that but um and and
then what happened is there was more
consolidation for a decade of the
banking industry so that you went from a
situation where
the top banks had 20 of the assets and
deposits to now the top banks have 50
and and so you just you just continue to
concentrate the industry and concentrate
it with more risk added to it and now
you have these banks using deposits
again as capital to speculate and trade
just like they did back in the 20s and
that takes us to the issue of too big to
fail exactly and what too big to fail
means is
is that if a
huge financial institution goes under
it's going to take half the economy with
it
and then dust the justification for
having to bail them out
now it seemed to me and i said this on
the floor of the senate that if an
institution is too big to fail
it seems to me that it's too big to
exist
right i
but since the bailout we have not seen a
breakup of these large institutions
quite the country i don't know paul
volcker among others has raised that
issue what do you think about this too
big to fail what should we be doing i
think we should be going back to the the
current glass-steagall we should be
separating these banks back out again we
shouldn't have gotten from a crisis into
a situation where there are now fewer
banks controlling more assets in the
country
which goes back to what the fed was
doing in terms of blessing those mergers
so we have a situation where we need to
separate them out we need to separate
out again the consumer deposits and
loans and assets from the speculative
investment banking and trading because
what we have right now not only are
those banks the big banks bigger jp
morgan used to be just well just jp
morgan chase which had a lot of mergers
in it to begin with but then having
achieved the acquisition of bear stearns
it adds a really risky investment bank
washington mutual it adds a whole bunch
of consumer deposits so now it's just
this bigger animal floating on more risk
and that risk was what we saw in their
profits last quarter there again no
secret about this the only reason they
made money last quarter is not because
consumers are doing better consumers
continue to post losses because they
continue to hurt where they made money
was in trading so i think we have to
totally take that risk out of the
government's responsibility to back
which means you have to break up these
banks so if people want to speculate
they can go speculation but they're on
their own
but they're not going to get through
exactly by the government and if
banks want to make loans to people real
people
we will back them up is what you're
saying and and that makes so much sense
because not only will you back them up
you will understand the risk you know
exactly what you're dealing with
i i don't i don't think there's a lot of
people in in in washington to sit there
and look at what a cr
an actual credit derivative prospectus
or or a a transaction
you don't and it's complicated and i
think i think to some extent it's
actually not as complicated as it's made
out to be but it's certainly arcane and
to anyone who's not you know in the
trenches and and that's why it gets
that's why wall street gets away with
creating a lot of the securities it
creates it uses that lack of
understanding i think to its benefit let
me switch gear for a moment i i i think
the average american after the bailout
during that period
wanted
to understand how the crisis occurred
who
was responsible for it and how we hold
those people accountable who's going to
jail
who's apologizing
we really haven't seen a whole lot of
that in fact one of the issues that we
fought for i-44 was a real investigation
for cora you explain to folks what the
court the core investigation was in
1932. well in 1932 pakora who who was
the assistant d.a in new york basically
was asked to undergo an investigation of
predominantly the banks by the senate
banking by the senate banking committee
um
to basically look at how what the
practices of the banks that were
happening at that moment contributed to
the crash and contributed to the
depression and that was and and and what
he found was this idea of speculating on
the back of nothing or on the uh
jp morgan and these other guys morgan
ahead
and and and he basically really
hammered them to explain exactly what
their practices were um and exactly how
they inflated value and exactly what
they used what what deposits or money
they used in order to do that and it was
so clear from that
so clear that this was something that
was a direct contributor of the crisis
it wasn't that and foreclosures were
high then too historically for that
period but that wasn't the crisis that
was just a manifestation of what wall
street was doing the little individual
home in in vermont or in stockton
california or wherever the the
foreclosures on those are very very
difficult for the individuals but they
are not what brought the system down
what brought the system down is all of
the speculation that the wall street
mostly investment banks created on the
back of those loans but the american
people really have not gotten that kind
of explanation of what happened they
haven't had the leading the guys who who
caused this problem in front of the tv
cameras answering hard questions have
they that and that's that's really a
good thing to do i mean some of these
guys have been in front of various
committees mostly talking about their
bonuses and and there's a good thing and
a bad thing about that certainly the
bonuses are
agreed just particularly now after the
crisis and with federal funding beneath
them but if we just focus on the bonuses
we lose sight of the practices that
actually contributed to the bonuses so
you need to do both and i agree it would
be really nice if you even got these
people in front to say they were sorry
but i mean i but even in addition to
that i think the american people are
owed an explanation of what happened
and then
the understanding that the congress is
trying to make sure that this doesn't
happen again
but what i think you're implying is
these guys are very moving very
aggressively to bring us back to exactly
where we were before the
the financial collapse well absolutely
because one of the things that
contributed to them being allowed or
being able to create these assets out of
loans is that money was very cheap money
was very cheap under greenspan actually
in 2001 in early 2002 as a result you
have
more esoteric loans being given out
because banks are getting this money
cheap and they need to figure out how
they get more out of it so they extract
it from subprime or they extract it by
creating an asset or they find some way
to create
money from nothing or money from cheap
money and now we have the exact same
situation rates are very low and in
particular banking system is getting
like zero to quarter of a percent loans
from the fed
so we're in a recreation of that
scenario just on a much grander scale
let me ask you uh another question
changing gear again a little bit um
there is
growing i think interest in the fed
itself which as you've indicated today
is an enormously important institution
but a very secretive
institution
uh you can argue that certainly at
particular moments
ben bernanke the chairman of the fed is
more powerful than president obama
he controls more money
he
controls the ability to create money and
that is a very powerful ability talk a
little bit about
the fed how does somebody like the
chairman of the fed get all of this
power what do we know about the fed
should there be more transparency in the
fed and i i have to admit that i am the
author of the senate bill which calls
for a gao audit of the fed to do all of
these things a little prejudiced and
asking this question but i think whether
you're you know you're a conservative or
you're a progressive as i am
people just kind of shake in their heads
that an institution with so much power
can operate in so much a secrecy what do
you think and and also subsidize so much
of a private sector um and and reside in
washington and i i think i think to a
large extent the fed in this particular
situation has totally overstepped even
its mandate and even what it was
designed to do the fed is supposed to on
a regular working day um you know
control or basically set interest rate
it's supposed to set something called
monetary policy it's supposed to raise
rates lower rates depending on whether
or not money is easy or harder to to
flush into the general system be used
for credit be used for businesses or
what have you um and and they do that
it's also supposed to oversee these
commercial banks it's supposed to make
decisions as to whether they are allowed
to become bigger if there are risks
within them it is actually supposed to
go in and say something um the fact is
it doesn't because it has such a tight
relationship with wall street with the
banking system that it's almost like
telling on your brother all right do you
happen to know how many people there are
in the fed how these guys appointed
um well
there's there's 12 federal reserve banks
um they're they're appointed basically
people are appointed through those banks
so for example the new york fed um sort
of appoints people from
its back door which is which is wall
street and therefore you have a board of
the fed um which which controls to some
extent how this money goes back to where
they came from um to one extent last
year stephen friedman who was chairman
of the board of the fed at the the new
york fed where tim geithner was
president was at the same time on the
board of directors at goldman sachs um
so you're basically you've got your foot
on the place that you can get money from
and you've got the foot on in the door
of the place that gets
benefits another expression for that
it's called an enormous conflict of
interest it is a tremendous cost from
day one the fed was a conflict of
interest from from day one particularly
the new york fed and i mean the
relationship is that the new york fed is
the most powerful of those 12 feds but
from day one that's a conflict there
should not be members of that board
on the board who are in any way related
to the banks that receive
any kind of money from from the fed
otherwise call it a bank let it be a
private bank but but don't let it have
access to the ability to create public
money
now how do in your judgment these guys
with so much
power playing literally with trillions
of dollars
get away without the kind of public
scrutiny i i made the point you know
when you're on the floor of the senate
you're fighting for 28 million dollars
there could be a six-hour debate oh you
don't need that money it's only f
meanwhile very quietly these guys say oh
well we're going to provide trillions of
dollars in zero interest loans no
discussion nobody knows who gets it
right how do we what's going on there
well i i think to some extent um and and
you're different but at the time i think
there was an idea of well the economy is
going out of control it's firing
downward something needs to be done and
and for some reason the fed will know
what to do and so there wasn't as much
question there was so much debate over
the bailout over the 700 billion dollars
and there wasn't any questioning at the
time over what's been going on on the
fed's balance sheet and i think to some
extent there needs to be and and
certainly the auditing bills are the way
to do that and and extend opening what
they're doing to the public is a way to
do that there needs to be
a required
accountability to congress because it's
public money
period how do you live in a democratic
society where public officials are
supposed to be held accountability
without with without any kind of
knowledge yeah it's it's it's it's it's
wrong i think i think what we've seen
out of this this scenario in particular
is that the fed should not be
an sort of isolated private secretive
organization if it's going to
be involved in huge
raising of public funds in order to
subsidize a private industry it needs to
publicly disclose what it's doing um it
is bizarre that that so much
conversation is given over 28 million
editions to help anything he almost
think it's like a shell game that we're
going to have all these great things
over here
i mean there are great debates literally
right on the floor of the senate about a
hundred thousand dollar earmark that
goes on hour after hour after hour
and then you get trillions of dollars
being lent out here with no discussion
whatsoever at one point the amount of
money that the fed had on offer to the
banking industry was eight trillion
dollars now it's six it is six trillion
dollars worth of open possibility i'm
not saying every bank has used all that
we don't know but but there is an open
possibility of six trillion dollars
worth of money
i mean that's just it's staggering it is
staggering and then you also debate over
stimulus package or of extending
unemployment benefits or so and the
numbers aren't even in the same zip code
all right let me
uh we're rapidly running out of time but
this has been a fascinating discussion
and i'm glad your
your father made your major in
mathematics or something it
sounds like you used that background
very productively
don't we conclude our discussion um
where do you think the president and the
congress
should go what would you like to see
them do right now well first thing i
think they should have a real debate
over to this idea of too big to fail i
think by simply increasing capital
limits and having these too big to fail
banks be sort of watched better um it is
not the way to go because you're
watching something you don't understand
i think we need to break them up
reinstate glass signal make them smaller
you know and and i think that will have
the added benefit of reducing risk in
the system because then we know we're
actually dealing with um and then you
can control compensation which is
created out of the risk taking and out
of the bonuses that come from those
profits because you're you're subduing
the risk in the system and yes bankers
won't make as much make as much money
but that's okay
no me we're running out of time but i
think the main point that you have made
maybe the most important point of many
many very good important points
is that we can't look at wall street as
something separate from
the middle class and working families of
this country that we can't continue a
process where these guys live in their
own world do not
invest in anything of productive value
while the middle class continues to
shrink and unemployment goes up that
they've got to play a different
different kind of a role exactly and we
can't make it up to them that that's the
key thing um president obama's talking
about raising small business loan caps
and and that is good but if the banks
don't want to extend the loans it
doesn't matter that the caps are higher
so there has to be an attachment there
has to be an actual
legislative attachment to
making this behavior occur
all right on that note let me thank uh
no me prince for being with us the book
is an excellent book and i can't think
of a subject matter which is more
important for us to be engaged in nami
thanks very much for being with us thank
you very much senator
book tv sunday for more best-selling
titles go to latimes.com
book tv is back live at the los angeles
times 15th annual festival of books you
can see some of the the uh
tents and some of the booths that are
set up here about 130 000 people are
expected over the next two days we will
give you five and a half hours of live
coverage today five and a half hours of
live coverage tomorrow author panels and
author call-ins the c-span bus is also
here and you can see some folks are
gathered out in front because we're
passing out book bags and book tv pens
so if you're in the area come on down
and see us and about 20 feet from where
the bus is is our temporary call-in set
and now joining us on the set is nomi
prince whose most recent book is it
takes a pillage behind the bailouts
bonuses and backroom deals from
washington to wall street this was
written 2009
nomi prince the senate is currently
working on financial regulation matters
what do you think about what the u.s
senate is doing well i think they appear
to be trying but unfortunately if you
really dig into how banks operate
and i worked at them and i've written
extensively about them unfortunately the
financial reform package as it stands
now the bill that senator dodd has put
forth so far
will really not
get to the core of the kinds of risks
that banks put into the general overall
economy
you say you used to work back she used
to be a managing director at goldman
sachs yes i was and what does that mean
to be a managing director what did you
work on well basically i worked on the
beginning of the credit derivatives that
the cdo's you know a portion of these
toxic assets that blew up and blew out
into the rest of the economy when i
worked on them i left in 2002
um they were predominantly made up of
high-yield or junk bonds they weren't
made up of the subprime loans and
individuals kind of homes beneath them
that they ultimately came to be but
that's what wall street does it takes
a method
it takes like the crust of a pie and
then it fills it with different kinds of
fillings as those become available and
makes money out of them
let's put up the numbers so we can get
right to calls with nomi prins it takes
a pillage 202 is the area code 585-3885
east and central time zones 585-3886
if you live in the mountain pacific time
zones also you can send her a tweet
we're checking our tweets so you can if
you have a question via tweet
twitter.com
tv is our twitter address
know me prince you mentioned cdo's
collateralized debt obligations
uh
junk bonds
where did all this stuff come from i
mean
why are we talking about that and not
talking about profits and and
econ 101 where does econ 101 fit into
all this well that's that's a good
question the cdos are these these
packages of weird things that became
part of the public consciousness when
the financial crisis happened in 2008
were really uh constructed back in the
late 80s michael milliken the junk bond
king and drexel burnham lambert which
which disintegrated after that without a
bailout disintegrated without a bailout
important difference between that and in
a couple decades later and and it's and
what wall street does with the bigger
banks the more uh speculative banks do
or in their speculative components of
the big banks is they say all right what
can we stuff into and re-engineer and
rejigger and everything else into new
packages whatever we call them cdo's
just it's just a name
and make money out of them by slicing
them dicing them selling them marketing
them to you know little pension funds
and
in iowa to little towns in iceland and
basically
take money up front throw the risk out
to the world
and not care about what happens to it
they are
risk
transfer
products they always work
and there's a lot of money to be made
out of are they marketed that way is it
all clear and how regulated are they now
they're they're not regulated securities
that that's one of the problems with
with the market despite the problems
it's had over the years um it is not
regulated there's no exchange that says
all right well here's the cdo here's
what's in it here's what you can check
here's how it's trading on any given day
they're so tailor-made
for that deal for those clients for
those backers each time they're created
that there isn't um an exchange there
isn't regulation the regulations are
regulators are so far behind considering
it and even in these bills that have
been proposed by the house and the
senate there's nothing in there that
really gets at making them more open so
so almost anything goes if you want to
bet against the weather and i want to
bet for the weather and we go to goldman
sachs and say you know do something
create something on both sides goldman
will say okay well i'll structure a
piece the weather here in you know
brazil here in africa whatever we'll
stick it together you take a bet she'll
take the bet we'll make money on both
sides and that's really how because they
do the structuring they do the
structuring and they do the trading they
put it together they sell it so is that
what happened with john paulson he came
to goldman sachs and said hey
i want to put this package together and
i want to bet against it
yeah for the most part and and and most
of that is is perfectly legal within
unfortunately the structure that we have
is it important is it an important
economic thing to do does it does it
help the national economy in any way no
it is purely a betting mechanism um
there's there's no there's certainly no
help that that paulson gay paulson
took a bet that the housing market was
going to go down uh frankly at that
perfectly legitimate to do it's
legitimate to do there were many writers
including myself who thought there were
problems with the market and things were
looking too good to be true so so that
in itself wasn't the problem the problem
was that he came to goldman said i want
to do this structure i want to select
the things that you're going to buy from
me but i'm going to bet against you and
so that that's kind of again sort of
legal because
the fact that i'm betting against you
you're still taking the bid on your side
you shouldn't care that i am betting
against you the problem comes in and the
sec charge is going to try to get to
should goldman have disclosed to someone
who bought part of that deal that
paulson not that he was on the other
side they don't have to disclose that
but that he selected some of the
securities and was on the other side
that he was a part of the selection
process which was not disclosed in their
marketing materials and that's going to
be where the case is going to hinge
it takes a pillage nomi prinz first call
up for her comes from richmond virginia
good afternoon richmond please go ahead
with your question
hey um uh i just wanted to ask uh with
the with the huge bailout is there a
danger with that of the devaluation of
the currency
through inflation or whatever
well i think that you know the currency
question is good a lot of people want to
know if any of these problems will
affect the dollar and so far they
haven't and part of the reason why
is because all these assets all of the
transactions all of the marketing was
was very global so so problems that
happened on one side that might have
emanated from the united states where
most of the manufacturing of these
assets were taking place and most of the
bailout and the subsidies to fix the
market were given out um there's still
impacts across the world from having
been involved in those products so on
like
technically the dollar shouldn't remain
as strong by virtue of the fact that we
have and continue to hold so much
money
behind these assets without really
knowing where they went like they didn't
disappear you know a lot of them still
exist they're on books they're being
marked in different ways but that was
exactly how we got into this problem so
having money behind them having debt
accumulate behind them having the fed
put out a lot of money behind them only
works when we can pretend they're still
valuable or they become valuable again
the moment that that becomes less clear
is when we have more problems with the
currency even though it's been a
globalized problem i think
norco california good morning to you
please go ahead
norco
california really
important and i think americans are
beginning to figure out
that congress in the country is really
being run by
these big money cartels they even
bankrupted greece and iceland with these
um
cdos and the like uh who who
you know with them embedded in the
government every term who can come
against this cartel and i heard the
money is going to crash this year
at the end at the library all the these
sites say the dollar is going to crash
did you hear anything about that thank
you very much
um well yes as i mentioned to the other
question whether the dollar crashes or
not really depends on whether we get
another revelation that indicates that a
lot of these assets um really aren't
worth what the fed and banks are saying
they are worth which is which is not
impossible i don't believe they're worth
what either of those entities say
they're worth um and we do have a
problem we have a problem that wall
street um and certainly the senior
managers and ceos of wall street have an
incredibly tight relationship with
washington uh you know ceo of goldman
sachs now lloyd blankfein you know and
the firm is being charged by the sec at
the same time um has had many meetings
with obama um you know there are
continued reports um you know before
that of ceos having meetings with the
white house with the treasury secretary
the treasury secretary was involved in
tim geithner was involved in
an enormous portion of the bailout and
the subsidization of the banking
industry without requiring any rules be
changed without putting any strings
attached to not just the tarp money but
all of the bailout money the fed loans
the guarantees all this stuff all these
gifts that were given to wall street and
that the tight relationship between the
people the real
personal relationships is definitely a
problem i don't know how he fixed it i
think we people have to continue to be
you know really pissed off really
angered really vigilant about what we
think of these relationships you know in
our votes in our comments
and everything else because it's not
going to change
by itself
and in fact nomie prince writes if it
seems as if the culture of goldman sachs
pervades the halls of washington that's
because the people of goldman sachs
pervade the halls of washington that's
why despite all the talk in washington
about reforming the system the same
execs who orchestrated its failures were
the ones hobnobbing with the political
leaders of the bush and obama
administrations
yeah i mean that's the that's the thing
to realize here this is not a partisan
situation this is not like bush was bad
obama's good obama's bad bush was good
you know there's a series and in years
of interrelationships um no matter which
party is in power in congress no matter
which party has the presidency um hank
paulson who was the former ceo of
goldman sachs when you were there right
when i was there um of course was a
treasury secretary that was involved in
a portion of the bailout the other
person that is involved in the bailout
tim geithner was working with hank
paulson during that time and so there's
a consistency in approach
related to what goldman people in in
someone like poston wanted robert rubin
another former co-ceo of goldman sachs
before i got there just before i got
there um was very instrumental in
deregulating the banking system to
devolve into the problems that we now
have under clinton's administration so
we have these series of both
uh goldman ties as well as deregulatory
actions no matter who's in control
politically that
culminate to create a situation where we
see crisis and then wonder how the hell
how did that happen
you used to be with bear stearns as well
yes what did you do for them
um again i i
have always been involved in structuring
these types of acid therefore i i i do
know these very well um and i left to
write about them but i wasn't um
uninvolved and when i was at bear
stearns it was in london
and i worked on a lot of different types
of analysis i i worked in
giving suggestions to investors as to
not just buying toxic assets but which
government bonds to buy which
governments were better which were worse
at any particular time and in a lot of
the analytical type of of advice and
i think when you're in
the environment um and that's why i can
look at it from outside and and really
dissect it you don't think about the
ramifications necessarily of the
products you're making there's there's
all of this pressure to make money
there's all this pressure for your area
to make money within the firm for your
firm to make money within the industry
is it constant and it's it's absolutely
constant um and and there's a real it
depends on the day and the firm and
everything else but but everyone is
talking about how to get to the bonus
there's months where this is discussed
towards the end of each year before they
are said everything sort of leads up to
to really making money and you don't
have conversations like oh if i'm
betting and creating a structure that's
going to hurt greece oh my god what's
going to happen to
the greek people it's it just doesn't
really enter into the conversation and
that's a really bad part
of the entire industry and and it
continues to get worse because
everything that's made and all of these
products and all this
risk that's been accumulated there's
there's nothing to counter it the the
rules that are being put forth again in
congress really won't and so we it
continues to just spiral badly and every
so often it has to correct itself for a
second because the market comes down and
buyers go out but they come back in and
then it goes on
next call for nomie prince to cater
good afternoon
yes uh naomi you know that this uh
synthetic studio is nothing more than a
stock future and there's always a seller
on the other hand of that type of trade
so
regardless of whether it's john paulson
or john doe
um itb which was the bank that was on
the other end of that trade
uh actually
they tried to upgrade that investment by
putting in 14 of their own
mortgages to try to upgrade it which
which did what they ended up doing they
ended up downgrading it which they
didn't know so the government case uh
they didn't
uh disclose that john
paulson was on the other hand is without
merit this is nothing more than a
political football wouldn't you agree
with that
well i mean as i said before the fact
that polson was the other side
um is to me not not an issue and and and
for that to be made a part of the issue
really isn't where the potential fraud i
believe would would lie if there isn't i
don't think that's that's the problem
the problem is potentially this um when
the deal was put together um and yes iqb
was on the other side but there was a
management team that signed off on these
securities that on the reference
things that were inside the cdo
and that was five different count
parties including jp morgan including
merrill lynch including ambac
and they were the selectors they were
put on the marketing materials being the
selectors
paulson was also a selector and he was
specifically not put on the marketing
material so the question is would
this management group have done the deal
with people have invested had they known
maybe they would they obviously wanted
to invest in this deal but things could
have turned out differently had they
known that and it was not disclosed
specifically not disclosed and i think
that's where there's there's there's a
potential case
what is deimos and why are you in
california
um demos is a nonpartisan
public policy think tank that deals with
issues from
voting rights to financial
reform and everything in between it's
based in new york um it's actually going
to have its 10th anniversary next month
i joined right after i left goldman
actually when worldcom was the crisis of
the moment
and that was the first thing i was
speaking about about corporate fraud and
about worldcom and how banks and and
those companies related to each other um
but deimos itself is um 60 or so
individuals now they're based in new
york they have an office in d.c
um they are beginning george soros uh
funded it's it's not actually funded by
by george soros i mean there are other
funders that ford is was a or is a
funder um and and there are other types
of funders
i believe the rockefeller foundation is
there was so i mean there's some
significant funders behind it um and a
lot of the work is very research-based
there's a lot of data that that is also
used for the reports that deimos comes
out with i did a report on on bank risk
and really looking into the books and
really seeing where their numbers were
and those kinds of things take
time and research and effort and that
kind of thing
i am out in la really
kind of to be an offshoot but also
because i
kind of like l.a
it's it's it's a change for other
reasons and other types of writing and
and things as well to be on another side
of the country what was there something
that happened or did it just kind of add
up for you to to leave the
the world of finance i think i think it
was an accumulation process i mean i
think even when i was a bear in london
before i moved back to new york to to be
a part of goldman i was kind of
already a bit disenchanted with with
everything we were doing and how it was
was was turning out this was around the
currency crisis and everything else i
mean it just it just wasn't feeling
right um what i was doing and also just
the environment and you know the
internal politics the bureaucracy that
the intensity on the money just seemed
really empty and yet i i did move back
to new york i did join goldman as the
last place
in the industry that i worked and i
really hated it
i really thought that everything i felt
about the intensity of
of how a firm operates
and
what it does and how that doesn't
connect into what's going on outside in
the rest of the world
really hit home for me there and i think
after 9 11 where i was on wall street i
wasn't goldman at the time um you know
there's a kind of moment so i think a
lot of us
um
just just think is this what i want to
do with my life or or do i want to
educate do i want to do something else
so
and this is nomie prin's most recent
book it takes a pillage is the name of
this book but she's also written other
people's money the corporate mugging of
america and jacked how conservatives are
picking your pocket whether you voted
for them or not
next call for her comes from
philadelphia philadelphia you're on the
air
hello um miss prinz and um slenz
um i just wanted to react to um a
program that i watched last night and i
would encourage you to check it out uh
bill moyer's journal comes on every week
you may or may not know that he's going
to retire from the program as of next
week well he had william black on off
the road best way to rob a bank is to
own one
and he was reacting to testimony given
by
um
geithner
on august 10 for congress but they were
talking about the financial crisis some
of the bank regulations and during his
testimony geithner
stated
that during the time that all this was
blowing up with aig and goldman and what
have you
um that said the new york fed
and the other central banks had no
authority under the law
to limit
uh risk taking
amongst all these entities
and that essentially they were toothless
how frustrating things
uh also ms shapiro the head of the sec
testified on the same day uh april 10th
and also expressed her frustration that
why the sec could not do more
and um when asked to react to that mr
black said
that well the reason why they couldn't
do a lot of the things that they they
were unable to do to curtail this fiasco
was because they had the federal lobby
to repeal last step
so they in fact were the architects
of uh dishonoring themselves taking
tools out of the toolbox for the dispute
and then going to congress and saying
that we had no way of stopping this
because we didn't have enough tools i
was just wondering all right thanks
thanks caller know me prince yeah well i
i think that you're right you're you're
pointing to a real disingenuous kind of
component of the whole argument on both
sides yes glass-steagall was repealed in
1999. that allowed big banks to both
take depositor money you know deal with
creating loans and also
bet
betting requires speculative trading
requires putting capital behind it you
can choose where you put that capital
and you still can so if a bank decides
you know what instead of putting capital
behind creating or renegotiating new
loans with individuals we want to put
capital um against betting on packages
sub prime loans or embedding on oil or
food or whatever else we want to bet on
that's just a choice we will move it
there
the the new york fed has a very close
connection to wall street it is wall
street's fed and the federal reserve of
course has the ability to see
information as this stuff is coming to a
head they also had information about
what was going on with the subprime
loans underlying what became all these
toxic assets it was obvious between 2006
and 2007 that foreclosures were doubling
that these securities were having a
problem that ratings were going to be
as disingenuous as they are we're going
to come down on these securities and
your responsibility
as
the regulatory enforcer of the banking
industry is to not sit there on your
hands and say i can't do something that
wasn't the decision that was made when
the bailout decision was taken there
wasn't a we can't do anything there was
more like i hear some cheap loans and
here's some money and here's some other
stuff to get you through the day um and
so
there are emergency powers acts within
the federal emergency powers within the
federal reserve act that allow
the fed to do whatever it needs to do to
promote economic stability and if it
sees that there are
information lacking or
non-transparencies or whether it might
be coming from the banking sector it is
their job to take a look at that stuff
and they they just failed at that job
the sec failed at its job the sec
allowed the risk taking the leverage the
betting against these types of
securities and others to accumulate from
2004 when they change the rules to allow
that to happen when you change your
rules to allow something to get more
risky and then you don't watch it as it
becomes more risky that's a failure on
the part of the regulatory body um so
they contribute to their own failure but
then they fail in executing
their defense against what they
contributed i mean so it's it's a bad
cycle
and you call in uh it takes a pillage
you call you say that the repeal of
glass-steagall was one of the biggest
mistakes ever made why because it
allowed banks to both have the benefit
of having fdic backing and have their
their deposits backed and have that
capital
assurance that cushion in order to go
off into other areas and bet more and
what was happening i should talk about
this my first book and other people's
money is that they're they're unleashed
after glass-steagall has repealed this
really big competitiveness within the
banking industry there was banks like
jpmorgan chase and like citigroup that
were full combinations of investment
banks the speculative banks and
commercial banks that deal with
customers and sort of more vanilla
loans and deposits
and then you have the goldman sachses
and the lehman brothers and the bear
stearns and the merrill lynch were like
okay we don't have those deposits so
instead we are going to leverage or
borrow against what we do have
by much more so we can compete with
these bigger banks so even though they
weren't combined post-glass-steagall
banks investment and commercial together
they were just investment for a while
the competition against what was going
on with the new kind of commercial
investment banks post-glass-steagall
drove up all of the risk in the market
and right now again the bills that are
put forth so far in congress don't
actually repeal the repeal of
glass-steagall there are some senators
that have produced amendments to want to
try to do that but so far
they are not and have not been put into
these bills what would you like to see
in a reform package passed by the
congress well yeah yeah first and
foremost we should have a
repeal of glass-steagall repeal we
should go back to that's not that's not
even under consideration is it again
yeah it's under consideration by some
senators and some house representatives
but the thing is what is under
consideration instead which uh they are
saying many senators are saying will be
the helpful thing and so is tim geithner
and so is the fed chairman that if we
just
uh increase the capital that banks have
to put behind reduce the risk that way
but don't segment them out into
glass-steagall type of
separations that will be okay but it
won't be okay that'll just take money
away from lending
and put it into speculation they'll
still make that choice it will just hurt
the other side of the economy more
nomi prinz has been our guest for the
last half hour this is her most recent
book it takes a pillage and in fact if
you would like to see more of nomie
prinz she taped an afterwards program
with us she sat down with senator bernie
sanders last year and taped it
afterwards so you can go to booktv.org
you can just search her name and come up
with all the programs and you can watch
it all online at
booktv.org nomi prince thank you for
being with us thank you so much peter by
the way everything that we're covering
today is going to re-air tonight at 11
p.m eastern time 8 p.m
pacific time and that will be the re-air
of today's uh entire coverage of the la
times festival of books well right now
it's time to go to our first panel and
here in haines hall on and now on book
tv nomi prinz discusses our current
economic situation in the u.s and her
book black tuesday a historical novel
about the 1929 economic crash
this is about an hour 20 minutes
good evening
i want to welcome everybody to the
strand i hope you enjoy our new event
space which is located in our rare book
floor as a way of introduction i'm nancy
white and i'm the owner of the strand
the strand was founded by my grandfather
in 1927 it's been
around for three generations
of my family
so
a contrary to the so-called experts who
say the kindles and the ipads and the
next cool devices are going to wipe out
bookstores we believe that people do not
want to just be sitting home at at home
tethered to their gadgets even though i
see matt brought his device bookstore
but we're just planning to serve the
book community for a long long time
tonight i am thrilled to welcome back
naomi prims
for the launch of her first historical
novel black tuesday this is the second
time that she's been at the strand and
she says that she only signs at
independent bookstores i love her for
that
[Applause]
so with the mounting frustration with
wall street and the recession this novel
and topic is extremely timely timely so
this um and thank you special thank you
to demos the nonpartisan multi-issue
think tank for co-sponsoring this event
and they're located here in new york
city
[Applause]
so we have we have a lively group of
panelists here tonight none of which are
afraid of controversy
including matt to be to believe
okay
and rich benjamin that's a lot easier
who'll talk about the current uh
financial climate back tuesday is a
black tuesday is a character-driven book
that vividly portrays new york on the
cusp of the great stock market crash of
1929.
it captures the romance and desperation
of one of the most fascinating
historical times
um nomi prims left a lucrative career at
goldman sachs and bear stearns after a
decade to pen three non-fiction
whistleblower books it takes a pillage
other people's money
and jacked
exposing fraud and deception from
wall street to washington her first
novel the trail is a thriller set in the
corrupt banking world and it was written
under pseudomen you'll have to tell us
why and she's a senior fellow at demos
and a frequent commentator for all kinds
of media
pbs fox byfox msnbc
cnbc
cnn bbc and other global media outlets
matt is a contributing editor for
rolling stone he writes about
politics and finance in one article he
famously described goldman sachs as a
great vampire squid wrapped about the
face of humanity relentlessly jamming
its blood funnel into anything that
smells like money
he's authored five books many of which
we have here
including the new york times bestseller
great derangement and grif topia
and he's recently became a contributor
for current tv's countdown with keith
oberman
rich benjamin down at the end is the
author yay
searching for wittopia an improbable
journey to the heart of white america
which was the winner of 2009 editors
choice award from book list and the
american library association
rich regularly appears all over the
media including on npr msnbc c-span new
york times usa today and cnn.com he's a
contributing producer of short
documentariesfortime.com
in partnership with cnn and he's a
senior fellow at deimos
um so for a little bit of tonight's
format we're going to have a
conversation then we want to open up the
mic to your questions it's a really big
crowd here so if you don't mind just i'm
standing um standing up and i'll hand
you them and just wait a second for me
to hand you the mic so everybody can
hear you and then the authors are going
to stick around and sign copies of their
books also a special thanks to c-span
for filming tonight
and for the work they do to inspire and
educate us
so please join me in welcoming some of
america's great contemporary
whistleblowers and advocates of
financial reform naomi prims and her
panelists to the strand thank you all
hi my name is rich benjamin i'm a senior
fellow at demos and first of all i'd
like to welcome you guys who make this
event possible
and i want to thank stran such a beloved
beloved institution for we book lovers
here in new york and i want to thank
demos which as nancy mentioned is a
multi-issue think tank which works for
three overarching goals the first of
which is a more equitable prosperous
economy the second of which is a
democracy where more of us can
participate and the third of which is a
public sector that works for the common
good
now i want to
offer a different angle in introducing
our other panelists uh
i got this email in july from nomi and
it said hey rich i've written a novel
called black tuesday
right here
and i'm thinking word
nomi wrote a book about african-american
tuesday
she had to clarify black tuesday of
course referring to dark tuesday in the
stock market crash of 1929 and
immediately i could see the timeliness
of this topic
although naomi could write a book called
african american tuesday
now for those of you who don't know nomi
is such a dogged incisive
elegant voice
for progressive values and i'm so
honored to introduce her
what you may not know and which was
alluded to before is
nomi was part of the one percent before
she joined the 99
nomi was a wall streeter and not only
was she a wall streeter she was a
managing director at goldman sachs which
is such an achievement in itself in
terms of her brilliance
but uh now she's based in la and she's
writing full time and i want to briefly
show you her novels because that really
gives a wonderful trajectory of her
thinking and her career
the first
other people's money the corporate
mugging of america
secondly jacked how conservatives are
picking your pocket whether you voted
for them or not
third whistleblowing book it takes a
pillage
behind the bailouts bonuses and backroom
deals from wall street to washington
by the way nomi is also the queen of
titles
in case you hadn't noticed
so you can learn more about know me at
www.com
and i just introduce her with a great
deal of pride and a great deal of
affection and we miss her here on
the right coast
so know me prince thank you
now matt taivi you might figure you know
matt's a bit of an underachiever and a
boring writer
seriously matt is a regular contributor
for rolling stone and he has made such a
name
to really exposing the underbelly and
the dark side of our financial
institutions in this country
you read the beautiful
quote
that matt had to say about nomi's former
employer goldman sachs
and i'll briefly
read from
mass blog today you can find matt
at his rolling stone blog
when he's not on countdown
matt wrote today quote
what nobody is comfortable with is a
movement in which virtually the entire
spectrum of middle class and poor
americans is on the same page
railing against incestuous political and
financial corruption on wall street and
in washington
the reality is that occupy wall street
and the millions of middle americans who
make up the tea party are natural allies
and should be on the same page about
most of the key issues
and that's a story our media won't want
you to know or you to handle
i have a gripe to pick with matt um
as
nancy mentioned i published a book
called searching for wytopia in 2009 an
improbable journey to the heart of white
america
in 2010 matt released griftopia
bubble machines vampire squids and the
long
con that is breathtaking that is
breaking america
so please visit madd and welcome matt
and matt we're delighted to have you
thank you
sorry to steal the title
so
let's just begin let's just jump right
in what we'll do is we'll have a
conversation and then we'll open it up
to questions and no me let's hear about
black tuesday
um well thank you for the introduction
thank you nancy for that lovely
introduction thank the strand thank
demos
thank the lower east side tenement
museum where i spent a lot of time and
took a lot of tours doing uh some of the
research for this book thank your
grandfather for two years before the
time that this book took place
starting this bookstore
um because a lot has happened and it's
wonderful to gather here tonight for
that
um
obviously a lot going on in the world
with respect to and particularly in new
york on wall street and so forth that
you're just talking about that matt
talks about with respect to what
is an uprising
amongst people who are just sick of the
way things are economically and want it
to actually be different not to have
talk about how it might be different but
to actually live differently and i we
are i'm sure going to talk about that a
lot tonight but what i want to do first
is take you back 82 years
to a period in time that was
both very different and very similar
to today
and that was part of my inspiration for
coming up with the story for this book
is that a lot of what what i do what
rich does what math does you know we
talk about numbers we do talk about
people who talk about stats but it's
really in a novel that you can
also look at the emotions behind that
the sort of the sheer humanity
of struggling and what you bear and what
you think you don't want to deal with
and what you ultimately
come to achieve and there's a lot of
that in this book too no one's a natural
hero
least of all the main character lyla
khan she comes to what she ultimately
does in this book through
a lot of internal struggle and a lot of
different situations i'm going to read
three brief passages from the book to
give you a sense of
you know what she went through what
things were like on both sides of the
divide
the one percent the 99 percent but back
then
and it wasn't too different and
though from there so the first passage
lila lives in this fifth floor walk up
on orchard street
in an apartment that she shares with
four other people um her old aunt rosa
her little sister rachel and her two
cousins and it's tiny and cramped as as
you can imagine back in the 20s back in
that day back at that time um and she's
having a conversation with her aunt
about this
idealism that she's seeing sort of
activism that's kind of happening
amongst the workers and the people she
knows on that side and how she really
feels about it which is which is not
sure
um
lila eyed her aunts hollow cheekbones
and defiant limbs the silver streaks and
the wiry raven hair that she wore
braided down her back she felt her
throat constrict listen to me go on said
rosa with a labored flick of her wrists
of course things will be fine enough
with thesaurus how are things with you
and nelson fine answer lyla that's all
just fine
i don't know i wish he could be happier
he's always going on about how miserable
things are fighting about something ever
since his brother was shot i'm afraid he
may join the gangs again i guess i guess
i'm tired of it i'm tired of not being a
fighter he thinks i should be
rosa nodded and swayed her body back and
forth her eyes closed as i transported
her to the internal movie of her past
he's a good man with a loyal heart you
should try to see where he's coming from
should should should
rose's words made lila feel inadequate
she could not help but think of the
stranger at the morning spot
the morning spot's a diner down on wall
street
did he have any warmth any goodness she
knew nothing about him and yet he had
somehow burrowed into her heart
i know replied lyla but that won't make
him easier to deal with
you remember what i told you when you
first came here a young girl of 14 not
knowing a word of english she asked i do
tanta
lyla braced herself for a speech she'd
heard many times before it was her duty
to listen diligently but her heart
impelled her to flee she loved her aunt
with all her being but that love imposed
a burden that she wished she could shake
i told you that in order to succeed in
america you must find your purpose and
always help those less fortunate than
you
i know which is exactly what nelson
strives to do every day i know it's just
that you and he have such courage as
patients i wish i did instead i just
want to get out of here
lila stopped herself but rosa seemed to
understand exactly what she meant
sometimes you don't find your cause lyla
said her aunt with a little smile your
cause finds you
there is a little fight buried in all of
us
and that's kind of one of the messages
in the book is that you know not all of
us start out knowing anything about the
direction of our life or or fights we
might have or how we might uh react in
those particular situations i mean
certainly when i started on wall street
i was lyla's age i was 19. and um
i had no idea
uh what it was about and it took me
working there many many years to finally
finally figure it out and ultimately to
get out and share it um but but you
don't know you don't know the answers
and and you don't always do the right
thing and i think that's that's a part
of all of us and
um sometimes you come upon
the right thing in a really difficult
way
um one other scene
i'm going to read this one and one more
this is a scene where now she's
lyla is working on on this in this diner
on wall street and she goes home every
night to this dingy little apartment on
the lower east side not not very far
away at all but
millions of miles away in terms of the
conversations that happen in the money
divide and everything else
but she's just discovered a secret about
this wall street banker who comes to
frequent her diner
lila arrived home to a glorious may
evening vibrant swaths of magenta
tangerine and rose striped the blue dust
sky like the swirls around the candy
canes at cohen's sweet shop on rivington
street
the air carried a gentle breeze
throughout the lower east side
lila was so gleefully distracted with
thoughts of rodrick and the morgans that
she circled her neighborhood several
times before reaching her building
rachel was playing stupol with a few of
her friends the brow under her raven
ringlets was damp with the sweat of
competition their building had the
tallest stoop in the neighborhood seven
steps in all so it was a magnet for kids
children were laughing and scampering
after every stray ball that bounced down
the sidewalk the twins were unofficial
neighborhood champs jonathan would wind
his arm like a yankee pitcher on opening
night he could go 20 points without
missing a catch and finish a game with a
hundred points joshua had stopped
playing a few years ago hey cuz jonathan
called delilah mid-pitch his hair
tousled messed the sleeves of his work
shirt rolled up to his elbows your
sister's gaining on me she's out to take
my title it's war
i bet on rachel by the left is that all
my talent means to you ask jonathan
grinning sorry jonathan but rage is no
slash we all better watch out for her
and would you mind making room for me to
pass through the big game do we have to
stop now moaned rachel i'm having my
best run
of course you don't reeska answered
arriving breathless at their stoop she
hung onto the iron railing her ample
breasts breathing
heathing
i haven't seen your sister in weeks
we're gonna do a little ketchup so keep
beating jonathan okay okay agreed rachel
grabbing the ball not needing the extra
encouragement reefka lila hugged her
friend so good to see you but i'm late
for dinner rosa will be waiting for me
to help with the finishing touches rosa
definitely does not need your help in
the cooking department reefka chuckled
now tell me what's new please my life is
one big bore right now i need to come up
with better fish stories for joshua or
move on it's tragic how's your crush
lilac couldn't suppress a wide grin that
unleashed her dimples see there's news
exclaimed rifka tell me okay but let's
go over to feinberg's hardware away from
his big ears over there she gestured to
rachel the two walked a few buildings
down the block they strode past marcus's
shoe store and harold cigar shop
sniffing wafts of sweet tobacco they
passed another set of kids playing
hopscotch and a third playing stickball
everyone was out tonight after they sat
down on feinberg's steps lyla blurted
out the latest development are you
kidding me
reefka's emerald eyes nearly bulged out
of their sockets he's a morgan flesh and
blood of the richest man in the world
and he talks to you
um
and that was part of what was going on
at the time there was there was a
a cynicism amongst a very small group of
people about what went down on wall
street because it was it was very
secretive there were bankers down there
there was money made down there there
was a stock market everybody was talking
about but but it was still pretty
secretive and it still is today but but
it was even more so then
and um
yet there was this adoration of it like
it must be so amazing you know this guy
is making this money what are they doing
what what what crazy things are going on
down there and until the market
really crashed um and things got really
bad there wasn't this notion of a
connection between those things that
went down there and how it was impacting
a stoop ball game on the steps on
orchard street
and just as a background to that one of
the women that i had interviewed and i
talked to a lot of people about their
experiences during the great depression
was kind of a little bit rachel who is
the little sister of lila the main
character and she used to tell me that
you know they didn't have a lot of money
so they would they would have a ball and
this ball would be basically everybody's
game and it was stoop ball and you'd
find the stairs and you basically throw
the ball catch it and there'd be like
these tournaments going on on the
streets you know you'd find a stick you
play stickball
whereas uptown on park avenue and so
forth you had all of the the latest toys
the latest fashions the latest
everything and it was a tremendous
tremendous difference as again it is
today even even more pronounced
back then
but
obviously there's there's a cost that
comes with that difference on our
economy on people and people back then
and the bankers that ultimately
perpetuate some of what happens don't
always know what they're doing and some
do and herein lies the problem her crush
is
a morgan partner
in real life there are 40 partners at
morgan bank he was the 41st in my book
but um has a lot of the elements of the
others um so this last scene i'm going
to read will probably
take you into today a little bit but um
it was the afternoon for real of 1929
october tuesday 1929 the 29th
and roderick the morgan partner
had to go into the secret meeting at the
new york
stock exchange
right now if you imagine the triangle
down on wall street there's the stock
exchange there's the old morgan bank
which was the the first big morgan bank
and then there's federal hall it's kind
of a triangle um obviously it was the
same then and um for real they
in the middle of the stay when the
market was going crazy and crashing
there was a notice given to the morgan
bank that there was going to be a secret
meeting held at the new york stock
exchange to talk about what to do
bankers had several days before that on
black thursday pooled lots of their
money together and thought they could
save the markets and they did for a
little bit and the media said that was
all great and then they all plummeted
again and so now they're several days
later and they know they know that
everything they've basically created and
lied about is going to come crumbling
down so there's a secret me in the new
york stock exchange to decide what to do
and it was told to people that were
coming over from from morgan um not to
let anybody basically see them come over
because that would incite a riot you
know imagine there's all these people
down in the exchange everybody's angry
and and the actual um
this was only reported much later wasn't
reported at the time the meeting that
was held was actually held in secret
they went up the back stairs of the
exchange
to avoid being caught
the exchange was the last place roderick
wanted to be it was just like his uncle
to stay away from the fray always in the
shadows he grabbed his overcoat and hat
and followed lamont from across the
lower lobby of morgan roderick saw a
cluster of men before the bank's doors
yelling at the morgan guards with fist
clenching stock certificates lamont said
not that way out the back
the two men exited the bank through the
same steel doors that normally opened
for truckloads of gold bars once outside
they had no choice but to barge through
the crowds to reach the back door of the
exchange across the narrow street
fortunately there were less people on
this side of the exchange than raging
directly in front of it but the task was
still far from simple just when they
reached the back of the exchange two
guards told them to wait outside so that
people wouldn't spot two morgan partners
entering they might just kill you
said an exchange guard
ryder adjusted his hat to cover his eyes
and waited by lamont he was looking down
at his shoes when a man wearing a gray
overcoat and matching bowler hat marched
up to him and punched him in the stomach
roderick doubled over may you rot in
hell said the man before he spit in
roderick's face and ran off
um on that happy note
um
there there was obviously a lot of
visceral anger back then we we see
that anger today
but when i started
writing this book
it
it was the story the notion of this
young girl who
really didn't know anything about any of
this
not about bankers not about wall street
not about fighting not about labor
activists you know she just wanted to
grow up in this america have the dream
that everyone talked about
when they immigrated here and and that
was all and uh she comes upon what
some discoveries that she can't ignore
even though she she tries really hard to
and that's a lot of the conflict in the
book is that you know sometimes you
ignore ignore ignore until until you
can't and and what do we do at that
moment of our humanity or our situation
our personal lives in an aggregate
situation for the country or whatever to
stand up um and what's our internal
struggle in doing that so she does go
through a lot of that and i think today
um there's there's a lot of that allowed
now i mean there's a lot of anger
there's there's matt's quote um
there's all of the stuff that that we
know has been imposed upon
the economy on the conditions of this
country by virtue of criminal activity
by virtue of fraud by virtue of
inflating the value of things that
shouldn't be inflated um and and what
we're seeing now is really no different
the details might be different but but
the mechanisms the people are all the
same really they're just
you know like nancy's here instead of
her grandfather you know it's like jamie
dimon is here instead of jack morgan
um but in a in a worse way
um and and i think that's also the
impetus for um
learning from our past and and hoping
that you know maybe we can bring the
good parts of what happened in that pass
forward um because not all of the
bankers at this time got what they
should have gotten not that none of them
uh were actually arrested none of them
were actually tried for uh securities
fraud or anything like that at the time
but sounds familiar and which is very
familiar which i know matt
will talk about but we did we did have a
situation where there was an
understanding that the country had to be
protected um and that in the midst of
the great depression that followed the
stock market crash in 1929 the the
foundation of the country that the core
of of uh
the financial system had to be protected
vis-a-vis the population um and that was
part of the reason why they split up the
banks ultimately in 1933 it was the idea
that you can't be doing fraudulent
things and then crash the whole economy
however it is that happens and either a
get away with it or b get to continue
doing it with our help i.e the
government's help um and so back then
they had that distinction they had the
glass-steagall act passed which divided
banks and basically slapped back uh
not their all the speculative activities
but at least gave the population
protections um that we don't have now
um which is a sad lack of historical
understanding um in today's world um but
all of that aside
going through it at the time and if you
can imagine going back and seeing kind
of simpler world
as a person just coming here and
figuring it out
with their heart with their head
struggling between family struggling
between the wealthy and the the poor and
everything else you know you get a sense
for um
how we are really not that different
from from how we were 82 years ago
so
that
i i just want to say one thing about
about matt um in addition before he
starts um responding no no
when he wrote the um the piece about the
vampire squid um
which was my old old firm i had so many
calls
um
about him
and um we didn't we didn't actually know
each other at the time um it was it was
sort of like who is this you know i mean
i knew his work i didn't know him we
hadn't had a personal conversation i
think i had so many uh calls about that
piece and about this guy
um that i reached out and i'm just glad
to say we we you know have become
friends and um i deeply admire this
man's work and
i'm sure you guys all do too
well that was that was great um
i have a lot to say about nomi uh but
just a couple of really quick things
before i start first of all rich i'm
really sorry for stealing your title
i didn't you know i saw it i thought
that sounds catchy i'll take that
second thing
before we go on i just want to say how
cool it is
for me personally to be able to appear
at the strand i've been buying books
from those bins outside since i was like
this tall and like literally half the
books of my bookshelves come from the
store in one form or another this one or
the one that used to be downtown so my
wife and i used to go there every
weekend and come out with you know
stacks this big so this is a big honor
for me and
i'm very happy to be here i'm glad you
all came out tonight um
oh this is this is a great for me to be
able to come out and and talk about
nomi and nomi's book uh just to
explain a little bit about where where
i'm coming from with regard to to know
me and what i think she meant to
um
this period to a lot of journalists like
me i just want to tell my story about
how i came to to know her i think my my
story was kind of typical for a lot of
political journalists uh up until 2008
most people who cover politics in you
know
national american politics really didn't
know anything about economics at all
our whole
modus operandi for covering politics was
covering the economy excuse me was to
look at the stock market and inflation
and maybe
unemployment figures and uh and that was
it if the stock market was up we would
say the economy was good and if
inflation was low the economy was good
and that was really about it most people
didn't understand anything else i can
tell you that with 100 certainty that
the people on the campaign trail who
cover politics for a living know
absolutely nothing about economics and
we have one of the
sort of precipitating incidents for me
is there something we can do about that
feedback no
no okay
um
does everyone remember the whole drill
baby drill speech that mccain
uh did in the summer of uh 2008 well i
was on i was covering mccain i was on
the mccain campaign plane and i remember
we were in kenner louisiana
and he was sort of unveiling a new
version of that speech and um
you know after
and of course when mccain was talking
about was this the surge in gas prices
that summer everyone remember gas prices
went through the roof and and he was
basically saying oh if we just drilled
in the gulf of mexico then those you
know somehow that would magically make
gas prices go down
um so he gives this speech and and all
the reporters are filing back into our
little you know private prison which is
the campaign plane and um
and uh one of the tv reporters is like
mccain what a jerk you know as if as if
drilling in the gulf of mexico has
anything to do with why gas prices are
going up and i kind of turned to him and
i'm kind of raising my hand and i said
does anybody here actually know why gas
prices are going up and it was like
the cartoons you know where the crickets
come in you know like
literally nobody knew and i and i uh i
kind of turned to one of these uh
another reporter who was sitting next to
me and i'm like
doesn't that make us all frauds and he's
like dude you're just figuring that out
now you know
so
so there was that you know so so then
the crash happens like you know a couple
of months later and suddenly this whole
army of ignoramuses uh who don't know
anything about the economy are suddenly
given these assignments like go figure
out what just happened
uh
and then tell everybody else about it
like you're an expert and so i was one
of those people who was like given this
daunting assignment of
explaining
all of these labyrinthine you know
machinations that led to the financial
crisis of 2008 and i was one of those
people who didn't even know how to
balance a checkbook so
um i'm starting from square one and i
remember i started making a whole bunch
of calls to people in the industry
and i remember like the first time
somebody explained
uh credit default swaps to me uh and
they were saying oh you know two
financial institutions are basically
making they sign a contract with each
other and if uh you know x person
defaults on his loan then this bank gets
the full value of the the loan but if he
doesn't default on it then this person
continues paying uh that that party you
know a regular payment every month and
i'm i'm sitting here listening to this
and like that sounds just like gambling
you know that is that economics and you
know these guys on wall street who are
calling they were saying no no you don't
understand it's it's very sophisticated
it's it's not it's not just gambling
it's really it's a it's a mechanism for
lessening risk and you know they had all
this verbiage that they were cloaking
all this in but it sounded really fishy
to me and then you know then they got
into
collateralized debt obligations and you
know the more people explained this to
me you know i was i was
talking to them and i was saying so let
me get this straight so you take a whole
bunch of subprime loans that are
basically
worthless or junk rated they're
extremely risky and then you somehow
sprinkle a bunch of magic dust on them
and they turn into triple a rated loans
that you can sell to pension funds and
you know dutch trade unions and other
victims all around the globe and and
they're like yeah and then i'm like well
that
that sounds just like the guys on the
street who sell prada bags and you know
gucci watches they're not real you know
how is that any different from just
crime and and they're like no you don't
understand it's it's you know it's
economics it's it's a risk management
tool it's you know it's it's creates
liquidity that's the phrase that which
is it creates liquidity
uh so you know your instinct is to say
is to like run with a headline that just
says craziest [ __ ] imaginable you know
like
like this can't possibly be happening
and
but i think like a lot of reporters you
know i
i was hesitant because
most of us had never met
any people from that world you know none
of us had any actual access to people
like
lloyd blankfein or jamie dimon we didn't
get to talk to them i mean even
even presidential candidates most of us
have gotten to sit down and talk to
these people
but we don't have access to the captains
of uh finance and at least political
reporters don't
and uh and so we didn't really know how
it worked and and so a lot of us were
really hesitant to make judgments about
it then you and add to the fact that the
entire financial press was treating what
happened as just sort of a grotesque
accident and you know a thousand year
flood this this is just you know
economics these things happen it wasn't
crime it wasn't fraud you know it's just
a whole bunch of people who made some
bad judgments about the market and these
are seemingly smart people on television
and there's a whole army of people on
cnbc who are acting like this isn't
crazy and that it isn't crime and so you
you hesitate uh because you don't have
that personal experience and
uh and so what was really needed was for
somebody from that world
to come forward and explain to us yes
this is this was nuts it's exactly as
crazy as crazy as it seems like and
moreover let me tell you a little bit
about what these people are like so you
can understand the motivations in the
background and that's really what nomi i
think nomi's role has been in this
entire fiasco uh she's she was one of
the first sort of wit first first-person
witnesses to history to come forward and
to confirm
the superficial conclusions that all
these outsiders were drawing but we just
didn't we couldn't know for sure unless
we had somebody who was actually
on the inside explaining a lot of this
to us and you know i i had the uh it was
shortly after i think my goldman piece
came out i i
i forget who called who first but um but
we ended up meeting in new york in a
jewish deli in uh in the diamond
district
yeah they closed at the dairy luncheon
did anyone know that place um
and we sat and nomi basically you know
she ran through her the history of her
experiences that you know particularly
at bear stearns and goldman and she told
me a lot about what
you know her her career had been like
and what her apprehensions were and why
she ended up leaving and
and you know for me it was
as a reporter was it was invaluable
because
you know not just confirming
intellectually
what all these instruments were and how
they worked and and why why why they
blew up but it was also you know what
how these what the rooms look like where
the where these deals went down what the
attitude was of the people who were who
were doing these deals you know from
from on the outside one has to one comes
to the conclusion that these people must
have been looking at you know
numbers there must have been internal
objections people in the risk management
departments coming forward saying dude
don't we can't do this it's going to
blow up the company and there must have
been people who said now forget about
that we'll worry about that later and
and it wasn't until i met nomie that i
that i realized that
you know i had somebody to tell me yes
firsthand yes this did happen yes these
people were routinely ignored and that's
why a lot of these disasters happened so
um
all of this you know there weren't a
whole lot of people from this world who
came who came forward uh to tell us uh
what it was like on the inside and so
she's really an invaluable resource in
in that regard and i think you know what
what she's able to do with black tuesday
there are a lot of things that we can't
imagine
except in the realm of fiction because
they couldn't possibly happen in reality
like for instance we're never going to
have a trial a fraud trial of a jaime
diamond or a lloyd blankfein in this
country it's just work these people are
not going to be dragged into court and
forced to answer uh for their crimes uh
and make no mistake about it this is
another key point that nomi
her experience brings out and she bears
out in the book you know there were a
lot of people who were trying to say
that what happened in the crash was the
work of a few bad apples here on the
side and underlings that
the guys up at the top couldn't possibly
have been aware that they were selling
you know
mismarked instruments unknowingly and
unloading them on customers that's
complete crap these none of this could
have happened without the full
and total participation of the guy at
the very guys at the very top of these
companies and she makes that plain but
you know her her novel comes to a
crescendo at the end and there's a
there's a trial scene where a character
you know the jack morgan character who's
you know sort of like titan of industry
is actually dragged into court for fraud
and forced to you know come face to face
with the people who bought
these uh you know these
dicey investment trusts which are very
similar to the to the cdos of our modern
time although they're a little bit more
primitive and
that's exactly what we're not going to
see now as everyone heard about this
foreclosure deal that the ag's are
cooking up now the state attorneys
general
that's going to be sort of a a unified
settlement that's going to give the
banks immunity from
all kinds of
legal liability well it's precisely
because of that deal that we're not
going to have
gigantic class action lawsuits of of
defrauded investors who are going to
drag these guys in the court and prove
uh that they all committed fraud that
they knowingly disguised the crappiness
of these loans as they were selling them
as triple a rated securities around the
world
we're never going to get that scene
inside a courtroom we're never going to
see that evidence dragged out it's been
years now nobody has gone to jail for
any of this stuff and it's it's just not
gonna happen unless unless more pressure
is brought to bear from you know these
people downtown
uh we're just never gonna see that scene
except you know in in nomi's book and
it's a it's a great place to come
you know face to face with what the
evidence would be
if we were actually able to see it and
so i think it's an invaluable
opportunity for all of us and and the
novel was a really cool thing and i
think everybody should read it so
uh
[Applause]
let me ask you both a question sure um
[Music]
let's say
after freud novels have become about
psychology so i want to ask you guys
about the psychology of wall street
because when you go to occupy wall
street a lot of people are frustrated
and pissed off at what has went down in
you know the last uh seven to eight
years so the question is tell us know me
about the villain in your character
and matt tybee
someone has said in order to work at the
highest levels of wall street you have
to be a sociopath i mean that's a direct
quote what is your
understanding of people's motives and
people's psychology
over the last five years and what's gone
on so in the novelistic sense and in the
real life sense
um yeah i mean basically i i think i
said they're so surpassed
but i because there has to be
a
clear
separation of of how you act and who you
think you are
at those top levels and not because
they're ceos not because you're running
the morgan bank but because of
everything that made you able to take
that position
and and i i continue we could talk i
continue to to think about this just in
a more psychological emotional sense you
know are you a sociopath first and
that's how you get to that position like
is it a latent quality
uh no i mean it is it and and when you
get there it's sort of it sort of
flushes out
um or you know when you get the power is
that sort of like you know water on a
plant and it i i don't know or is it
something that that uh you know it's
it's a late human thing um or inhuman
thing but um
one of the things that struck me in in
looking at the history of of the morgan
bank and jack morgan who's you know jp
morgan's um
son
is that uh when he was actually called
to trial in 1933 and this is for real in
in washington at the pacora commission
trials that looked into all of what wall
street had done up until the 29 crash
um he was like really steely and really
calm and and the way the media portrayed
it at the time you know he's he's he's
so cool and he's so calm and he's so
that and you know there was a little
circus
a mini girl or something that stepped on
and on his lap and and he was so nice to
her and and the way like after all of
what happened there was this turning
around of of of
the media
almost embracing the same people they're
also running headlines about
sensationally uh the pakora trials so it
was it was just always this weird sort
of dichotomy of you know they're up
there and and and so forth and what i
did in the novel and i don't want to
give away the scene because it's it's
not
things happen there are twists and stuff
but but but the the jack morgan
character really um is based on jack
morgan uh the morgan bank really is is
is morgan bank and and there's a lot of
elements i think of of crime you forget
calling it securities forget labeling it
as anything complicated lying about
something for profit
you know that that is very simple to
achieve
you know it's it's as simple as a
signature on
a document it's as simple as two
separate documents that say different
things
you know it doesn't have to be a
complicated cdo credit link derivative
times a million like it doesn't need to
be that the the mechanism for
pulling one over on anyone who buys this
stuff
requires that same sense of separatism
from the people that are buying it
and to me that's a sociopathic quality
now now in here and again not giving
away the plot but there are other
elements that that flesh out the
sociopathic quality of the villain um
which you can read but but i think that
the elements of one kind of crime versus
another kind of crime
are
pretty much the same
yeah i i totally agree i mean first
i think the the one of the first ways
you have to answer that question is is
to identify what happened like what's a
typical
crime that went on during this period
this this recent period is
take a um you know a banker is going to
sell
uh you know 250 million dollars of
mortgage-backed securities to
let's say the state pension fund of
minnesota so let's all be clear about
what this is some guy who knows he's
selling to a gigantic load of extremely
risky subprime mortgages that are likely
to blow up he's selling a whole bunch of
crap to a state punch pension fund so
that's the
retirement savings of working class
people janitors teachers policemen
firemen this guy is going to basically
steal from old ladies and and old people
that's that's what he's doing when he's
when he's selling this big block of
mortgage-backed securities to a state
pension fund or to calpers or where
whatever
and in order to do that i mean you're
going to make an enormous amount of
money and you're never going to see
those people and all you got to do is
sign a few documents and hit a few
strokes in your
on your computer and you're emotionally
i think right i mean these guys are
completely dissociated from from the
results of of their activities and i
think a lot of them
uh they they came to genuinely believe
in
the righteousness of what they were
doing they they they believed that
somehow uh this was uh you know the
survival of the fittest that somehow all
this this trading this capital
capitalist activity was weeding out the
weak and and it was going to create
liquidity and somehow it ultimately
helped the economy in the end but the
reality is what they were doing is just
stealing from old people and and and the
weak and there's no way to do that and
let unless you completely cut off
your conscience and and morality i mean
i think it gets back to that in that
famous experiment where people are told
to turn the dial if and they're going to
hear the screams in the other room and
and they they what the results show is
that people tend to do that as long as
an authority figure tells them that it's
okay
uh and i think that's what went on in
this in this community there was a
mantra that kind of existed generally
that this stuff was all right right and
and
this is the way you made money right it
wasn't just all right it was your job
right right you had to right so
we we'd love to hear from you guys so
we're going to circulate a mic and if
you could just ask a concise question
and please speak into the mic because
you're being recorded thank you
hi well um this is a really awesome
honor um so thank you for doing this
my question is uh speaking about
training for which you get into these
jobs what part of the problem is you
know rooted in the fact that academic uh
economics is sort of
uh has this inherent problem in which
professors or people write papers but
they don't have to disclose who funded
the papers so they could write like uh
documents about oh you know uh
currency exchanging is so much you know
this is great invention but it they
don't have to actually disclose at 4x
the you know currency trader is the one
that sponsored the paper and how if
that's the case do we like turn that
back how can we force
academia to like disclose information if
they're getting funded by certain
financial institutions when they write
papers
i think your question is part of part of
the bigger issue of um the the
transparency notion of what happens on
on wall street in the whether it's the
papers that people write about or the
articles or whatever and what actually
goes on and there's there's still a lot
of of sort of cloak and dagger as to
what goes on actually every day and a
lot of the documentation that does comes
out
is very difficult to sort of process it
doesn't necessarily have all the
information
that you need and therefore you know if
you're in academia and you decide my
bigger problem actually with academia
or some certain academic papers is that
those people don't necessarily live
through the things they're talking about
you know so they'll be talking about
currency swaps or credit derivatives and
they've never structured one you know i
don't believe you know huge i don't
believe anyone in washington knows what
a swap is and you don't have to in
day-to-day life and that that's part of
what you know lila discovers in the book
you don't need to know a lot but but if
you're making decisions and you're
enabling conditions that allow whatever
it is you don't understand to devastate
the economy then it's your
responsibility
to get out a spreadsheet and just like
like look at some numbers
um and and or find a person or do
anything that gives you some
understanding and at least have a basis
for what you're what you're deciding
upon which does not exist um in any of
the people i've spoken with in
washington yeah
i mean just quickly the only thing i'll
add to that is that um
it's not just that the
university level i think there's been a
lot written and there was an inside job
about how the banks are sponsoring
academics and they're behind a lot of
those research papers but
there's a tremendous movement afoot for
uh all the banks are getting heavily
involved in sponsoring uh
secondary education even elementary
school education if you go into the
communities all across the country there
are a lot of these deals where a bank
will come to a strug community that's
struggling financially and they'll say
here here's five million dollars for
your school system but in return we want
you to dissolve your teachers union or
you know we want this or that and there
it's kind of like the imf world bank
structural adjustment method where we
give you a whole bunch of money in
return we want your ideological
cooperation on this x y and z
right exactly and and they're they're
very very keen on doing that and i think
it shows how how far reaching their
their vision is about society they don't
have any immediate benefit to doing that
and they're spending a lot of money on
it and that tells you that they're that
they have a very very broad vision for
how they want to impact the world and
keep the information out
right
oh hi
sorry
you two are heroes so thank you very
much
and this is sort of to both of you
do you think we can stop them at the new
hampshire primary before they turn this
country into kind of
mad max nightmare world
yeah i think
you know one of the things that occupy
wall street is really
bringing out is that there aren't any
obvious electoral solutions
to a lot of this i mean i think we kind
of
we've kind of gone the route of trying
to fix this at the at the ballot box
because
you know the democratic party the
republican party there
if you look historically the democrats
actually have
probably dirtier hands in terms of
deregulating this mess than the
republicans do and if you look at what
happened in dodd-frank uh the
negotiations last year that was a fiasco
as well you know there are a lot of
well-meaning people in washington you
know there were 33 votes to
to
start breaking up the banks and the
brown kaufman bill uh amendment but you
know that's it's not quite enough you
know i i don't i don't think there's any
i mean do you think there's a there's a
solution out there no it's a
presidential level well the presidential
level definitely i mean the fact that
you know president obama has tim
geithner as a treasury secretary um
right right there is is a
it's a rubber stamp to the idea of
subsidizing bailing out whatever term
you use for the way wall street acts and
the way wall street will continue to act
it's it's a big rubber stamp status quo
let's let's not touch anything because
and treasury sector is not about to turn
around say oops i made a mistake i
shouldn't have really backed bank of
america just because they bought all
this like crap from countrywide and
merrill lynch which by the way i said
they could do
um you know between my role the new york
fed and ben bernanke at the role of the
fed head they're not going to turn
around and ever and made a mistake which
which by the way is part of the whole
sociopathicness there's there's there's
the culpability at the most powerful
level you know where you keep say banks
big you keep them structurally as they
are you
you agree to large mergers that
shouldn't ever happen because they are
very unstable for the rest of the
economy
those people
have no
incentive interest ability um to
consider anything they've done a mistake
i mean look at what happened right they
you know you had this mess that was
because of concentration of capital and
what was there they concentrate more
they concentrated it more they took the
the residue from all these banks and
they jammed them together and made them
more even more dangerous and and today
actually they're they're they're
re-restamping that you know bank of
america my my favorite negative bank is
today i change but is
uh taking a lot of the stuff that uh was
toxic from merrill lynch which uh
was something they purchased in the wake
of the financial crisis component of
2008 and they're basically putting it on
their deposit side so because banks are
not just big but complex they can be
like you know all this stuff over here
that we don't understand it's going to
lose money we're just going to mix it up
with deposits and that way you really
have to back us in case all of that
fails in case you didn't do that enough
the first time like we're doing it today
like like today this this you know the
fed is approving this so it's not only
that we've learned
nothing we continue to we're going
backwards um right now i think right and
then both parties have an equal hand in
parties quick comment when people
with the protest are accused of being
conspiracy theorists i wish the screen
read this is what they mean
thanks yeah
well yeah i actually um that
just
does sales pretty well i was going to
ask this about stuff that that you know
financial services companies are doing
now um
like there seems to be all this
volatility in the market like there's
this weird thing that
goldman tried to do with facebook there
seems to be some kind of tech bubble
emerging and and there are appear to be
investment banks shorting entire
countries in in europe if i unless i
misunderstand that it's very disturbing
to me that you would bet on the
destruction of italy that's that's i
wouldn't want to win that bet but i
don't know if you have any views about
that
i mean
that stuff is so is such a classic
example of what modern wall street is
all about it's it's like take the
example of greece right like you know
goldman goes into greece and they
and they uh
sell this country a gigantic raft of
interest rate swaps to basically what
are what are interest rate swaps do you
have a country that has a whole bunch of
debt they they can't afford to pay it
right now and it's just really just a
mechanism to push the debt into the
future so that they the the current
spate of politicians doesn't have to
deal with it and the future generation
of politicians has a big bomb that's
going to go off in their face so it's
it's basically this symbiotic deal
between wall street and and the sitting
politicians it's like we'll lend you a
bunch of money now uh as so that future
politicians can give us a big bribe
later well of course goldman does this
deal right which is gonna enormously
destabilizes greece it makes their
long-term outlook extremely negative and
what do they do right away they set up a
mechanism to short grease
because they themselves have sold them
this stuff that is going to blow up and
that's an exact repeat of what happened
in the mortgage industry where they were
selling this stuff then they turned
right around and bet against it and then
when they broke their bookies doing that
and couldn't get their bets paid off
they made us pay it off uh through the
bailouts and that's that's exactly
what's going on with this euro bailout
right now they're going to get somebody
else to pay off those bets and actually
again in terms of history repeating
itself
that day i was telling you about black
thursday six big bankers got into a room
and they decided to pull up the market
they put in their own money it wasn't
federal money but but still put it one
of those was the head of what was chase
at the time now it's jp morgan chase it
was a morgan bank there's chase they've
gotten together
and um
he was in this room and he's like i'll
pledge this
it's you know our stock is going to be
worth it we're going to put in the
market all these you know little people
are going to buy stuff everything is
going to be great and meanwhile he set
up like five companies in like canada
run by you know the names of his
relatives and he's shorting the stock
right this guy's name's al wiggins he's
shorting the stock he's in the room they
call the new york times right after that
wall street you know banker saved the
day blah blah blah the real headlines
all over the place on uh and he's off
shorting the stock and a year later when
the depression starts to really take
hold
he's in europe
trying to figure out how to basically
get money out of
the european side of the crash
right so it's it's exactly the same it's
make money where you can when it falls
apart like move on i mean that that
that's kind of the bonus and again it's
not complicated and i think the one
thing that's one of the good things
that's coming out of the occupy wall
street movement is that um it's showing
you you don't have to know every single
mechanic of every single detail of how
this happens you just have to know that
the impact that the ultimate result is
is bad and that there is a connection
and um
i think that that you know i i show it
in here through lila just understanding
that at a base level like what happens
if one person makes one bad decision on
one bad deal like how that not just
escalates in financial world and in
economy but how that escalates in in
people's real lives every day at home in
their family in in terms of mortality um
and so there are so many
connections
thank you matt
for letting everybody know about how
goldman uh propped up a grease then only
to short it uh a really accurate
portrayal um naomi uh
bill friedman said that the federal
reserve caused a great depression
and i would if you go along with that
line of reasoning that the federal
reserve constricted the or didn't allow
for the
uh uh
monetary uh supplies to increase
if you look at this current crisis would
you say that the federal reserve bears
responsibility as well because of how
they enable the banks to go ahead and
have such an easy supply of money
to lend out
that would allow for the mortgage
industry government bears its
responsibility for creating the
regulations but what uh
burden would you put on the federal
reserve for that and would you propose
the abolishing of the federal reserve
and if you would what would you put in
its place
okay this could be a topic for
this is it's an excellent question so
i'm just going to give a very short
answer though we could honestly talk
about this a lot and it's a really good
question the the federal reserve and and
wall street are symbiotic right there
there is yeah printing money making
making uh the currency cheap giving out
cheap loans
is
what has pumped a lot of the the toxic
asset market it's what's pumped a lot of
speculation it's what's allowed banks to
survive when they shouldn't be solvent
on the other hand it's banks that are
using that money to speculate and
leverage and do all these other things
so it's almost like the nature in which
the fed has enabled
wall street to do what wall street does
in its current form is the danger so it
is totally a symbiotic danger back
in the great depression and i take issue
with ben bernanke's whole i'm a great
depression scholar thing i mean i know
no i mean i know he's written a lot of
papers and he spent a lot of time and
that's fine but but again to go back to
a banker's a personal situation one of
the bankers sitting in that room not the
guy was shorting a stock another one
was also also had a first class a seat
at the new york fed at the time so the
head of what was then citigroup city
national charles mitchell was also
sitting at the new york fed he actually
and this doesn't come up in ben
bernanke's papers
he was actually trying to get the fed to
keep rates low into the crash of 1929 to
keep money cheap and keep the
speculation going because his bank was
going to be screwed
if rates went up when he couldn't handle
that
and he had a lot of stock in his bank
and didn't want that to happen so he
basically
increased
the bubble that became the crash
personally
i mean other people but you know he had
he had a personal impact and right now
we have jamie dimon who's the head of jp
morgan chase who's sitting at the same
seat the same spot at the new york fed
able to have the conversations you know
with tim geithner over there you know to
talk about we need rates low now we need
cheap loans now you know if we don't the
economy is going to get worse or
whatever conversations are happening i
need 30 billion in guarantees to buy the
bears
and and and i'll just keep that forever
by the way let's never talk about the
fact that i only own bear stearns
because the fed i us are you know
financing it and the treasury
department's all okay with that so it's
not
the fact that the fed can both
regulate banks is allowed to tell them
how to behave or not behave to emerge or
not to merge which they never say not
they always say to
and print money when they screw up
is is is a completely yeah
bad economic policy it's morally
hazardous and all of those things so
having the fed being control of
regulating the banking system when it
also is allowed to save it when it
screws up is is just not good for the
rest of the economy
let me just add one really quick thing
about to that i mean one of the
criticisms that people like know that
nominee and i mean got uh
when we talked about all this stuff as
well you know you shouldn't criticize
people at goldman and jp morgan because
these guys are these guys are really
smart they earn their money because
they're the smartest guys in the world
and and they they deserve to get all
that money that they earn because
they're just so smart
if you're if you're borrowing money
billions of dollars from the fed at zero
percent and then you're going out and
lending it
at five percent to the rest of us or 25
in a credit card 29 or 29
and that's how you're making your money
what kind of does it take a genius to do
that
right i mean god i mean a three-year-old
could make a billion dollars if you have
that kind of setup it's it's criminal
with these guys the fed is basically a
gigantic atm machine that all these
banks get to use they get free money and
then they lend it all out to us at
market rates and that's their business
that's how they all that the the
washington called this recapitalizing
the banks
after the crash and that's all it is
it's free money go get yourselves well
and then charge us the market rate and
there's a reason why there's not a lot
of money that comes back out there's a
reason why it's hard to negotiate a
mortgage renegotiated to renegotiate a
student loan or to get a small business
loan
because they
wouldn't want to do that if they can
basically be getting money for free and
and using it in any capacity there's no
there's no attachment there's no there's
no obligation there's no economic
obligation to actually spread it around
and there wasn't back then except then
the the issue was there were more
farmers than other kinds of businessmen
and there was a lot of conversation
which doesn't happen in ben bernanke's
papers about how they were trying to
suppress loans to the farmers which
ultimately also helped create the great
depression and and now it's you know
it's not farmers it's kind of everybody
um and farmers also but but but it's the
same mechanism it's it's the we keep it
low
we restrain when we have problems we get
bailed out when we have problems um and
whatever happens on the outside it's an
accident of nature
it's the economy it's the cycle it's
it's
the
way things are
yeah
i
i have a question um i know what it's
like for a typical day to work in a
bookstore what's it like to work for
demos for a think tank what's it what
how's it structured
okay now naomi works for demos too she's
a senior fellow my my typical day is um
i have a series of long-term projects
i'm working that are related on culture
and politics and i work on those but i
also follow what's going on on a daily
basis
whether it be occupy wall street whether
it be election issues and i'll write and
comment and research on those
so there's no typical day per se but
that's what i typically do
um it's also very much i mean what you
do is it's also very much about what's
happening right now and how these
policies um whether they're on democracy
whether economic policies are impacting
people
right now and rather than just saying
they are actually coming up with you
know good solid information that
people can use
when they talk about the issues
this has been an absolutely incredible
evening thank you all very very much my
question gets back to it something uh
matt said that uh we'd never see these
individuals prosecuted and i hear that
but uh eric schneiderman and beau baden
and there is a group of people who are
trying to defend the bondholders and to
make sure that doesn't happen given
everything that's going on with occupy
wall street where americans are becoming
interested and informed thanks to you
and i hope uh we see an awful lot more
of you all
on tv and everywhere what can we be
doing and how can we institute some sort
of change to see these people pro
prosecuted and also to have a better
future all the way around
that that's that's a good question i
mean the obvious answer is
write letters protest all these things
that you know about i think politicians
are
rapidly becoming aware
that
that if they sweep this whole
foreclosure thing under the rug
that they're playing with fire i mean
there's four million people already out
in the streets because they lost their
homes
and that that's just lighting a fuse if
if they if they decide not to get take
anybody to jail for all that stuff and
and and and also give them immunity from
civil liability
i think they're making a huge mistake
and politicians you know we saw the
attorney general in california has
already doubled back uh i think they're
very very sensitive to public pressure
right now obviously we have a good one
here in new york who's already not going
to jump on board with that but if you're
from another state
uh i think they're listening so you know
letters show public support i think all
that stuff
actually is i mean even though they're
not at that level the senate or the you
know in washington per se i think the
collective pressure that they can exude
if they hear what's going on and they're
doing their jobs um you know prosecuting
at the at the foreclosure fraud level
and also taking that all the way up to
um the ceo level because
that that fraud is something that's that
remains in every single asset that is
created all the way up the line from
the one home and the one mortgage that
might have been fraudulently created to
you know the mega cdo
rap synthetic whatever thing that's on
the other side of that that the fraud
continues it doesn't stop because it's
passed to the next level but i think i
think that
uh i used to say the same thing write
your congressman right and there is
something to be said for that i think
the occupy wall street room is a visible
movement so so help to that actually as
a representative movement of everybody
um is is useful and also the the
attorney general route i've been finding
more and more um is is a good accessible
route as well just really quick on that
uh one of the narratives that that is
that people are trying to the banks are
trying to push about the foreclosure
thing is that this is all about
paperwork this is you know we maybe we
we didn't transfer the deeds properly
that's all this thing is about if that's
not what it's all about this is a
massive systematic cover-up where they
with the what they were talking about is
a
gigantic industry-wide effort at selling
crap as chanel number five uh to to
investors all around and and
if i think a couple of ag's like
schneiderman are they they're on the
scent they recognize that there is a lot
of political hay to be made i mean if
you go down that route with
investigating securitization that whole
aspect of all this they could be making
cases to the next century basically and
i think a lot of smart attorneys general
are real are realizing that that that's
where the that's where the money is and
that and a little push and they'll go
there
you know a um there have been some
prosecutions but they're odd though if a
a ceo or a member of a board of
directors has a fiduciary responsibility
to his shareholders he'll always tell
you that
so if i were a shareholder
and my
ceo when he was about to sell these
this junk
said oh but it'll hurt that little old
lady in the pension fund in minneapolis
i could sue him
i could sue him because he has to put my
fiduciary responsibility first and if
the guy is decent as i'm talking to the
kind of people who are decent what
they'll say is make it against the law
then i won't have to do it in other
words stop me before i kill again
um so there have been some suits but you
know
take think back to enron
the suits were not enron for raising the
price of electricity in california to
the point that it broke the state and
ruined the educational system
but only
when you kept secrets from other
shareholders when you tried to pass it
off on the shareholders so it was only
on behalf of shareholders that suits
have been brought i mean that's really a
shameful system these guys will tell you
i'm not even allowed to think about the
common good yeah but but
i would quit
them we just have to control them i
would i would quibble with that only in
the sense that what these guys were
doing was was criminal it was there was
fraud it was against the law and by and
by doing it it was against the law i
mean i if you're if you're taking if
you're taking a a gigantic batch of
subprime mortgages from countrywide
which you know is a criminal
organization that is that is giving out
loans you have you have information that
you
fraudulent
you are not moving along so you also
know that right so you you know that and
then and then you're knowingly unloading
them on people and not disclosing those
facts you're committing a crime and
that's incurring a much bigger liability
potential liability than missing out on
the profits by not selling that that
thing so i would argue that they they
created a much bigger problem for their
shareholders by doing this than they
than they would have by not doing it and
under securities fraud laws a lot of
this stuff could be prosecuted the whole
reason the sec was created was to
investigate a lot well was to basically
keep the kinds of trust and the kinds of
weird things where we were selling
chanel and calling it chanel and selling
whatever else was inside it that was
basically the sec's job was to
protect the public from
public fraud from the securities that
were created by these institutions that
impact the public being fraudulent you
know so it's it's it's a really yeah
i don't get to prosecute this stuff but
i mean it's it's
it's very
it's much less complicated than they
make it out to be
uh yes um well someone kind of asked a
related question about solutions and
your answer kind of scares me a little
bit because
a lot of what your books are about is
how these solutions aren't working right
so
um
these solutions don't get adopted right
like just presidential uh we think they
could work or i yeah i think
there's some basic solutions the
question do you protect the economy
the general population do you protect
the banking
institutions
my question more is though um
doesn't there need to be a shift in the
way we view these things though because
i think a lot of the problem is like
matt mentions in his book that
there isn't
this isn't seen as criminality by
everybody and so what can we do to kind
of change the mind state of our country
where we actually see this is outright
criminality because i feel like i just
personally i feel like that's a lot of
the problem
and that's probably on the media more
than anything right i mean i i think
yeah i don't think a lot of the media
said that security yeah they've
committed securities fraud securities
fraud is illegal they've committed
illegal acts they should be prosecuted
and penalized yeah we don't we don't see
a lot of that but you know as regards
solutions i think
like there's there's going to be a huge
debate
down the road about things that need to
be done and then and you know the right
is going to have its traditional
solution of
deregulation and and the other the other
side is going to say let's have more
regulation but i think even before we
get there there's a lot of really
obvious steps when we have to end this
sort of unhealthy plutocratic or you
know symbiotic relationship between
government and wall street that but
neither side agrees on i think i don't
think anybody on the right or the left
agrees that our tax dollars should be
going to pay lloyd blankfein's bonus
right i mean that i don't think nobody
agrees to that nobody nobody believes
that uh you know stevie cohen or george
soros or john paulson should be paying
half the tax rate of a fireman or a
teacher
i think that's something that everybody
can agree upon so there are a lot of
things break up the banks a lot of
things that are obvious solutions and
then there's you know the more
complicated policy discussion down the
road yeah one of the reasons i wrote a
novel instead of the nonfiction this
time around was because there's that
know you sometimes have to take a break
from like yelling about the solutions
for for like almost
however many years i've been doing this
it was sort of like let me let me go
into at least another time another
period look at this a different way you
know touch a human side of it because
the solutions aren't
that difficult either it's it's it's the
will to get there
that's the will problem
hi
my name is george uh i've been down to
occupy wall street a number of times and
uh my contribution is in a pictorial i'd
like to hand it to you
uh
it made uh
meet the press in um
in their first 15 seconds of last two
sundays ago
i hung that uh that's a skeleton holding
a um
a placard saying throw me some crumbs
and i think it's how the 99 certainly
feel it's been very well photographed uh
my question though i'm trying to get the
group down there to focus on what i
think are the two most important
overarching initiatives which dylan
radigan seems to have one covered and
that's uh campaign finance reform but i
think that's going to be a really
i think that's going to be a really
difficult thing to do a constitutional
amendment it's going to be carefully
written
with uh you know tricky parameters and
the worst part is that we need both of
our illustrious politicians
to vote on it and now since the uh debt
ceiling crisis when they played
political chicken with each other we
don't seem to have any confidence in
either one of them so my question to you
if it's a question sort of is do you
think that campaign finance reform is
one of the best ways to go about fixing
what's wrong with our government or do
we also need uh to actually change our
voting system from single vote into
something like score voting to level the
playing field so that third and fourth
party candidates will have an equal
chance to win this and we'll be able to
actually vote instead of having being
forced to feel that we have to vote for
the
democrat or the republican we'll be able
to actually vote for anybody that we
want to and everybody that we want to
and pick the guys who are the more
generally preferred moderate centrists
when they're they're not even on the
ballot now
so that's sort of a question
thank you yeah i mean i think just a
real simple answer that yeah if if we
get
money out of politics
that leaves
real issues and real solutions and real
activities in politics and um and so you
know the campaign finance reform the
fact that we went in the again this is
another thing the last few years we go
in the opposite direction of what makes
sense to be more palatable for the
general population and and the supreme
court decision regarding campaign
finance reform is just another example
of a recent happening of that so if the
people that run
are
you know require the money that comes in
from whether it's corporate sponsorship
or wall street and president obama this
year a second largest um group
contributor is is the financial industry
um so you know if they're keeping your
you or your job
you're gonna
sort of do what you need to do to to
stay in power and and so that definitely
should be disconnected
just just really quickly on that um
you know from my own personal experience
from covering the dodd-frank bill and
when i was down in the senate um at that
time really interesting
statistic the financial services
industry had 2 000 lobbyists in the
halls of congress during that bill the
other side
which was like americans for financial
reform had 60 volunteer lobbyists
and i was
i remember very distinctly being in one
senator's office actually one of our
senators
and not having room to stand in the in
the waiting room because there were so
many industry lobbyists in the in the
waiting room uh so
the problem of money in this whole i
mean look there was a lot of reforms
that got
passed in the dodd-frank bill despite
this avalanche of money that got thrown
at all these these members of congress
which just shows you how
you know it was what they were asking
for was so wrong
and and the other side was so was so
appealing to the to whatever was left of
the conscience of these congressional
members
that they actually did do a few things
despite the fact that all the money was
on one side and none of it was on the
other side so i think if you can get
some at least even half the money out
you'll you'll start to see a lot of
movement and i think it you know that's
something
question here
okay
hi uh just by the way matt to your point
about the greek uh swap deal the goldman
partner who arranged that is now the
head of the public debt management
agency for greece the socialist
government by the way
yeah hey um
nami do you really think that dodd-frank
deconcentrates financial power or
doesn't it re-concentrate it by making
it uh further concentrated by raising
the transaction costs to a point where
and complexity to a point where only the
largest institutions can navigate
through it
well i think even more than that the
dodd-frank bill does does nothing to
change the current complexity or size it
does not split up banks it does not
reduce their ability to create complex
assets and call them
gold when they are not
it does it i i don't find the dodd-frank
bill does very much of of anything that
will be meaningful at all
um so
i think one
one member of congress that i talked to
had a great way of describing what
happened with dodd frankfurt's everyone
here read old man in the sea yeah uh you
know so the guy from schumer goes out he
catches this huge fish and he's all
stoked about it and then he starts going
back to shore and by the time he gets
back to shows like a skeleton left
behind the boat that's exactly what
happened at dodd-frank there are all
these great ideas
that came out in the beginning and by
the time all the lobbyists got done with
that bill there was literally nothing
left that all got eaten away in those
last minute discussions behind the
scenes and that was a sort of a classic
example of how the public doesn't really
see how the real work gets done all
those public things we saw in c-span and
uh the arguments on the floor of the
house that really it just disappeared in
the middle of the night in those
committee discussions which was really
really sad though we did have a point in
time where they they did pass so i mean
they didn't now which is again very sad
for now but when they did pass in 1933
they did create a somewhat more stable
banking system
economic environment and so
again those solutions exist the the
problem is getting
them to happen
okay
[Music]
before that we have one another thing to
talk about
the um thank you to the tenant museum
we're kind of strand bookstores kind of
going oprah winfrey but one person under
their seat has a two-person membership
for the tenement museum for
for one year
and umi's
research for the town
so thank you so much rich know me and
matt for such a spirited and you guys
for great questions spirited discussion
crime is about an hour
welcome
i'm pleased to have with me today a wall
street insider and renowned journalist
author and speaker nomi prince
having worked at chase manhattan bank
lehman brothers bear stearns and as a
managing director at goldman sachs
naomi prince had a distinguished career
on wall street and has only
distinguished herself further by sharing
her expertise
via the written and spoken word
widely sought after by major media
outlets nomie has written a number of
acclaimed works
including other people's money
it takes a pillage in black tuesday
she joins me today to discuss her most
recent work all the president's bankers
the hidden alliances that drive american
power
nomi welcome and congratulations on such
a fabulous book
as we take a look into washington wall
street
and the families that have had such an
enormous impact on our nation and the
world
thank you so much larry thank you for
that lovely introduction as well
my pleasure and it was very easily done
again given the uh the fabulous career
that you've had uh both on wall street
and now off wall street uh in the
literary world so it's truly a pleasure
to have you let's dive right in
uh
this is truly an incredible and i would
say an unparalleled written history
of the the relationships between wall
street the large banks that have
dominated uh
our nation and washington
what motivated you to take on such an
incredible amount of effort and exercise
to produce this book um a slight bit of
insanity i think given the amount of
time i spent working on it and the
intensity
but but actually the novel i had written
black tuesday which was a historical
novel on the crash of 29
had a scene in it that i had researched
slightly nothing near the research i did
for this book on six bankers that had
gotten together at the house of morgan
on 23 wall street one noon
to decide to try and save the markets
that were crashing around them in late
october 1929 by themselves and a fellow
named tom lamont who was the acting
chair of the morgan bank at the time his
real chair jack morgan was gallivanting
around the world he was elsewhere
gathered five other bankers together the
most powerful families of bankers
running the most powerful banks on wall
street to say we need to do something to
save these markets and they decided with
just 20 minutes
to throw in 25 million dollars each into
a buying pool tell one of their guys to
go and buy a lot of stock and basically
by themselves try to boost this market
that was falling all around them and i
just found that really fascinating this
idea of these big six banks and i
started to notice that well today we
have six banks and i looked back in time
just cursory analysis and there were six
banks a hundred years ago in the panic
of 1907 and they were all largely the
same banks in the first part of the
century also the same families now
similar legacies um but i started to say
well what is that relationship um and i
was fascinated in general with other
works i had done with the political
association of bankers and so what i
decided to do is take a look at the
history of that period and look at the
real relationships between six bankers
whoever the most important one was at
any point in time in our nation's
history during that century and what
their connections were to presidents and
what i found because i didn't know that
every single president
from teddy roosevelt through barack
obama had strong associations not always
with the six key bankers but certainly
with a subset at least of six bankers
through documents and letters and phone
calls and all sorts of other forms of
communication as well as social
connections through clubs and and
harvard and other types of places where
they would meet
clearly relationships are everything i
and whether people want to promote those
relationships or not
but can let's let's take a step and go
behind the scenes
uh and you know
could you take us you know uh into your
research where did you go uh whom did
you meet
to to you know unearth some truly
incredible material
yeah i decided to go to all of the
presidential libraries to to make the
research very even and always start from
the president out to whether they had
associations with particular bankers so
for every period in time i wanted to
make sure that at least had the
appropriate historical events that would
have occurred at that time for example i
used to joke with my editor carl bromley
at nation books and i would say i just
don't want to forget that world war one
happened you know i don't want to forget
about vietnam so what i did was i had a
sort of outline of major events that
happened and each president of course
and treasury secretary and i went to all
the archives all the presidential ar
archives where the material existed
throughout the country for example i was
at abilene kansas in in one hot august
working with the archives of president
dwight eisenhower from where i went to
independence missouri to look at the
archives of president truman i started
actually in austin with lbj and i went
back to austin several times throughout
the period of research because i found
that that period very critical in terms
of relationships and changing attitudes
in america between presidents and
bankers citizens and presidents and and
so forth um and i really just dug in
deep and i didn't know what i would find
in some cases i had to
submit foia's freedom of information
acts to
unearth certain documents for the for
the more recent presidents that had not
been unearthed yet
in some cases for example the reagan
library in california the archivist
really kind of took my project to heart
and and spent some of her own
time really trying to look for documents
for me as i was sitting there going
through the boxes that i had um when you
do research they bring out carts and
boxes and it's almost like a race you
know you're going through the boxes
you're like what can i find and and
there could be anything in a box so with
harry truman there could be anything
from letters about
you know why did you drop the atomic
bomb to
letters from bankers saying thank you
very much for your support and him
writing back to them saying i couldn't
have done it without you and so there's
there's all sorts of things that you
find and you just get into this mode of
being in that time and that president
with those people
going through just just an immense
amount of documents and then and then
sort of typing everything up while
you're there typing it up at night
editing throughout the process and then
sort of going on to the next location
and the next president were there any
libraries that were that you deem to be
somewhat reluctant to to share
information
um well a lot of um until reagan
actually from fdr through the reagan um
library era there was there's a certain
code
under which everything is classified you
know for military information for
finance information economics personal
relationships and it's a very clear code
with very clear um identifications and
it's very almost easy um taxes
information the carter library for
example i went there
shortly after the film argo came out
and there had been apparently a whole
team of like argo researchers down there
slightly before that movie looking up
information about
the iran hostage crisis and what
happened and they had this this cool
rack system where you could go in and
actually look um digitally at a lot of
documents not every library has that but
then when some of the more recent
libraries for example the clinton
library there's very little already
opened and part of that's because
there's just such an immense amount of
information and plus now you have email
and everything needs to go through
security clearances and it's in a
different code after reagan came in the
codes changed um so it was a lot harder
to find information the reason i could
find it in the reagan library was
because the archivist had worked at one
of the prior libraries so she kind of
knew
the difference between the new codes and
the and old schools she could help me um
but i i still have four years
outstanding at the clinton library i
still have foyers outstanding at the
george bush library in texas and of
course the george w bush library just
opened so i i didn't have the
opportunity to look at anything there
and obama's still in office yep yep
was there a point in time where the
the picture started to uh or the started
to sharpen in terms of the
uh the nature of some of these
relationships
uh where it it really
where you started to realize
wow this actually goes deeper than
perhaps
uh either yourself as well as the public
uh would have imagined or might even
still imagine yeah and because i didn't
really start at the beginning of the
presidents i kind of worked more on
geography and flight patterns okay um i
was doing a little bit of jumping back
and forth and so for example yeah i
would go to the lbj library and i would
see his relationship
with sydney weinberg who was the
chairman of goldman sachs at the time
and then i would be at the fdr library
and see how they had been very close
friends because something lbj had said
to sydney weinberg in the 60s i.e we
were both fdr men back then it's so good
to have you on my team again even of
course he wasn't in office anywhere they
were just you know on the same team
and then when i went to the fdr library
to see for example the beginnings of
that relationship so a lot of times
starting in the middle of history and
going backwards allowed me to then catch
up in the middle and and go to those
same bankers and see what their
relationships with all the presidents in
between um and what i found in many
instances if you had a relationship with
one president you've had a relationship
um with many and then going back further
in time
i mentioned in the beginning how tom
lamont was the
chairman at j.p morgan during the crash
in 1929 i knew that from black tuesday
what i didn't know and i found this out
when i was at the fdr library
in hyde park which is very near where i
grew up as well i got gone there as a
kid but certainly not at research
expeditions
he actually had rented out his town
house on east 65th street in manhattan
to thomas lamont for several years while
fdr was the assistant navy secretary
under woodrow wilson
so the tie
that happened after the crash into the
great depression when fdr was then
president had started way back they had
both gone to harvard
they had both been involved with the
crimson harvard paper over there tom
lamont had actually been one of the
editors a very young editor of that
paper when he was at harvard um and they
had a very long history which then
lasted through several decades and so
he just kind of there was this onion
effect where you would just layer and
layer and it wouldn't necessarily be
history going forward it was history
going backward and a lot of decades and
relationships in between so the
relationships really uh
went from not only the business and the
political but often into the social as
well then yeah exactly one of the other
bankers for example winthrop aldrich who
ran chase during the great depression
was was a friend of the roosevelts and
he was also a yachtsman one of his boats
won the american cup back in 1930 or
something like that so yes um so there
was there was all that going on back
then as well and and fdr and his sons
also were interested in that and so um
and of course jp morgan had you know a
tremendous yacht at the time sort of the
equivalent of what we have now with
larry ellison um and so there was there
was similar
tastes as well that that came into play
um and so there were social
gatherings um going forward in history
for example in 1938
fdr had at this point appointed a
well-known name well-known family named
joseph kennedy
to be
the first head of the sec when it was
created and also he appointed him to be
the uk ambassador in the late 30s after
uh joe kennedy was head of the sec so
now joe kennedy's off in england he's
having a gala coming out party very
lovely huge social event for his
daughter kathleen who unfortunately died
young as part of another kennedy tragedy
but john f kennedy a young john f
kennedy was at that event david
rockefeller who was part of a long
history of industrial financial
family
strength uh was also there in fact he
somewhat dated kathleen kennedy for a
minute back at the time and so the ties
these connections were
you know went through all sorts of
social events that
people wouldn't be involved so again
it's not just the social and the
individuals but as you're just alluding
to the strength of the families as well
and those family ties that run deep i
mean the morgan the rockefellers these
kennedys
the roosevelts james roosevelt fdr's
father and jp morgan the immensely
famous and powerful jp morgan created
together among few other um
established families the metropolitan
club in new york which was a very
exclusive club where
these men could get together and talk
about affairs of the day and decide
things in a very small tight environment
board is on board is on royalty almost
it really was i mean when you think
about even the terms today that are used
for you know ascension the throne of the
hierarchy of you know the terms that we
use even um in industry and banking
today you know who's gonna who's the
heir to the throne of jp morgan chase
but even the terminology um has that
sense of monarchy to it and certainly
back in the beginning of the 20th
century and throughout a good portion of
it there was really three or four
families that that were most
instrumental in running the top three
financial institutions in the country
that also had the tightest personal and
political financial connections with the
presidents over that time although in
some cases the difference is that these
people don't get elected they are
they're family appointed
um one of the other families the
stillmans who were running uh national
citibank back in the early part of the
20th century and of course national
citibank is now part of what we know a
city group
you know he had two daughters they
married two sons of uh one of the
rockefellers and together they they
produced a stillman rockefeller that
then ran
what was uh citibank in the late 50s and
early 60s so you know these lines blood
is thicker than water right absolutely
and sometimes money sure or connected
yeah yep well i guess when they combine
all of them you know blood money power
becomes uh it's game of thrones it's a
game of thrones and ends up in exactly
an incredible book let's go back to uh
towards the beginning of the book uh set
the scene for us please
we go off the coast of georgia to a
place called jekyll island
what happened who was involved what came
out of it
and were the motivations of the people
in your opinion were they truly pure and
sincere
so there's a lot there
they were sincere for themselves no what
happened was
at jekyll island in november of 1910
there was a meeting that was called by
senator nelson aldrich all churches were
also a very uh famous
powerful political family that
integrated into being a political
financial family
and nelson aldrich as the senate finance
chairman was tasked with trying to
create a central bank that would appease
the public as well as pass politically
in washington and the reason for that
was there had been a panic a major bank
panic in 1907 a few years before that at
which teddy roosevelt had asked j.p
morgan to get his people together to try
and save the markets
it's a little bit different today where
the government works to save the bankers
then it was the government calling the
bankers to try and help the general
economy and
after that panic and after jp morgan got
a bunch of his friends together to
decide which banks or trust companies
could live or die and how much money
each had to pony up to back them up he
was a little afraid and thought you know
i i don't want to have to do this
exercise again i would prefer a central
bank as well so the bankers adopted this
idea of having a central bank to help
subsidize or stabilize them so that they
wouldn't have to put their own money in
whether or not they had caused the panic
and from a government standpoint
teddy roosevelt didn't talk about it so
much but when taft came in as president
he very much pushed this idea of having
a central bank and nelson aldrich and
the aldridge family was close to the
taft family and they basically decided
that they would uh do these expeditions
into europe see what was going on with
the bank of england see what was going
on in with france and see if america
couldn't duplicate something that was
more american
but still enable them to have this this
powerful central bank to back bankers
and also to back the emerging currency
that was going to be the most powerful
currency in the world the dollar so fast
forward a few years of
fact-finding and you know traveling
around europe and nelson aldridge went
around with james stillman quite quite
often who was the head of national city
bank and he got back and lots of report
files lots of documents but things
weren't at an official level jekyll
island happened because it was time to
make it official
and
jp morgan said you know you need to do
this somewhere somewhat privately only
after nelson aldrich was hit by a
trolley car
on madison avenue he was in new york he
was discussing things with bankers his
son winthrop eldridge lived in new york
as well and uh he got hit on 60th street
by this madison avenue trolley car so he
was a bit convalesced it had been
planned to have a big meeting at his
estate in rhode island um but now he's
in new york he's with the bankers and
morgan has this club membership at the
jekyll island club off the coast of
georgia and really sponsored which is
something i found out when i went myself
to jekyll island sponsored this six
people again
um to
work together at in secrecy
away from
eyes
to
bash out this idea of the fed now the
the sort of cloak and dagger stuff i
think is a little bit
exaggerated i mean it wasn't like you
had paparazzi sort of flying in and at
jekyll island it's generally
at the time it was off of the
coast you couldn't really get there and
you certainly couldn't drive there
and there were posts of men watching if
boats came in to make sure that they
couldn't even
dock near the jekyll island club so it
was it was a pretty secure place already
any
um and that's where they bashed out the
plan and at the end of them bashing out
this plan nelson's going to go back to
washington to present it to the senate
and what happens was
um
he was still not feeling well from the
trolley car situation
and so what occurred was two of the
bankers who had been at the meeting
frank vanderlip who was the number two
at national city
bank
and uh henry davidson who was one of the
senior partners at the morgan bank
actually presented the plan to
washington
which i did not know either this was
something i discovered in the book so it
wasn't even the bankers planned this
whole thing and were there which they
were they actually went to washington to
to present
the findings
the actual federal reserve
act that was passed ultimately under
woodrow wilson looked a little bit
different from that plan but it had a
lot of of a lot of similar aspects of it
you know this idea of a central bank um
the concession was that there would be a
new york fed which would be close and
has continued to be close to the wall
street banks and then there would be the
federal reserve on which the president
would appoint the chairman and so there
was kind of this idea of a balance of
power and everybody was was happy and
there's a whole bunch of stuff in the
book about all the maneuverings at
midnight and 1am in the white house
until that finally did get passed and
signed under wilson i mean clearly the
federal reserve is uh
you know a lightning rod especially
currently given a lot of the
quantitative easing programs that are
going on but right from its right from
its outset
uh it's always been promoted as an
independent
institution
in your opinion can it be independent
you know given the nature of the
relationships as you have laid out i
mean
uh exquisitely in your book
um no it's it's it's really naive to to
think it can be independent one because
the very structure has member banks
within each of the federal reserve banks
sort of owning shares in the federal
reserve as as a full entity so that's
number one there's sort of an even
ownership uh type of relationship there
but beyond that the philosophical
relationship which is really the strong
one
that started
back in jekyll island and has gone
through today it's our actually benjamin
strong was the first head of speaking of
strong the new york fed he was one of
the guys who had been at jekyll island
so he got to be head of the new york fed
and paul warburg who was another of the
men that was at jekyll island that
meeting was appointed
by woodrow wilson to be
one of the governors of the first
federal reserve and from the beginning
through through world war one so so from
the get-go there was a connection
between
how it was established why it was
established and the appointments
that were allowed and
physically done by the president at the
time and that really hasn't changed
there's never been a suggested
appointment that's come through a
president that has not been accepted by
congress who was supposed to have an
extra say in this it's always been a
very slam dunk kind of situation larry
summers recently kind of took his name
out of the plate and other stuff
happened there but for the most part
historically
every time a president wanted someone at
the
helm of the federal reserve it happened
and from the beginning
these people
tended to be bankers particularly
on the new york fed which is the most
powerful component of the federal
reserve system remains a a fascinating
topic and uh again all the calls for
transparency relative to opacity so
there's there's certainly more uh that's
always to be studied there yeah and bill
grider's book you know secrets of the
temple was something that really
inspired me i could have spent a lot
more time on the relationships in the
earlier years in the fed but he did such
a
exquisite job on that that i will give
him i have it where it has there you go
obviously having studied extensively the
the president's as well as the bankers
uh
in your opinion you know have there been
a couple of presidents either who really
stood out in your eyes as being
truly you know magnanimous in their uh
in the way that they've executed their
office or you know on the on the other
end of the spectrum
uh you know woefully weak and in far too
uh
willing to turn over the reins of power
to the bankers
um well back in the 20s you know before
the the crash in 1929 we had a
succession of presidents from harding
through calvin coolidge through herbert
hoover all of whom
um just just allowed
the who were their friends also to do
what they wanted to do because they
believed this was important after world
war one
not just for financial power but for
america's emergence as a political
superpower that if you had banks who
could expand who could you know
basically do what they said they needed
to do to become strong themselves and
that was good for america in general
which is actually a theme that continues
to exist through today then it was very
specific because of the post-war it was
the emergence of you know america the
superpower
calvin coolidge did really
nothing to thwart any of this i mean he
he was famously talking about how uh you
know the business of america is his
business um but also his treasury
secretary actually the treasury
secretary that served
for harding and coolidge and hoover
andrew mellon
was himself
a banker and himself believed that it
was important to allow
the banking community to do what it
needed to do which meant not having any
real rules and and the ultimate result
of that was a tremendous amount of
speculation after world war one that
ultimately led to a tremendous crash
which ultimately led to a great
depression so so those presidents had
relationships but they they didn't
really try to use them to get anything
back from the bankers um yeah just going
further forward in history lbj was
someone who didn't really come from the
same eastern establishment
societal connections as as some of the
main bankers of his time but he was such
a master politician
that he
understood how to sort of
stroke the the personalities and the
positions of the people
in power and banking at the time as well
as get stuff done so he was very much a
man about you know i will yeah if he i
will pass i will or i will not you know
i will not restrict you i will not worry
about your competitors you know smaller
types of financial service firms who
think you have too much power i'm gonna
i'm gonna not play in any of that i will
let you do what you need to do but you
need to support my great society you
need to not say anything negative in the
press you know you need to be on my side
um and that even continued into the
beginning of the vietnam war there were
a lot of bankers who helped raise money
in the beginning of that war um they
subsequently turned against him and
things started to unravel towards the
end of his of his
second term but he just knew how to
use the relationship to work for
a broader
public interest as well as
allow the idea of financial strength to
continue so he was very good at doing
that not having had as many
long-standing connections as someone
like fdr who also did a lot of that
had when he worked on his policies
let's stick with that topic there of the
wars i mean the 20th century we had the
the the two great wars we had uh you
know a korean crisis the vietnam war as
well but then also the the the cold war
you know what sort of uh of role
uh did the banks and these bankers play
in terms of you know our nation's
involvement both pre and then post-war
yeah i mean it goes back to the the
woodrow wilson uh thomas lamont
relationship
back um during the end of world war one
well first the morgan bank itself worked
with wilson and the treasury secretary
at the time to finance 75
of the private investment that went into
funding allies for
war related arsenals and so forth so
there was already a very strong
alignment between the morgan bank and
the white house
very regular very
much an idea of that money that needed
to go into the war effort was going to
be
consolidated through through the private
bank
and then of course there was war bonds
where individuals across the country
were
asked to invest in the war invest in
america and so forth and ultimately that
helped banks grow because they had new
customers after the wars um and then in
second world war they sort of tried to
do the same thing there were some
different people at the helms of the
major banks and at this point
winthrop aldrich who was running chase
really stepped into the forefront
because of his relationship with fdr and
the chase bank became as well as
national citibank there was a
relationship with the vice chairman of
national city bank burgess with
morgenthau who was the treasury
secretary under fdr during world war ii
that allowed these institutions to
continue private financing of the war
but also a much larger blanket approach
to getting individuals to buy war bonds
and take out accounts in these banks at
the same time so that was the way they
sort of combined helping the country
expanding their presence and getting new
customers
but then by the time you got to the cold
war all these new customers are there
and the policy of america under truman
and under eisenhower was to make sure
that communism could not prevail
basically throughout the world and that
capitalism would be the dominant
ism
and
in eisenhower's doctrine he basically
states that you know america would stand
ready to to fight
from a military perspective or an
economic perspective or what he said was
a trade perspective in order to protect
its its allies effectively the ones that
were on the sort of capitalist side of
the equation that really helped the
bankers because now the sudden they have
military support to expand their
branches into these countries and as a
result of the beginning of the cold war
they expanded into cuba before castro
came in and and
nationalized the banks out of cuba they
expanded into beirut because that was
going to be a stronghold at one point
into the rest of the middle east and all
of this was done with the protection of
the u.s military
so the whole idea the whole reason the
international aspect of banking happened
particularly with these major banks was
the connections that they had into
presidents and policies um and they also
were on the pulpit to promote these
policies winthrop aldrich went around
the country talking about
the truman's marshall plan and helping
and aiding countries that were on the
side
of the u.s and so forth and open trade
and free trade so there was a there was
an extensive alignment amongst people
that knew each other and had similar
interests and used each other to expand
truly fascinating stuff i mean so you
talk about that sense of alignment
and uh you know clearly coming out of
the depression there was this you know
this anti-banker you know look what you
just did to us in terms of speculation
uh
you know working our way though into
world war ii where this this sense of
collaboration
uh
and you know now it seems to have come
full circle again so i mean it's this
this
cycles these ups and downs
uh you know are the bankers in your
opinion though at uh
you know trying how do they balance that
that that profit uh motive and incentive
uh versus you know national interest
yeah and and that that is a big cycle
that was something that was very
interesting to me in the book i mean the
fact that aldridge was working with fdr
for example to pass the glass-steagall
act which tremendously reformed banking
and reduced the ability of banks to
speculate with other people's money with
depositors funds was was really
interesting to me because you wouldn't
assume
on the surface that would happen but
under the surface it does make sense
because if we have a more stable economy
for everybody
then a banker who understands that that
is actually good that a ground-up
stability is actually good not just for
the country but also for
his bank
actually wins in in the profit stakes
because you know look today jp morgan
chase is the most powerful bank in the
world certainly the most powerful bank
in the united states so the fact that
winthrop aldrich pushed his bank to be
split up in the 30s because he
yeah on the one hand he wanted to take
over his his uh competitors and sort of
be the guy and have the bank that did
that and have the government backing but
on the other hand it worked jp morgan
chase exists today so so that sort of
gamble that profit motive um
worked out but so these guys were you
know aldrich lamont these guys were out
in in europe doing uh food drives and
and trying to uh lamont spent a lot of
time trying to um raise money in
congress after world war ii to help the
chinese who are impoverished and so
forth so there was a really different
mentality of what you could do for your
country as well as balancing uh what you
wanted to do in terms of your own power
and your own profit from from from the
banks and and working together with with
presidents to sort of have everyone
aligned on the same page i mean today
what we have you know several decades of
the dissolution of this in between is is
nothing yeah remotely like that you
can't imagine you know jamie dimon going
off and running food drives like leaving
his posts for you months to to help
anyone you know so it's it's a really
different
form of
patriotism that existed then versus not
existing
now and also it's not demanded from the
presidency you know then there was this
idea of i'll do this for you all open
markets for you do this for me this will
be good for the country with mistakes
along the way um and now there isn't
even an expectation
there is an accountability there isn't a
demand to have that kind of a
relationship well to that point uh
was there you know a point in time where
you you sensed or or could pinpoint
where the the balance of power
shifted in these relationships
yeah i was it was it was two points it
kind of happened i think in in in two
stages one um after this period of
alignment between fdr through through
eisenhower um where the needs of
what the political needs and the
financial needs and the individuals were
all on the same page and and very
closely connected and in in conference
and everything
you had jfk come in and of course he did
on a family basis he he certainly had
relationships
with the people that were rising at the
major banks but he was a little bit sort
of standoffish about the idea of asking
them for favors okay um and as a result
they weren't as nice to him
publicly
in fact in 1962
david rockefeller um wrote a very sort
of well they had a famous set of letters
that were published in life magazine
between uh
rockefeller and jfk where on the surface
they looked like they were being
collaborative but actually if you read
the the text it sounds like david
rockefeller is kind of critical of um
some of the initiatives of of jfk in
particular uh with respect to latin
america jfk didn't want to you know
fully
have latin america open to the private
interests of
individual companies he thought that
they should be strong rather than you
know simply pushing uh their leaders to
to be open whereas david rockefeller and
another walter risden and people that
were coming into the folds of the major
banks at the time um saw this as a
tremendous opportunity you know you had
cheap commodities it was right next door
branches were going up left and right
and they really wanted the government to
support much more of their private
endeavors and jfk kind of thought that
latin america should be strong on its
own so that was kind of a divergence but
then of course he was assassinated and
lbj came in and as i mentioned before
lbj had this
uh first of all he was much more about
sort of private interests
internationally and he much more
supported what the bankers wanted to do
and he had many more personal um
he knew how to stroke their egos too
there was a lot of invitations a lot of
back and forth between weinberg between
david rockefeller between
members of national citibank in and out
of the white house you know invited to
his ranch he had these monthly elite
dinners in washington where he would
invite very particular members of the
financial and other types of business
communities to make them just feel like
they were all on the same side um and
actually even after kennedy was shot and
lbj came into power there was there was
tremendous support he had more public
support in the press and on wall street
um
to help because they thought that he
would be supportive of what they wanted
to do so again it got back to connected
nixon was a bit more like jfk which a
lot of people don't wouldn't say
but from from from the standpoint of
you know this collaboration he didn't
want any part of that at two points
during his presidency for example though
he did
suggest that david rockefeller should
become treasury secretary and walter
wriston should become treasurer ask them
to become treasury secretaries uh they
both said no they're busy expanding
their their their homes but also he
didn't ask them personally you know
whereas lbj would get on the phone have
an invitation have a dinner invite him
to the white house be all buddy buddy
you know how's your daughter doing he
just didn't do that um and at that point
they they had gotten together and
thought all right well we can take
policy
from here and they actually push nixon
and people in his cabinet to get off the
gold standard which which happened in
the beginning of nixon's presidency and
all sorts of other things that now they
started making demands without
feeling they needed to to give anything
in return and i could don't they there's
a lot of stuff on the book you know that
that then devolves into the middle east
oil and all sorts of other things that
came out of that
disalignment got it
so was it was it your sense you know uh
at that point in time that the bankers
felt you know what i actually have more
power where i i'm currently situated
then one might think
that they would have in whether it's as
the head of uh treasury or elsewhere in
washington
yeah that was exactly it they were they
had just gone through this expansion
they were still going through it there
was consolidation in the banking
industry
because no none of the presidents that
got in the way of having that
consolidation and concentration happened
so it was much more
lucrative from power and influences well
as a money standpoint money wasn't even
really the thing it was more about the
influence and the power
um to to not have to
um
work on sort of a public international
interest side and um and having having
access to petro dollars to oil in the
middle east in the 70s was also a big
point of departure in this because all
of a sudden you don't necessarily need
the backing of the military to open up
branches you just have all this extra
money
that you can then refunnel around the
world which it turned out went into
uh the form of debt in latin america and
ultimately caused a third world debt
crisis which was bailed out by the
government so it started to really
dissect
let's stick with that theme right there
this this whole concept of bailouts
obviously i mean we had the massive
bailout in 2008 and the american public
is you know never again we you know we
can't if we can't do that you know just
stay away from it and washington
promotes we've taken care of that so you
know we'll never have to have another
bailout 2008 was not an individual event
i mean we've had uh whether is the
bailout of penn central the bailout of
third world debt
savings and loans mexican bailout
long-term capital management can you
talk about the the role that uh you know
all those bailouts had in terms of
behaviors within these banks yeah
those those bailouts
were really
open invitations to
have another crisis
because if you if you risk
money and it either isn't yours
to begin with to take that risk or you
know someone else i.e the government is
going to the taxpayers is going to have
your back and
you're consolidating and merging and
increasing your your base of deposits
and of capital you can work with because
you're getting more and more
citizens money in as well
you tend to
do things that are stupid and that are
reckless and that are illegal and or
some combination of those things and the
snl crisis was an
example of
deregulation in certain types of
financial
instruments and services that
enabled lots of speculation at the time
and mortgages as well which we saw
repeated in the subprime crisis more
recently um but the third world debt
crisis was showed bankers that they
could they basically stonewalled
washington and said you know we have all
these billions of dollars on the hook
these countries are right next to us if
you don't help us if you don't help the
world bank which is supposed to be an
independent institution help us
everything's going to go to hell and the
american people will suffer and so this
idea of you know if you don't help us
the americans will suffer so help us but
we won't help back here we go was
manifested by all of these of all of
these bailouts and by presidents
um
from
reagan through bush through clinton
through bush through obama who just
really got on board with that
um
continually play that card that you know
help us so we can help them yeah help us
so we and and that obviously doesn't
happen and we're still bailing out the
big six banks in particular because um
the way that the federal reserve works
uh the quantitative easing the fact that
the federal reserve continues to buy
securities from these banks supposedly
you know we're like
six years almost after this crisis
happened that's that's a tremendous
amount of help and the government the
government was helping everybody sort of
pay their mortgage instead of buying
mortgage securities from the banks it
would be a very different stability in
the overall economy rather than of the
big banks yep well then let's let's
compare and contrast then if we could
the the regulations that were put in
place back in the 1930s post the the 29
crash versus what we've seen
uh here post the 2008 crash with
dodd-frank
what's your take on that right well the
glass-steagall act that was passed in
1933 after fdr came to power
was a very clear
line
between
the speculative
versions and services and things that a
bank could do
and the deposits it took and the
services it provided to regular
individuals and small businesses there
was a very very
clear distinction one does not connect
and as i mentioned before
the key bankers of that time two of them
actually winthrop aldrich i mentioned
and james perkins also a friend of fdr's
who came in to run national citibank
after his predecessor charles mitchell
was such a crook
um
also was on the same page as fdr one of
the one the fascinating things i found
in the research in the fdr
papers
was that they had meetings james perkins
was at the white house
three days after the inauguration
talking
to fdr about how he would split up his
bank first
he would tell his shareholders this is
how it's going to go
and he did and so did aldrich before
the glass-steagall act was actually
signed in the summer of 1933.
so that's what happened there was a fine
line
between betting and traditional services
the bankers were on the same side as fdr
the population was on the same side as
fdr and and things became stable for
many many decades several decades after
that
you contrast that to what happened in
the wake of the 2008 crisis which has
been a much more expensive crisis for
the general economy for the actual
unemployment level not the sort of
tagline unemployment level
for what was lost to individuals
throughout and relative to the bailouts
and subsidies that have been given since
and dodd-frank came along and did
nothing remotely
like dissecting speculation
from
depositors and traditional banking
activities deposits and loans nothing
it's really really long
it has lots and lots of pages yeah and
it does absolutely
nothing significant it's a huge
difference
where's do we have the political will do
we have the do we have the leadership in
your estimation in washington to take on
that battle
no i mean we have president obama
basically said it was sweeping reform so
if you can look at something that is not
sweeping reform and compare it to
something that fdr did which was
sweeping reform and say that sort of
with a straight face and have your
treasury secretary tim geithner say that
with a straight face um then no we we
don't have the leadership that either
would do anything hasn't done anything
to to stabilize the situation um yet
it's pretending that it has which is
actually more dangerous than not doing
anything sure
um and i don't see anyone really coming
into play right now in terms of you know
the potentials we have or that are being
debated in terms of who might run for
for president in 2016 that would change
that at all so um we
we don't have a leadership that that is
asking something
of those relationships even if they're
less tight even if they're less about
you know family connections even if they
have more lawyers and lobbies lobbyists
in between there's no demanding
and there's no giving because there's no
demanding well that's a dangerous
proposition exactly
at the wow truly incredible
just a couple quotes from the book
what's your take on on the following
quotes
first uh first off he who controls the
money supply controls the nation
this is uh what we have right now with
the big six um banks today we have a
money supply that the federal reserve is
technically in charge of but what it has
done in its policy has it has bought
over four trillion dollars worth of
securities
from the banks or treasury bonds that go
through the banks back to the fed on
which the fed pays interest to the banks
so
they have a say in rates they've made
rates close to you know zero percent for
the longest period in u.s history or in
the history of the fed
but the control
you know is retained by the banks that
get the money
to receive the assistance and you couple
that with the fact that today
there's more concentration of capital
in the hands of fewer banks and fewer
bankers running them than there's ever
been in our history
and you're not just controlling the
money supply you're controlling the
capital 84
of the deposits in this country that are
insured by the fdic reside at the top
six banks 84 85
of assets
96
of the derivatives exposure
six banks in the united states they
control 45 of the derivatives exposure
in the world that's a tremendous amount
forget the political financial phone
calls to the white house visits and
invitations
that's a tremendous amount of capital to
be in charge it sounds like a powder
cake it is
and and again we we've only emerged um
and when i say emerge i mean we've only
continued on from the crisis of 2008 to
have these sorts of worse statistics
than we had before and have big banks
bigger than they were before controlling
more than they did before and that's
that's a very very unstable scary
position yeah scary proposition
obviously i mean the elephant in the
room in terms of too big to fail but
what's your take on you know too big to
regulate prosecute and trust yeah
to too big to too big to fall too big to
reign in
um and
and as you said before larry no
leadership yeah at the highest echelons
to do
anything
about it well that's very troubling in
chapter 16 you write the quote this was
this uh this really grabbed me no longer
was there even a pretense of alignment
with domestic concerns or collaboration
with the white house so take that quote
relative to you know what we had coming
out of uh world war ii
um
i mean that's a pretty strong statement
yeah and um i i don't remember if i said
that in the seven exactly what year
within the 70s that that quote came from
um or that i was referring to but but
but but the fact is that that that
disalignment that we have
used
um the government for what it's worth we
used to
have this sort of
relationship where we would give and
there'd be a give and take and
we don't need that anymore we'll just
we'll just take
and
the government really receded into a
position of of having less power
as
the as the consolidation of capital
became more and more concentrated
the power base shifted back to
wall street it had been that way in the
panic of 1907 that was when teddy
roosevelt had asked jp morgan to save
the country you know the morgan even in
the late 1890s that the morgan bank had
more money than the treasury department
we've covered
full circle we've come and then it was
like real money it was like real gold it
was real money now it's it's it's
leveraged capital it's all sorts of more
complicated money
and and and and with broader power
yes than it was back then and to that
very point the the power and oftentimes
power is uh is equated with oftentimes
uh arrogance you know there's there's
one quote uh in the latter part of the
book that really grabbed me and some
people in the public have heard this
this quote that's why i'm richer than
you
yeah that was a jamie dimon
in an internal call with some analysts
at chase and the impetus for that quote
and basically just what it means and
what it what it says
is that you know this this isn't
about
um
a greater good it's not about a public
interest it's not it's not about even a
profit motive being sustained by by
something reasonable it's about
my ego
and my money as it feeds my ego and my
power as it feeds my ego and and you
bring that into the equation and that's
just part of why it's it's all so much
more dangerous now there was a fellow
who ran chase
back in the 30s as well al wiggin who
had quite a big ego and he was chucked
out okay when
when winter baldrige came in um under
fdr and he
didn't
work to run the bank anymore um you know
and so there was a humility that that
sort of existed after that depression
and into the wars that doesn't exist
whatsoever at all anymore that's truly
troubling
uh
early 1900s we had these six large banks
you know dominating the marketplace we
still have now six large banks but in
the interim
uh there have been endless
numbers of mergers has there ever been a
merger that you know that a major bank
hasn't liked
uh and whatever happened to the sherman
and clayton antitrust act
in the world of
major banking yeah i mean
it all goes back to to that panic what
what happened after the panic of 1907 it
was very very significant
because out of that came as we talked
about the federal reserve and then when
the world war one happened woodrow
wilson and it's it's an interesting
little story in the book called jack
morgan jp morgan's son to the white
house after having campaigned on this
notion of
breaking these money trusts that were
run by people like morgan because there
was a war coming on and there was all
sorts of speculation in the press at the
time you know why are these guys getting
together why is morgan at the white
house what's wilson doing you know
and it turned out a couple months later
that they were trying to figure out how
to finance a war and they were very much
on the on the same page and and um you
know we we now have
that situation where the
there's nothing to to keep um
that page well it clearly seems i mean
with such uh as you were just
referencing you know the the the
percentage of capital and deposits and
derivatives and assets in such few hands
that it allows for ultimately uh
manipulation and uh and scandalous
activities within the markets which is
why if you
that which is why you need actual
defined well-defined
structures to at least be unquestionable
and unlobbyable and unlawyerable against
in order to at least
create less risk yep to everyone else in
the general economy i mean that should
be yeah you talk about you a government
is supposed to protect
the citizens of the country well it's
not just about all the money spent on
military the government has and should
have a responsibility to protect the
country from the standpoint of its
economic well-being
and in a situation where the
concentration of of of wealth and power
and influence and capital is so out of
whack
then
a government that's allowing that
presidency any presidency that it's
allowing that to happen
is is not doing its best by the american
people is not
doing what would be best in the interest
of a true democracy
well then the question begs
does it really matter who sits in the
white house
um
yeah these these last several decades it
it really hasn't from from from this
standpoint you know you talked about all
the various bailouts all the um crazies
that have happened in between
internationally between the third world
debt crisis the mexican peso crisis the
snl crisis domestically versus the 2008
crisis and all of this continues to
happen regardless of whether there's a
republican or a democrat in the white
house regardless of whether the treasury
secretary is a republican or a democrat
and who's running the fed so it hasn't
mattered it hasn't mattered
nomi this has been fabulous we've got uh
we've got three or four minutes left
here uh
let's just touch upon let's try to look
forward to the future
uh obviously a lot of unknowns you know
we're we're sitting here at a point in
our nation's history which you know
having come out of this crisis of 08
kicked the can down the road
lots of issues
what would you like to see
and how are we going to you know to make
that happen
yeah i mean i i'd love to see true
leadership coming out of of the oval
office with regard to the issues we've
been discussing here today
i would love to see a return of the
glass-steagall act not a pretend return
of the glass-steagall act to at least
create structural reform because there
will always be
lobbying and lawyering and personal
calls to ask for things
a little more balance between what's
required for the stability of the
country versus putting everything and
all the eggs into the basket of
stability for the largest banking
institutions
and a real
strengthening of america from that
standpoint
that would be good to see it would be
not good to see another crisis which is
very likely what will happen instead
because these things
aren't happening i think there's a lot
we can learn from our history i mean it
has some very bad moments and it has
some really decent moments and i think
that and that's one of the things i
found in in this book you know that the
periods where things worked better
are things we should accentuate
like move up from there
we can criticize them but we should look
at them
but and the things that worked worse for
the general public we should try not to
do
um and that that was really one of my
main takeaways from this book aside from
from the connections and and just the
anatomy of how power relationships work
between the white house and wall street
in this country and how they impact
policies on a foreign and domestic basis
but also
what makes sense
for the general public and in the
greater public interest and do that more
yeah
well regrettably it seems those who have
failed to learn from history are doomed
to repeat it and there's a lot that has
been repeated here uh obviously leading
to the you know the crisis of 08 uh in
your estimation will it take another
crisis to bring about some changes that
we haven't seen from this this most
recent one
i i think there's
no way that won't happen
now whether we get the changes after
that crisis i i i can't say but but it's
astonishing to me
that
what happened wasn't enough and that the
fact that we are still subsidizing
the the banks that were involved was
is is is very incredible to me and and
and truly we need to be in a better
place well nomi uh
i can't thank you enough for the
incredible work that you've put into
this book you've done in my opinion a
national service
and for those who uh you know watching
the show please read the book share it
with uh with you know friends family and
colleagues congratulations on a fabulous
piece of work thank you so much larry
okay
welcome to book tv's coverage of day two
of the 2014 los angeles times festival
of books from the university of southern
california today's schedule includes
panels on finance world politics and a
discussion with scientists and pulitzer
prize-winning author jared diamond on
his book the world until yesterday what
we can learn from traditional societies
and we kick off our coverage now with
the panel on finance
okay i guess uh i guess we can start
it's
it's time
um
thank you all for coming this is a great
crowd and we're all very happy to have
you here to talk about
uh the financial crisis and and
financial history uh under the the title
gaming the system
which is really what it's all about
before
i introduce myself and the panelists i
just want to make a couple of quick
announcements first of all we ask you
to silence your cell phones
um and uh we point out that personal
recording of these sessions
is verboten
uh there will be a book signing uh for
uh all the members of the panel and
myself
right after this session
uh i'm asked to tell you that uh if you
are buying a book you buy it upstairs in
this building in the lobby and then uh
the signing will be across the street
there'll be booths there where we'll
we'll sign them
after you buy them so
anyway
once again welcome to all of you
[Music]
we're privileged to have with us today
three authors who've taken three very
different approaches to reporting and
analyzing
the financial crisis that began in 2008
and in many respects is still with us
before i introduce them i'll introduce
myself i'm michael hiltzick i'm business
columnist at the la times and i blog for
the la times
at a page called the economy hub which
you can find at latimes.com
uh i'm also the author of this book the
new deal a modern history which uh the
paperback edition of which came out last
year which you can get upstairs
um as i mentioned the three authors with
us today have all taken these very
different
approaches
to the financial crisis but their books
all have a common thread in that they
address issues
of financial industry regulation
and history and the ways that incumbents
in this big sprawling financial
industry have managed through the years
through a combination of political
influence very well-funded lobbying and
misdirection and deception
to avoid the sort of regulation and
oversight that would have done much to
avert the financial crisis
of a few years ago and would do much
to keep the same thing from happening
again in the future
so uh on my left though it's hard to be
to my left uh too much
uh
as some of you
uh who've read my columns might know is
nomi prince whose book published i i
think just this week right tuesday
tuesday is all the presidents bankers
the hidden alliances that drive american
power
nomi is a former wall street executive
who's written for a wide range of
publications including the new york
times fortune mother jones and the
nation and that's a pretty broad
spectrum of publications in the united
states and her book exhaustively
examines the relationships between banks
and bankers on the one hand
and our national government on the other
going back to the turn of the last
century and bringing the story forward
pretty much to the present day
um on my right is anat admati who is the
author uh the co-author i guess
of the bankers new clothes which is also
just out in paperback
the subtitle is what's wrong with
banking and what to do about it
and that is george parker professor of
finance and economics at stanford's
graduate school of business and i know
from personal experience is one of our
most uncompromising and penetrating
analysts
of the banking sector that we have today
her book shines a spotlight on how the
banks have avoided what could be the
most straightforward and most effective
reforms of their industry since the
crisis
largely by lobbying and i hope i'm not
being too blunt by by lying
and on my far right uh just uh
topologically speaking
is helene ohlin one of my former
colleagues here at the la times whose
book is pound foolish
here it is
exposing the dark side of the personal
finance industry helene's work has
appeared in the washington post salon
slate and forbes
and her book really lays bare the the
charlatanism
that underlies the personal finance
nostrums that we're inundated with
every day on television online and in
print
so i'm going to ask our authors to start
by each giving us some preliminary
thoughts about their books their themes
their motivations in writing their books
if they wish in fact anything they want
to say about their books and their
subject that they can fit into say
five to seven minutes each and then
we'll move on to a broader discussion
and ultimately to your questions uh so
nomi why don't you
start us off okay
thank you and it's just an honor to be
here and with this amazing panel we were
all sort of golf carted over here so we
had a good 10 minutes to talk about each
other's things and we've known them
historically as well um
i came here by uber and the
man who was driving
the car
asked me what i was talking about and i
explained you know this is a book about
presidents and bankers and
he's like yeah it's really tighter than
ever now and i'm guess it is and he said
well but i hear it's gone back like a
hundred years this is nothing new and i
said yeah you know it's exactly what
what i talk about in my book and he said
and it's it's not just about you know
wall street washington it's all that the
families he's like it's the blood and
the marriages and i'm like you're
quoting me to me
that's weird
and and and it turned out he had you
know heard something throughout the week
and just as an author you know you ask
about you know talking about writing in
books it's it's it's so
it was so amazing to have someone who
wasn't related to me
actually you know
talk about a a theme
that
was out there that that is now part of
his discourse it was just it was just a
really really warm feeling to come here
um and the reason i i wrote this book
was because um
we know what's happened more recently in
time you know i i had worked on wall
street before the years before the
financial crisis that just happened in
2008 and and there's certainly an
intense alliance and relationship and
interdependence between wall street and
washington that i think we're all aware
of it's it's pretty obvious when the
heads of large banks don't go to jail
and the heads of you know and small
people who rob little stores do you know
there's a definite problem in in society
and justice and accountability and in
everything else and what we have today
is a more concentrated power of wealth
than we've ever had before the big six
banks in this country today control 84
84 percent of the deposits of all the
fdic insured banks so therefore probably
most of your accounts as well as 85 of
the assets of all banks as well as 96 of
derivatives that's a phenomenal
concentration of capital and leveraged
capital in one set of hands and this is
after the financial crisis but it didn't
just get there accidentally and so what
i did was i looked at this idea of the
big six and i had been covering what was
going on in washington and said you know
what there there's a lot more to this
than just what's going on with the big
six and six is like this interesting
number in history because i had done a
novel before this called black tuesday
in which i
did less research than i did for this
book but but but found a a meeting that
happened on wall street in 1929 on
october 24th thursday 1929 at noon where
the market was starting to fall where
all this unregulated speculation that
happened during the 20s was coming to a
head and this man named thomas lamont
who was the acting chairman of the
morgan bank at the time because jack
morgan who was the chairman at the time
was off like partying in europe
and
he got five other bankers together
that collectively ran the big six banks
of the time and they were called the big
six banks at that time and that that
name had been coined by bc forbes in
1917
and and forward because it was about six
bankers at the time those bankers were
all related in some capacity if they
weren't related by blood they were
related by marriage if they weren't
related by marriage their children were
or would be so there was a really strong
connection in that room and this idea
that you know put in some money we'll
save the markets we can do this etc but
the story went back even behind and
before those big six decided to save the
markets from all the the screw-ups that
they had imposed upon them and what
would become the great depression which
would be imposed upon the greater
society and all of the population of the
united states and and globally
is that the ties back from the morgan
bank went to
the panic of 1907 actually even before
that at one point in time j.p morgan had
more money than the treasury department
and in the late 1890s there actually
were too many crises at the time real
people like normal sort of people in the
street main street didn't really have as
much invested in the markets they were
just impacted by them today we both have
money pensions deposits invested in them
and we are impacted by them and it was a
little bit more isolated but at the time
there were some panics in the 1890s the
government called upon j.p morgan to
help but the panic in 1907 was a
situation which teddy roosevelt who
became the president united states
before that
was friends with the morgans and when he
was going about talking about trust
busting other industries he didn't bust
the banks the reason he didn't bust the
banks
was because
he trusted and supported and was
socially involved with jp morgan and
other sort of big bankers of the time
and in addition to that when the panic
happened in 1907 there was there was a
trust company called the knickerbocker
trust company in new york and it
imploded and the reason it imploded is
because of a lot of bad bets in copper
now they're bad bets in subprime then it
was bad bets in car in copper
and teddy roosevelt called upon jp
morgan to do something to save the
situation situation again and jp morgan
said all right i got this
teddy roosevelt you know you wait for my
word the treasury secretary was to wait
for the morgan's word and there was a
meeting that was called at midnight so
12 o'clock midnight
at the hotel manhattan in new york where
morgan invited some of his friends james
stillman who was head of national
citibank which is now citibank tom
lamont who i mentioned who was still
hanging around in 1929 but was then much
younger
and a bunch of other people to go around
and talk about how they would save the
markets and they put in some money they
also got 25 million dollars from the
treasury department so that was the
first time where this trustbuster said
you know i need your help here's some
money
do whatever you need to do morgan got
his people together he said you guys all
got to put in money again to save the
situation they they do accept they don't
do it with morgan's money they do with
standard oil money and shares that they
then dissect to get back into saving not
the knickerbocker trust company not the
company that people from harlem to fifth
avenue and in between were trying to get
their deposits out of because it would
affect their lives but the american
trust company the trust company of
america because in that
he had invested and running that were
his friends
and that was a situation where you know
the government basically said teddy
roosevelt said do this morgan said okay
saved his friends and that was sort of
the beginning of a situation that led to
the federal reserve act in 1913 where
morgan sent and there's a big part of my
book and i probably only have like 30
seconds or less
to finish that but basically out of that
came this this this idea
that the bankers wanted a bank that
could support them even more in these
panics so not even having to gather
these midnight meetings or later in
meetings but but to have some other
backing and it was the bankers that
pushed for the federal reserve act and i
went down to jekyll island as part of
the research for my book which also took
me to every presidential library in this
country to examine the original
documents because i don't trust a lot of
media um some may know some ideas it's
fantastic but but i i have this thing
of course not present people the thing
is that well that's the purpose of media
is to tell the truth but that doesn't
always happen in this case it absolutely
happens um but historically the the
exaltation to jp morgan at the time of
the panic by certain uh newspapers was
was was massive um he was a king he had
saved the country it saved the world i
mean you know it was all sorts of
massive we always now kind of see what
jamie dimon stuff in certain in certain
publications um so jp morgan jp morgan
chase there's a legacy there um but why
don't we i will wrap up okay um
anyway the point is that the these
things have a long tail and and there's
a lot of blood and connections and
protege mentorship relationships and
everything else that manifest in
policies that come
not from wall street to washington not
from washington and wall street but that
are together it's one box it isn't a
revolving door or two doors into it is
one box of power which is shared by
different groups of people that have
incredible philosophical political and
financial ties
okay uh and i why don't you take it from
there
[Applause]
i accommodate as an academic i teach
finance at stanford business school and
i awoke like everybody else in
fall 2008 and actually before that
wondering what's going on and why is it
that this uh industry managed to uh harm
so much
and the more i look the more of a
falling in the rabbit hall experience it
was
so two
great pieces of literature are alice in
wonderland and the emperor's new clothes
which is sort of the cover of the book
uh
it ended up being only men so their ties
cover uh enough
i couldn't believe what i heard and i
couldn't believe what i didn't hear
what
was all this nonsense and the more i
looked and the more i read and this is
media and this is
policy papers and this is even academics
the more disturbing it was
because some of it was just complete and
utter nonsense that you could
immediately if you only know what the
words mean you can debunk uh
literally i mean the headlines that you
get in the paper are just false you know
it's not true that the banks are asked
to hold cash in some vault that's false
to all kinds of subtle what we call
bankers new clothes meaning
nonsense in one way or another and
there's a whole wardrobe of those
uh
as i talked to people it became
obvious that it or it became unclear
actually what people knew and what they
wanted to know
and there became this
feeling that i
am in the rabbit hole and i people i try
to see where they're coming from as i
talk to them and i'm tutoring
whoever
i come across it takes a long time
and some of them um
don't uh care to know
so it became sort of okay assume
absolutely nothing it's not that hard
but if we don't clear the nonsense we
have no hope so this book is a book with
a mission
to
at least remove the nonsense from this
debate so we can maybe
challenge all these banking emperors
that actually have no clothes the bottom
line is this system has not changed uh
in the last five years it's very
disturbing and very scary all this talk
you hear is spinning narratives um
they want you to believe that it was
just a natural disaster that happened
and they sent this really really bright
nice ambulances for all of us
to uh to help us uh
but instead what they uh or they tell
you that it was just some problem
plumbing some liquidity problem
uh that's the narratives that are
favored these are flawed narratives that
are meant to hide the responsibility of
the regulators themselves uh and the
politician for very bad regulations that
that absolutely
failed to protect us and
which were barely tweaked uh since so
the narrative about big reforms
i can't obviously unpack all of them but
they are
just
false
the analogy you could think about is
imagine
trucks driving at 90 miles an hour with
fuel in residential neighborhoods and
they tell you they were really good
drivers and
90 miles an hour is absolutely an
essential speed for us
to drive or you terrible things will
happen if we drive slower
and uh
and here are the policemen just watching
by they don't even have the speedometers
showing the speed and then uh
they're burning the engines by the way
they're incredibly inefficient and
there's tons of them
around and then when they implode and
take each other down an implosion and
all these collateral damage happen
then
they got to be saved as well as their
insurance companies got to be saved and
everything else so that we can have this
fuel flowing again uh
into the market and then they get up and
say oh well you know fix me up so i can
keep running get back in the car
and drive again at 87 miles an hour big
reforms we did
um
and we're still leaving all this
risk that we can't see and all of that
and so the battle is uh nor pretty and
uh
the lobbying is intense on every bit of
it so the forces against a very uh small
and powerless uh in the end it's very
difficult partly because of this
politics that i did not appreciate but i
do
now
trying to just bring in a voice that
doesn't care exactly what the outcome is
but cares for the public and i feel it's
my responsibility to try to unpack all
these things that are completely wrong
that i failed students were saying
and empower more people
to challenge those emperors
otherwise
we're just driving again at this speed
and the next time it happens we're going
to wonder how come
these uh policymakers didn't save us and
they will have a story you can bet they
will have a story about it and they'll
get a lot of people to spin
narratives for them including academics
unfortunately
so that's why i come at it form
[Applause]
okay helene your turn okay um hi
everybody
um i came into this i write about the
area where all most of us are most
likely to interact with the financial
services sector and that's in our
personal finances
and the way i came into this is is i for
several years in the late 1990s wrote
and edited the money makeover feature
for the for the los angeles times and i
think as everybody knows because it
still runs occasionally you know you
take you have a subject you fix them up
with a financial planner and they give
some financial advice and the
implication is their life is going to be
just go fine after this they just needed
a little financial advice and all would
be well
and so i came back to this several years
ago
long after i'd stopped doing it
and wanted to ask the question of how we
had gotten to this point
how had we become convinced that with
financial planning and doing good
financial behaviors we would all be okay
you know we never addressed the point in
this world that you know we were putting
more and more responsibility on people
pensions were being taken away
um as as pensions were being taken away
as our salaries were stagnating and
falling and at the same time we were
saying well you know you need to save
for retirement you need to
you know save for your kids college
education and by the way we're going to
take away the right to declare
bankruptcy on the student loans if it
doesn't work out um you need to pay more
and more of your medical expenses
expenses for hospitalizations alone went
up 20 between last year and this year
according to some people
and you know you know and it's your
fault if this just doesn't work out
so what i became very interested in is
how we had been sold on this idea
exactly because you know it all seemed
very natural to us but in fact you know
our own planning our own retirements was
you know less than really 30 35 years
old at this point
so i went back and of course what i
discover pretty quickly is there
actually one group of people that's
doing really well off of this system and
it's not anybody in this room it's the
financial services sector it doesn't
matter how badly you're doing
they're making a mint on all of this
and
to give one quick example because i
don't have a lot of time to speak here
retirement savings we collectively have
roughly 23 trillion dollars
that in case which sounds like an
enormous sum of money
um that actually comes out to less than
twenty thousand dollars per person
um that's gonna really go far especially
since the estimates for medical costs
per household in retirement are over 200
000
but of course
why why are we tolerating this well
we don't really know how much the
financial services sector is making off
of this pile of money except to know
that it's an awful lot of money that the
estimates have ranged from 90 billion
annually at the low end to 500 billion
annually at the high end um it's
probably somewhere in there your gas is
as good as anybody else's they claim
they don't know that they can't track
this money somehow they manage to take
it but they can't tell you where it's
going it's really quite fascinating
actually
so but we've become convinced that this
is all our own fault
and the sort of premise of my book was
to tell the story of how we had been
sold on this idea that we could control
our financial fates in this world where
our salaries were stagnating and our
costs of living were going up
and why we weren't fighting back and of
course as i do the book i find out more
and more about the you know the lobbying
in washington the vast amounts of money
being thrown around to make sure you're
not protected um as i like to say about
finding about your dealings with the
financial services sector if um our food
was regulated as well as our financial
products we'd all have food poisoning at
least once a week
um and you could ask why that is okay
um and
and how this would come to be how we'd
become sold on the fact that women
were it wasn't that women were underpaid
and lived longer and um had more
responsibilities on their money it was
that women were simply too emotional to
deal with their money and that's why we
have less of it
and you could go through the whole
gamut of these things um you know it's
your financial problems are because of
your childhood memories not because of
your class
and so on and i basically wrote a book
telling this story and really came to
the conclusion that we need to begin
talking about this as a society and not
take such fault on ourselves and begin
to talk about this in ways
that you know we no longer think it's
you know if only i'd not gone to the
starbucks eight times last month clearly
i could have paid that ten thousand
dollar medical bill
uh so on that note i will uh conclude
and let the panel begin
[Applause]
uh okay well thanks uh thanks to all of
you for those uh those uh quick digests
um
one thing that that interested interests
me um as
writers i think many of us
have the experience that when we're
either researching a book or maybe
writing it
there's a particular moment an anecdote
or a fact that we learn that really
defines for us either the theme of our
book or maybe justifies for us
why we are committing ourselves to
spending
two years maybe three or however long it
is really deep ending into a subject and
i wonder if uh maybe each of you could
could dredge up
uh if you have it a case like that an
anecdote a fact a moment
that sort of defined for you um why you
were
taking on this project and and i i don't
know if this is the one for you but you
told i i think in your book you tell a
story of hearing the chairman i think of
deutsche bank
uh
justifying or rationalizing something
and if not that some other story so um
why don't you start
well i was
my moment where i was going to speak up
actually had to do with first wondering
am i missing something
let me read another thing and let me
read another thing
uh
and then thinking it's just a big
confusion somehow
but the big moment really was uh opening
up a textbook on banking and being
absolutely
horrified
at what i saw that really was uh
shocking this particular book
still has
completely false
teachings that contradict
the absolute basic courses that we teach
in other classes in finance as if
banking can just deny
all the forces in the world and somehow
there's no gravity you're supposed to
leave at the door everything you know
they can make it up as they go along so
basically they tell you that banking is
very special as an industry and in
reality
the specialness of banking is really
what they get away with
that's the specialness the privilege
that they have to defy
everything that and to live in an
entitlement for cheap funding
to take risks with it and hide those
risks and have somebody else
bear the downside and when i realized
that this really was going was the
essence of what was going on
it was a matter of unpacking little bit
by little bit for anybody who doesn't
know what a
balance sheet is from adam and most
people don't need to know that
what the words mean and how simple it
really is to see the
through all this nonsense so that's
that was the moment but there have been
many amazing stories someday when i
write the book outside job um
i might tell it
but i might drop dead from
uh helene was there oh they'll shoot me
joke that you have done my book right uh
it would have been five years five
hundred thousand words and then i would
have had to junk half of it and start
all over again and my children would
have published it after i'm gone because
that's how many scams there are in this
world but there were a lot of moments
but i think the one that really
crystallized it for me was um when
you're writing a book about personal
finance a lot of people come to you with
i've got the solve i've got the solve
and these are well-meaning people
sometimes they're not all awful people
and i began to look at a thing called
financial literacy which i think a lot
of people this room have heard of in
fact it's financial literacy month right
now
and the idea is of course we could just
teach people about their finances in
school you know all will be well and
they'll learn all these behaviors that
they should have learned and it sounds
reasonable right like how could you be
against teaching money teaching kids
about money so i start to look at this
i'm thinking oh maybe this will actually
work well i discover one of the greatest
boondoggles i have ever stumbled into
financial literacy as a modern movement
starts um with ford motor credit in the
mid-1990s
um they're trying to cover up the fact
that they're having a problem with what
we now call subprime auto loans
and so they get this bright idea that
they're going to fund children's
education and money and they start
throwing money at this and this starts
to pick up and it really starts to pick
up after 2008 if you go into the lexus
databases you'll see the amount of
mentions of the term financial literacy
doubles and doubles again and doubles a
third time within like a year
and
what it what it comes down to is you
start having the banks who are putting
this product into the school with their
names emblazoned on it as brand
awareness
are basically using this as a way of
dumping responsibility for all of the
disasters of the past several decades on
you so it's not that they issued a
subprime mortgage with you to somebody
who shouldn't have had it with that was
100 pages single spaced with more gotcha
terms and there were gotchas out there
you should have read it and if you had
taken that class in the eighth grade you
might have been able to get this
and it's all your fault and you should
have known when the mortgage broker who
was getting paid and you should have
known he was getting paid to sell you a
mortgage that you should have known that
oh no i can't afford that house and no
actually prices don't always go up you
should have known not to listen to him
and it went on like this and i just
found
example after example of how financial
literacy had basically been sold to us
and um
i really became to showed me you know
how
the the the ethos of responsibility that
you know that we were responsible for
what the banks had done had been sold to
all of us
when i
when i went
when i first even
began to have any word with people in
washington dc i was absolutely shocked
to see they had absolutely no idea about
anything at all and part of the way they
learned part of the way they learned was
that the financial services
industry was running what they called
financial services university and taking
uh staffers
uh winding and dining them for a weekend
to teach them uh how it works
yeah i have to just interject to say i
don't think i put this in the book but i
actually attended a major financial
literacy event on the hill where they
were whining and dining all the aids
with really great food and such it was
the same thing well that's the key to
financial literacy
how to read a menu
especially when you're not paying the
bill especially yes well and that is
actually one of the key points it's it's
other people's money and that's also
the last chapter of my book it's the
last chapter of you and and um
it's it it's also
the not just the political system but
but it really just goes back to you you
protect your own and if your own or
other bankers if your own or other
banker politicians or your families are
integrated or you understand them better
then all of your policies are going to
drive that way and and we kind of foot
that bill i mean the things that you
know anna talks about in her book and
and and um helen and hers in terms of
how all of this impacts people is
because we put the bill to to all of
this this political financial system
that is about political financial power
that has nothing to do with us um there
are so many moments in the book where i
i was like wow because i mean i was in
the middle of nowhere at times you know
i was in like abilene kansas at the
president eisenhower's
library it was me and some guy who was
looking up things on cattle ranching
because because eisenhower also had
cattle and um
and and just there every day and pouring
through these this information because
what i did was i went to every single
place and i was like i want the big six
bankers of that time and i started to
realize these people weren't just ahead
of their banks for a minute they were
ahead of their banks for decades and if
they weren't heads of their banks for
decades they were in the treasury
department or the defense department or
the state department or the national
security department there wasn't there
wasn't a place where there wasn't
overlapping in interaction and it wasn't
just because wall street was influencing
washington it's because washington wall
street were the same thing um and two
sides of the same coin of power and that
all of the stories that i found really
just
show that there was so much personal
integration there was personal
integration the families of power
through you know you talk about well you
write about the new deal in fdr but one
of the most fascinating things when i
went to the fdr library in hyde park new
york was that
i was looking at documents that no one
else had looked at because no one else
had thought that maybe all the people
running the banks were friends with fdr
a lot of people know that i shouldn't
say no one's written about that but all
of them
and and and when i say friends i mean
connected yachting
james roosevelt who was fdr's father
which i didn't know
worked with j.p morgan to create the
metro ten politician club in new york
where all the very powerful elite
political financial families would hang
out and discuss matters of the day
and this was something that went forward
throughout history so the political
financial families and individuals were
all very very integrated in every place
i went there were just these these
stories um
i'll i'll i can keep going i won't but
but kennedy's roosevelt's rockefellers i
mean these aren't conspiracies and i
think that was the one thing i also
wanted to uncover through actual
documentation is that the one thing i
noticed all of the moments throughout
the research is that
these are not things we are
assuming are conspiracies because that's
what the message is that oh there
weren't a bunch of people on on on
jekyll island oh there weren't about
people rigging the financial systems in
every manner possible that you can
possibly find it's it's real um and it's
and it's much more at the core of what
america is and therefore what our
democracy isn't
um if you really look at the information
and and that was something that all
along the way i i
going in thought there would be
connections but i just had no idea how
many
they would really be and how close and
tight they really were
well that's a great point and
since since you mentioned uh having been
at the hyde park presidential library
one of
one of the impressions that i got when i
was there was how how bad all of the
equipment was i mean you know none of
the
none of the microfilm uh readers worked
and they were all broken down and there
was a uh this of course is part of the
national archive system and
they were putting out appeals for for
money um
from the average person um
to preserve the truth well yeah to
preserve the collection um
one thing uh about fdr that um i wanted
is i want to move into sort of the next
uh phase of our discussion um
fdr of course had a lot of friends he
had grown up in great wealth he had a
lot of friends um
uh from uh from the the one percent
really and there was a great moment that
i
i came across when he was
he had written a speech or
prepared a fireside chat that was going
to be about
how he was going to raise taxes on the
wealthiest people who's going to raise
him up to
a marginal rate of uh 90 or so and he
was reading he was giving a dramatic
reading with harold ickes i think who
was his um
uh interior secretary and a republican
by the way but a very progressive one
and vincent astor was in the room and
astor was a very very close personal
friend of fdrs and one of the original
400 i think of ward mcallister's
great
term and and fdr was reading this out
and he got to the point where he said
this is what i'm going to do to taxes on
the wealthy and and aster sort of said
well you know franklin
i'm one of those people
and roosevelt sort of looked at him and
said well you're going to have to pay
too uh vincent so
but this leads me into a question i
wanted to ask you know me um which is
that in in all the the uh the period
that you covered going back as i said to
the
to the dawn of the 20th century um
it seems to me and you can check me if
i'm wrong on this that there was really
only one period in which
there really was a successful campaign
for wall street and banking regulation
and that was the 30s
when we got the securities act of 1933
end of 1934
we got the sec we got disclosures of
corporate finances
we got we we brought the new york stock
exchange to heal all these things
um the fdic of course uh
is that true and if so why do you think
that is why have we been so unable to do
it at other periods and what was it
about the 30s that that made a
difference
um there was a man named winthrop
aldrich who was actually the son of
nelson aldrich who was the father of the
federal reserve again family thing but
and by the way uh
related to uh nelson aldrich rockefeller
he is yes he was the great uncle of
nelson rockefeller four-time new york
governor vice president and david
rockefeller who ran chase also for two
decades so anyway i went through
baldrige a couple generations before
that
was friends with fdr and he was actually
concerned about the
speculation that had driven the market
apart he was concerned about the economy
and and confidence in general banking as
was fdr and his first inaugural address
he talked about the only thing we have
to fear is for ourselves do you talk
about banking he didn't name names but
he talked about stabilizing the system
because he believed fdr believed because
he had grown up in wealth that a
system that was more stable for
everybody would lift america in general
and actually went through baldridge
believe the same thing which is ironic
because jamie dimon would never get up
and say hey gee i'm going to split up my
bank that would be a really good idea so
everybody in the country can be more
stable that wouldn't but but then it
actually did and went through al just
took out a front page piece in the new
york times to push glass-steagall which
was the act in 1933 that separated
speculative activities from all these
deposits that now eighty-four percent of
them are at the big six banks and if the
fdic fdic insured by the government um
and he promoted it and he actually was
going back and forth to washington
to get the senate and to get senator
carter glass whose name is on that bill
to make the bill even stronger than it
was going to be to include the morgan
bank which was also one of his
competitors so that didn't hurt but but
yeah there's so much self-interest going
on here but but but the the point is at
that time with the population where it
was with fdr a very very very skilled
politician understanding the language
and with with getting certain friends to
bankers like aldrich um and also james
perkins who ran national citibank at the
time to work with him they separated
their banks before the legislation
so
that was something that happened that
helped the country it helped the bankers
it helped fdr that last did that that
that stability and banking and that
separation lasted for about 40 or so
years before in the 70s things started
disintegrating and there's a lot of
reasons in between but but that's when
bankers found other ways to make money
they found oil to recycle into the
middle east they started going off of
this idea of more stability at home
means a better profit for us and thought
how we could make a much much greater
profit if we don't really care about
that and sort of go off in our own
direction and politically they were
allowed to do that by all of the
presidents that came after that
uh right um
now uh anna you and i were talking
before the the panel began um
the in the preface
the new preface that you've written for
the paperback uh edition of your book
you talk about
the blindness of bankers and in fact the
willful blindness is the term you use
where do you see now
if there's
one particular product or market uh that
really has the most danger for us all
that the banks are
haven't been weaned from and maybe are
back into in a healthy way or
uh where the most mischief is possible
well the mischief is possible in every
which way i mean it's really there are
many ways whenever i see that banks go
congregate in some investment i think
first of all probably the regulation
views this is safe but it's not in
particular they went into municipalities
lending to municipalities and we saw
what that did so it was pretty clear
they were going to get the
municipalities into trouble it's like
you know over lending to certain
countries in europe because the
regulation encourages lending to
governments over landing to businesses
in europe
uh so there's the sovereigns in europe
there's municipalities now they say that
there's junk
car loans uh subprime uh so
there are many ways to to take risk the
problem in banking is not
risk-taking because i come from silicon
valley where a lot more risk is taken
actually
the big
thing that makes banking so fragile is
that they take it with somebody else's
borrowed money
that's the problem
so they are like
a homeowner that bought a mansion with
no down payment but they're a
corporation they have access to their
own profits they just rush to pay them
out to protect them from
their creditors which is our depositors
which is us
so
they just continue to live on the edge
like that is absolutely not necessary
and the problem is that they're allowed
to so in terms of the blindness well
it's a term i came after the book i met
a writer who has a book called willful
blindness why we uh
whatever don't see the uh miss the
obvious at our peril or something like
that so it's about see no evil hear no
evil which really represented when
somebody told me that there's a lot of
blind spots in banking it was more of
the willful
blindness kind in other words i don't
want to hear about it because i it's not
convenient for me and so i've had many
incidences about
you know
i don't i don't want to hear what you
have to say because i got my story and
i'm sticking
to it
okay um helene
when you you talk about
there's a lot of your book that really
um
[Music]
resonated with me because uh
just to tell a story on myself my wife
and i for a while were subscribers to
money magazine and uh we we discovered
two things about money magazine um while
we were subscribers and one was that you
really only had to subscribe for one
year
because it basically repeated itself
year after year year after year the
other thing was that every time every
month uh it would come in the mailbox
and we would play a game which was find
the waldo
and the walder was the
the place in every single edition we ne
it never missed one
where it offered the advice that what
you should do to save yourself
um from financial ruin is consolidate
your credit cards
and that one nugget appeared without
fail in every every last edition of
money magazine but that brings me to the
question which i'd like to ask you which
is that
since the the theme of your book really
is that the deck is stacked against the
ordinary investor or the ordinary
household because of all of this
sophistry
that we get inundated with
what what can the average
american
whether we're thinking in terms of being
investors or just savers
what can we do to save ourselves to
resist this is there anything in
particular that people should read or
keep in mind when they're just flooded
by all of this the surface of
information well there's the big picture
in the individual picture the big
picture is we all need to start speaking
up about this because ultimately we're
not going to keep up
and the only way is we have to insist on
protections out of washington and that's
not happening until we start squawking
about it it might not happen then but at
least we'll gets potentially get
somewhere because right now people
generally don't realize how stacked the
deck is against them and i don't mean
just in terms of income and health
insurance and retirement i mean in terms
of the fact that the financial services
industry has very little duty to help
you we all think that if we go seek help
it's like going to a doctor and this
person is going to have to give us
advice that's in our best interests and
there's some sort of hippocratic
financial oath that they're violating if
they don't
in fact that is absolutely untrue
they most financial advisors adhere to
something called the suitability
standard which could be described as if
it fits it's okay and fit being fairly
loose as anybody who's ever shopped for
a dress or suit knows
and um what i because most people have
no clue about any of this
what i say is is that you have to ask
questions constantly
and don't assume someone is acting on
your behalf so that means asking do they
have a legal duty to act in your best
interests and if they don't walk away
they're not your friend
ask what the fees they're getting are
how they're getting paid are they double
dipping which means they're charging you
and getting money from the financial
services sector this is a common don't
assume because you're paying for it it's
okay don't assume conversely if you're
not paying for it you're getting a free
service you're not somebody else is
paying the bill and that someone else
doesn't have your best interests at
heart
and those are really the things i try to
tell people just don't take anything for
granted don't just say okay
well uh
one of the things about michael is not
in the news finished his uh uh one of
his actually
weakest book called boomerang with some
exploration of the reptile brain and how
we can't deal with access and how we we
get tempted by by by credit and things
like that
what my book explains is sort of the the
magic of leverage and what that does and
the dark side of it the point about
leverage is everybody but bankers feels
the dark side and
those who lend are very good at
structuring the credit in such a way so
right now the distortions in banking
have to do with
sort of too much and too little credit
at the same time certain credit that's
good practices indeed of collection
credit card debt and other things that
are quite questionable at the same time
uh you know some lending that's not
happening or booms busts bailouts etc i
just like really quickly i have these
squirrels in my backyard and i talk
about them in some books not in this one
but that that it is so easy to take
someone else's money to leverage someone
else's money to bet however you want
wherever you want to have a political
infrastructure that allows you to do it
in a political and financial
infrastructure that saves you when it
doesn't work out at the expense of
everything that went into it that that
there there is
no real reason and there's nothing to
break um that danger on to on to the
rest of everyone else and the other
thing is don't ever consolidate your
credit like throw that thing away
seriously rip it that will that will be
painful but but there's so many ways to
extract
so many ways to extract the money to
leverage to go up and then have it
bailed out
as it is being right now even today
there wasn't a little bailout there was
a huge bailout it's still going on today
it's going on every day
plus the infrastructure creates an
implicit bailout and so
there's a definite danger to that
uh
right well that was the one other thing
that we learned from money magazine
which is that all of its advice was was
the wrong yeah do the opposite of money
basically buy money magazine and then
just do everything
now um one common element that that
struck me on reading all of your books
um
is the claim by your subjects that
they they actually are put on this earth
to do good and that they do they do good
um
the banks say
their lending provides the grease that
makes the economy go
the personal finance
types say they're saving people money
and helping them invest for the future
whether it's college
or
or retirement and we've heard we hear
this again and again certainly when
uh the prospect of regulation comes up
we're told that it'll destroy a good
thing um
uh i i know louis douglas who was um uh
one of fdr's original cabinet members
who i think both
and now we probably know the name um
very conservative but uh
at the moment when fdr uh called called
in his cabinet and said i'm taking
america off the gold standard
uh louis douglas's uh reaction was well
this is the end of western civilization
um so there's there's always this uh
this idea in the financial sector that
we can't do without them and and i'd
like to hear from each of you uh if you
have some thoughts on how much of that
how much of a kernel of truth uh there
is in that if if any and how much of it
is just pure narrative and and and
marketing
well i i now
sometimes when i don't have a lot of
time i use this quote
from paul volker this go again it's a
book that came out right after hours by
jeff connecton called payoff why wall
street always wins uh the in the preface
two quotes from there in the preface he
says unfortunately for america obama and
biden and he worked many years for biden
as a staffer
um
are financially illiterate i propose and
uh but then later when he worked for ted
kaufman ted coughlin was a very unique
senator because he wasn't running for
reelection so he actually was protected
from from delaware from uh money yes so
he took biden's seat when biden went to
be uh vice president and so he served
the two years remaining and he did not
mean to run for election therefore he
didn't care
about campaign contributions
jeff describes in the book payoff a
conversation between paul volcker and
ted kaufman the senator in which
paul
volcker says anything you propose to do
at all anything at all they'll always
say lending will suffer growth will
suffer and then he paused and he says
i'm quoting
it's all [ __ ]
so now how much let me say the following
it's not all regulation is good they uh
i i went i i go to sometimes to some
events where i see the the sausage
being made
i see the interactions between the
lawyers of the regulators and the
lawyers of the uh and then a lot of
lawyers involved by the way not
economists necessarily there's a lot of
legal stuff
and it's a it's this
power play and it's complicated and they
have this interesting relationship and
just like the tax code they want to
write it complicated generates more jobs
for consultants and other people so they
write a very complicated regulation with
lots of loopholes and and then lots of
people have to such as the volcker rule
for example the way it came off the
shelf was completely impossible to
implement then it's a thousand page of
of legalese rule
by the time it's done you know you might
as well forget it or let me give you
another example with words that you know
living wills so under the
monstrous dodd-frank
act that's supposed to save us somehow
the through to the same very regulator
that failed us before more and more and
more responsibilities only to mangle
this whole thing all the way and cut it
by a thousand cuts
and if any regular dares to do something
they cut their budget too sccf cftc
anyway uh in that
big first title of it there is a
requirement that the banks write a
living will
write a living would when you worry
about your loved ones you know making
decisions when you're alive about
connecting disconnecting you from
machines they want the banks to describe
how they would go through the same
bankruptcy code that lehman brother went
to through that took five years and
decimated all the assets that took down
the rest of the system when it was
triggered
how a jp morgan chase
at least four times bigger than lehman
brothers depends on the accounting
system
a lot more if you count more of the
derivatives in a lot more trillions of
dollars of assets no other company in
the world has so many assets to manage
how this
would be unknotted
through a bankruptcy course okay
good luck to all of us so they spend a
lot of time and a lot of money writing
these things
and then the regulator is supposed to
check these things and they're supposed
to tell us somehow that jp morgan chase
at the time when maybe other companies
like it will go down as well will go
down through bankruptcy without harming
us i do not need to see what they
submitted to know the answer is there's
no way in the world this will happen so
they will say no raid my lips no more
bailouts except for if there's no
bailout there's collateral damage still
so we're going to let them implode we're
not going to fix them then we're going
to charge these companies to fix them
meanwhile there's not going to be fuel
you're all you know these dead bodies
etc
so
in other words what's the alternative if
you let them drive at 90 miles an hour
when they do implode so
the point is not all these regulations
are effective or useful
there are things to do and they're not
that complicated but
it's a mess
um the dodd-frank act is [ __ ] all
right just to just to sum up what annoy
just said because because it is true
that you can drive a truck through
anything that is remotely related to
restraining anything despite every
complaint that's coming from the banking
system and the millions of millions of
lobbyists and lawyers and pr people that
are that are expounding upon it because
the regulators don't want to admit their
own the the volcker rule i read that
thing it's it's it's literally it's like
it's like it's like six pages of
somewhat kind of a rule and then it's
like nine hundred nine of of exceptions
it's ridiculous
um and the living wills too the the but
going back to your question too that the
after world war two and after that
period where where um
before that where fdr went off the gold
standard it was something that bankers
wanted at the time because though they
were in support of some of the reforms
that sort of divided speculation from
deposits
whenever it's easier to have money to
speculate with i.e you don't have to
connect gold to it you don't have
accountability to what you do with it
what whatever the matter is the less
restraints you have the easier it is to
speculate that the more likely it is
you'll make money quickly and then if it
falls apart and you have backing so what
and that was part of the gold stand that
actually went through the nixon period
because when nixon finally
took the us off of the gold standard it
was not he went up and talked about how
it was his
idea but in fact it was rockefeller and
walter riston's idea who was running
national citibank which is now part of
city group because they really really
pushed for this idea that america needed
to expand in order for america to be
powerful after the world war into the
cold war now in the ukraine in order for
america to be powerful that the joint
philosophy between the people that run
wall street and the people that were on
washington the people that elected
selected appointed and go in
all the sort of way in between is that
american competitiveness
is something that is important to both
it's important it was important
militarily to eisenhower when he came in
the eisenhower doctrine talked about a
military uh support of capitalism versus
communism that coincided a hundred
percent with the financial support
because while the us was was uh
supporting military maneuvers
the u.s bankers were opening branches in
those countries it was not it was not an
accident in terms of where the geography
politically and financially came so so
it's they do believe they believe it
very strongly because one and i said
this i think in the book and someone
quoted it or someone quoted it if anyway
but that they are mutually reinforcing
powers and the people that are involved
on both the political and financial
spectrum at the most elite levels
understand that is mutually reinforcing
they don't guess they don't think they
don't debate they don't need to
understand and they even if they did it
wouldn't matter because the ideology is
the same and the ideology about american
competitiveness and it doesn't matter if
that falls
on the faces if americans fall in the
face because of that or if anybody in
any other country falls on their face
because of that doctrine and that's the
same in republican democrats it doesn't
matter there are there are people there
are speeches in my book where different
people under different presidents say
the exact same words right sometimes it
sounds like they're reading each other's
lines uh
why don't you
take us out on this topic
as i think we all know our ability to
believe our own bs is simply
unparalleled as a species
and i think that's a lot of the
explanation that goes on here we all
believe we are virtuous actors in this
world uh maybe there's an exception here
and there but most of us don't and that
includes the bankers and the financial
services people they really think what
they're doing is okay and in our best
interests as naomi just said they think
that this is important stuff and that if
we don't do it the way they say bad
things are going to happen
um i think a lot of times it's their
best interest it's in their best
interest but they convince themselves of
that and more to the point these are
often very powerful interests and i
think as people since we're in l.a for a
minute i'll use my favorite celebrity
example which is
you know when i think when you live in
l.a you eventually know somebody who
becomes sort of a celebrity at some
point and you get to watch the process
and the process is is they start getting
surrounded by psycho fans and people who
tell them what they want to hear and
normal people are sort of embarrassed to
go near them and so what happens is they
slowly lose their ability to hear the
word no
and they get surrounded by people who
tell them who agree with them and this
is what happens to bankers and powerful
people as well so they just here they're
in their their um feedback loop
basically and they hear what they think
and what they think is of course that
they're acting right and we're all wrong
and that's basically how it happens you
know they're not evil i mean are they
doing evil things to some extent yes but
they're not always evil people
yeah okay um right i was just gonna get
to that um
i have a lot more questions but i want
to turn it over to the floor so uh any
of you
who oh gotta go
well we maybe we have time for
yeah
all right let's take a couple
thank you
there's a gentleman over there
i'm holding it i'm not i don't know who
i'm taking it to though okay all right
okay
[Music]
a fairly good looking person smiling
broadly on the
and
but i'm going to be the skunk at a party
but with a question
the left's interpretation of 2008 is
banking greed class
the conservative interpretation
view
emphasizes the role of government
specifically the role of the regulators
in pushing
banks on tight of losing their franchise
to
make loans that were bound to fail and
fannie mae and freddie mac also had a
very large role in that
and some of you talked in metaphors
it's just personal curiosity i'm not a
plant from the national review or
something
but
does do any of your books
mention the government's role in the
creation of this mortgage mess
thank you
before i take another question i just
want to remind you that books are for
sale upstairs and we'll be signing
across the way uh there's a uh
in 10 minutes lady right over here
yes my question is in regard to the
student loan system the student loan
system is coming upon its 50th
anniversary next year and right now it's
crossed a trillion it's into a trillion
dollar debt system it's not uncommon to
find anecdotes of people having their
social security checks garnished for
student loan payments
and you have
close to 50 percent of all students now
taking out student loans and
increasing number 20 30 percent in
delinquency or not making any payments
at all is this possible that this could
be the next great financial crisis
within the u.s
yeah um um absolutely i'm pretty
convinced this isn't going to get solved
till students are actually marching in
the streets and demanding relief at this
point
what we know is that the problem was
both growing for 30 years and then when
students lost the right to declare
bankruptcy on loans from private banks
and through part of the 2005 bankruptcy
reform legislation the amount of loans
out there doubled within about seven
years as soon as basically you know the
bank's defense by the way is oh no we
would never do this you know we can't
get blood from a stone well apparently
they think they can
and so this is what happened and the
only way it's going to stop isn't
because you're going to learn to manage
your money well or you're going to take
financial literacy classes or you're
going to go to a lesser college it's
going to stop because we demand that it
stop
and if it doesn't it will eventually
crash in on itself though i thought it
would happen by now it hasn't it could
go on a lot longer than we think i
suspect okay i guess the time has run
away with us um we all will be across
the way
uh to take more of your questions and
also to sign books so feel free to join
us thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
our coverage of the often questionable
means the program is about an hour
hi and welcome i'm nomi prinz i'm here
today with jake halpern the author of
the fascinating
and horrifying new book bad paper
um chasing debt from wall street to the
underworld jake welcome thanks for
having me
thank you this book is incredible and
and so is your story
and i think the two really mirror each
other this takes place um in buffalo new
york a lot of it um and you're from
there aren't you yeah that's right i
grew up there my dad and his wife still
live there
i go back there fairly often and it's
kind of how i find my way into this
world
you talk about a particular and many
unsavory characters that are scrabbling
to make their own piece of the world and
often have
prison records and have been drug
dealers and so forth there's a fellow
named jimmy that comes out here
that seems to be one of the main
characters of this non-fiction story can
you talk to me a little bit about how
you connected with him yeah so the way
this got started was
i was talking to my mom a few years back
and she told me she was being hounded by
a debt collector and she said i don't
owe the money that he's saying i owe
but
i think i'm going to pay him just so
he'll stop harassing me which my mom is
like no built-in willy so i thought
this is kind of bizarre and i started
googling it and saw that there was a lot
of this kind of going on and that
actually the epicenter of debt
collections in general in the united
states
was buffalo or was one of the big hubs
so
i had in my head that i was going to do
a story
uh actually from the collector's
perspective and what's it like to
collect debt what are the challenges you
face what's your life like so i pitched
the story to the new yorker just kind of
bare bones saying like what do you think
about this i'm from buffalo i could
probably get someone to talk to me and
my editor said great five thousand words
when can you get me copy so i kind of
panic because i i had nothing so
i went to buffalo once uh and
no one would talk to me basically and i
went a second time and i still had
nothing and so i started to panic
because i was on the hook for this story
so i went on facebook and i just sent
messages to everyone i went to high
school with and then everyone my brother
went to high school with and i get one
message back from
this guy was actually jimmy's brother
and i got jimmy on the phone and jimmy
said to me basically
you better get down here quick if you
want to talk to me because my but my
business isn't struggling i don't know
how much longer i'll be open
but if you can like show folks how hard
my day-to-day life is i will be
uh satisfied so i popped down to buffalo
showed up and jimmy just was immediately
one of these amazing characters it was
just eloquent and emotive and i'm
driving around in this car with him
going to church with him and meeting his
family and that becomes kind of my entry
point into this world
and he had a struggle uh you knew him
growing up as well you got to him
through a set of
correspondences through facebook and so
forth um tell me about your history in
buffalo just the atmosphere in buffalo
how it's changed
from what you knew growing up and in
your childhood to the kind of place that
it's one of the capitals right of debt
collection in the united states how did
that
yeah so i mean buffalo was once this big
industrial powerhouse it had all these
steel mills and all this industry and
starting in the late 70s and early 80s
basically when i was a kid that all
starts to fall apart and unemployment
goes to the roof and in place of a lot
of these old industrial jobs collections
kind of fills that void um someone told
me that buffalo is so good at
collections because even though the
country has been in a great recession
since 2008 buffalo's been in it since
1979 and people there you know can
connect with with people who are having
hard times so i when i was kind of a
teenager even this was starting to kind
of take form
um but i don't think i really knew about
it and and even though i went to high
school with jimmy we went to the same
high school
and it was supposed to be an integrated
high school we came from opposite sides
of main street and buffalo is a fairly
segregated city and i didn't have any
sense of what really what life on the
east side of buffalo was like or what
jimmy was going through and even though
we could talk about having the same
english teacher it was like we were from
totally different worlds and it wasn't
until i started reporting the story
that all of a sudden i knew that i
learned that when he was in high school
his father was a heroin addict that
after getting out of high school he had
become a cocaine dealer
had gone to jail in a gun possession and
you know our lives couldn't have kind of
been more divergent
so he you said is the entry point into
the rest of the store and he of course
has a very interesting component of this
story through something that you call
the package right um which seems to be
the crux of
what the what you're chasing and and
what the debt collectors are effectively
chasing and and involved in in the book
can you kind of talk about his
relationship what the package is right
and how that opened up the rest of this
amazing story to you so yeah so the
package is this one piece of debt that i
follow through the book and it's i think
helpful to understand that when i talk
about debt that's being bought and sold
here we're really just talking about an
excel spreadsheet so you have the big
banks or creditors and they try for say
six months to collect on a debt that's
not been paid and when they can't
they'll typically sell it off for
pennies on a dollar to to debt buyers
and
those debt buyers will collect whatever
they can then sell to the next and the
next the next and what they're selling
is just as they said a spreadsheet with
the bare bones information does the
information on customers on their
balances on where they live what kind of
information so like you look at the
spreadsheet we'll have debtors name
social security number address balance
date that the account was opened maybe
one or two other fields but that's
basically about it and they're just
being bought and sold and emailed or
sent by thumb drives and that's that is
the paper they call it paper but that's
really all that it is
and as you can imagine
it doesn't take much for something to go
wrong for some of the fields in the to
get mixed up the amounts the debtors
names to get confused or for someone to
sell the same excel spreadsheet to
multiple unsuspecting buyers who are all
collecting on it at once
so in my book i followed the package and
that what i call the package this one
piece of debt it's about 48 million
dollars in its face value but which is
bought for pennies on the dollar by this
debt buyer in buffalo his name is aaron
siegel
and what happens is this piece of debt
gets stolen
somehow
aaron finds out from his collectors they
start calling him saying aaron something
weird is going on with these accounts it
appears that somebody else has accessed
this information and is collecting the
money from the debtors on this package
before we get to them
so at that point he calls his fixer
who's a guy named brandon wilson who's a
kind of his unofficial partner who's a
former bank robber who's kind of gotten
into this business
helps him buy and sell debt but also
helps him solve these sorts of problems
and it's brandon who then goes
and tracks down
the thieves that have apprehend that
have gotten a hold of this debt and
retrieves it and we can talk about it's
a crazy
showdown with guns and they get it back
but the world in which he must go to to
retrieve that debt that's the world that
jimmy inhabits which is this kind of
gray area of legality kind of underworld
of buying and selling debts and kind of
sketchy manner that exists
in buffalo and other places right and
and this this underworld has that that
hierarchy you mentioned there you have
sort of
former thugs um to a large extent at the
bottom
level getting some of this paper that is
perhaps been sold and resold and you
also talk about how paper's been stolen
yeah um as well and then you have sort
of the level up through aaron siegel and
he seemed really an interesting
character to me i'd like you to kind of
talk about how you got to him through
jimmy and also through the package and
also he wasn't a thug he grew up on the
on the good side that's right buffalo
right he had a wealthy
family upbringing lived in a mansion
right um so how did he come into the
same
business right so the story really start
my the way that i tell the story in the
book it starts with this guy aaron
siegel and aaron grew up in a a a
wealthy and very well-known and
well-respected family in buffalo he goes
to wall street for a while as a banker
he even does a uh sometime in london and
decides he wants to come home and be
closer to his family and he ends up
working at an office of bank of america
in buffalo but around the time that he
comes back what's happening is is that
throughout buffalo
entrepreneurs are buying
some debt or they're buying this paper
these spreadsheets and then opening up a
shop where they hire a bunch of
collectors to collect on it and the
profit margins this is right before the
kind of great recession happens his
profit margins initially when he gets in
this business are through the roof he's
like buying a portfolio of debt for 30
grand and in three months making 90
grand
so
he realizes that he's kind of found this
amazing little
niche of the finance world
and his supply the key to much of his
success is he's got this supplier who's
supplying him with this paper at a
really great price and it's really
lucrative
the weird thing about the supplier is
he's this fellow brandon wilson who's
this former armed robber who's done 10
years in prison but has reinvented
himself as a debt broker who's got this
kind of genius for finding paper that
pays that is very collectible and isn't
that expensive to buy and so even though
aaron kind of comes from this very kind
of more rarefied world and has got this
kind of banking past
he understands that in this sector of
the economy it's not unusual to have
some kind of
shadier connections or some guys that
are rough around the edges and so he and
brandon form this kind of unlikely
friendship and partnership and that's
really the starting point for for for
the book and for the story and you talk
about how when they're looking for this
paper aaron's looking for paper looking
through it for it through brendan um he
actually also buys a portfolio from his
old firm from bank of america yeah that
you talk about as being not so great a
portfolio but for reasons other than the
fact that it's been stolen and moved
around the block many times right so the
irony is so aaron is always the key to
making a profit margin in this world is
getting good paper everyone's hunting
for for good paper
and
when he buys from his former employer
bank of america you would think this
would be as kind of respectable and as
dependable as it could be
he feels that the the bank of america
really pulls a fast one on him because
he spends all this money
millions of dollars buying this this
this piece of debt from bank of america
and it turns out they're almost all
senior citizens which have the smallest
amount of disposable income and he feels
that the bank of america failed him but
the former armed robber
um
brandon that he does business with kind
of comes through for him in a way that
his former employer doesn't what does he
do
so he's really behind the eight ball
when he buys this bank of america paper
and it's all these senior citizens he he
feels that he can't
he's not going to be able to turn a
profit because he's invested
all this money in them so and he goes to
back to brandon and brandon's specialty
is finding what he calls crap and crap
and brandon's definition of it is old
debt that everyone thinks is is is
worthless because it's been around the
block a few times it's been bought and
sold a bunch it's 10 to 15 years old but
it still pays because maybe it was
sitting in a call center in brazil for
five years and no one was working it or
maybe it comes from a debt buyer that is
about to go under and needs to sell it
off cheaply so brandon would find these
little deals on this paper and so after
aaron buys this stuff from bank of
america that really puts him behind the
eight ball he turns to brandon and says
brandon you got to come through for me
and really help me find these deals on
this crap and this other stuff that you
find and then the package which we
talked about before which is this piece
of debt that gets stolen the package is
actually fantastic paper for aaron it's
really good he doesn't pay a lot for it
it's it's paying off for him and then of
course it gets stolen and you know he's
like all right you know brandon go fix
this
right and how did aaron even come up
with the money to to buy the package i
mean he did okay he had a banking job he
went back to buffalo um who's behind
sort of funding the initial purchases of
some of these packages at the erin level
right so if aaron's story is you know
he's a banker he's in new york comes
back to buffalo
um sets up his own small collection
agency and with brandon's help he's
getting this paper that's really paying
huge dividends so he like any good
financier starts thinking wow what if i
did this on a much larger scale
so he
makes a few phone calls and finds eight
investors who give him 14 million
dollars to do a trial run the thinking
is
if if he can do with this 14 million
dollars what he's done with his own
money these 300 returns and whatnot
then he'll do it even you know bigger
for this 14 million and the 14 million
will then he'll do it a second round
with 40 million and bigger and bigger
the problem is is that you know that
there's several problems one of which
the great recession occurs and people
don't have as much money and then he
encounters many problems along the way
including the theft of some of this
paper um which you know i chronicle in
the book and he so basically before that
or while that's happening he he's in a
hole he's out
some amount that's a proportion of 14
million dollars he's got investors on
the other side squeezing him from they
want their money back you you visited a
couple of these investors right how are
they feeling about that what was their
stake in this and how much were they
pressuring him and how much was it a
portion of their own money how much did
they even care about what happened
really
i think what they gave eric it's funny
because so i did want to meet some of
erin's investors and kind of get a sense
for for what their take on this was and
i went out to dinner one night with one
of them and so first thing you have to
understand is there's this strange
sequence of events the debtors are owing
brandon who's collecting on it brandon's
getting the money he owes aaron who's
organizing the fund aaron then owes the
investors who gave him the money so
there's this everyone is beholden to one
ano everyone is connected by this thing
of debt so when aaron goes to meet one
of these investors this fellow named
joseph he's he's he's totally anxious
because he feels that he's going to fail
this guy and owe him money and it turns
out joseph just sees this almost as as
he's just popped him a million dollars
to see he's also put money into tanning
tanning salons and bars and
for him
aaron said he was hoping it would pay
off but it's almost like an amusement
and when we're having
dinner with joseph i say
do you ever
think about
basically the people's whose debts
you're buying
and he says
no why should i um they are they've made
you know bad financial choices is it my
fault for wanting to profit on and he
makes the analogy to a baseball game he
says if a pitcher pitches a bad pitch
and the batter you know knocks a triple
it you know
is the batter somehow wrong for taking
advantage of the bad pitch and that was
joseph's feeling about about the whole
situation um but it was it was kind of
crazy to think that um
you know i met some of the debtors
and they're you know you know a poor
single woman living in st louis is
connected to this um former armed robber
from boston who's connected to this
buffalo scion aaron who's connected to
this wealthy investor and all of their
lives are are connected by this chain of
debt but none of them really know one
another um that whole
aspect fascinated me yeah and the way
the way you write about it is is so so
clear it's like
we're there um you know in your writing
or you're an excellent writer and you
really are are not on the ground
journalists as well and that really
helps to bring a lot of these characters
and also the locations in which you're
meeting some of these people and you you
have gone around to meet from that top
of the chain the joseph's um down to the
bottom of the chain the individuals that
get really hurt and and rolled over in
this process and you actually talk about
some specific um individuals that are
just numbers right um in this package
they're just represented as numbers
that's right but they have real lives
and you went and investigated and spoke
with some of them you mentioned a woman
named teresa and joanna who
who were at one point
taking out credit and and paying it and
then things happened and they got
involved in this whole vortex right what
was that i mean you're absolutely right
what's what's so what's being bought and
sold here it's easy to think of it
almost as just as some sort of commodity
like coffee shares or something because
you're just looking at these string of
numbers on these sheets and there's
thousands of them and this one paid and
this one didn't pay but you pause for a
second you think that this package of
several thousand lines on this excel
spreadsheet
are basically several thousand stories
of people whose lives for one reason or
another have fallen into financial rune
so i managed to get a hold of this
spreadsheet for the package that got
stolen and i was looking at it and i was
thinking to myself these are stories
here these these names and these numbers
represent something that's happened so i
started kind of reaching out to some of
these people and explaining i'm the
journalist i'm looking into this
particular piece of debt that i believe
was stolen and i want to hear your
stories and most people just hung up on
me but a few
uh who i profile in the book talked and
and what they said theresa the woman
that you mentioned she was a former
marine
she had you know she defies whatever
stereotypes we have of a debtor she had
worked right through high school help
helping her parents pay off their
mortgage and
um her life comes apart after she gets
out of the marine corps she finds out
that her husband is cheating on her she
kicks him out of the house all of a
sudden she goes from being one income to
two income but she's still on the hook
for the for the vehicle payments and the
mortgage and she falls behind in her
bills
and at that point she stops
the fees start kicking in on this
washington mutual card which is the card
that was connected to the package late
fees and over the limit fees and
eventually she just can't pay anymore so
unbeknownst to her washington mutual
sells off this debt to a debt buyer and
it ends up in aaron siegel's hands in
buffalo and then it ends up being stolen
and in the hands of
these these guys that don't actually own
it so one day teresa of course doesn't
know about this so one day she gets a
call and says ma'am you owe this money
and you need to pay this right now or
there's going to be legal repercussions
and uh this is your chance to do it and
the calls get increasingly threatening
meanwhile teresa has got a job working
at border patrol in the southwest and if
she doesn't have a credit in order
it's hard to have a job like that
because you could be you know
blackmailed or there's it's a liability
right so teresa's thinking oh my god i'm
going to lose this job what am i going
to do i'm just going to pay these guys
off so she agrees to pay
2 700 off in several installments she
feels
good about it you know that she's
getting on top of it but when she makes
the last payment and she's expecting to
get some sort of receipt for what she
paid
there's nothing and when she checks with
the credit reporting agencies there's no
record of her paying she has no id she
assumed that she was paying people why
would you assume otherwise they had all
of her information
but she's paid people who stole her debt
and these are some of the these are some
of the people that aaron and brandon
realize are paying the wrong guy
so
you're absolutely right each one of
these names on this package of debt that
gets stolen are real people and the
stakes couldn't be much higher for what
this means for their lives and it seems
like there are so few rules or abilities
from regulators to really cover all of
these different points that you talk
about these individuals debt moving back
and forth when it does yeah um and and
people like teresa um
don't
they don't know what's going on they're
just they're just afraid they're just
paying because of the phone call what
kind of tactics are coming from that
other side of the phone call because
almost a third of americans who have
debt right now is it are in collection
that's right so they they may be getting
these phone calls from from some of
these people that you talk about in your
book what what is that like what's their
right so when so you're right absolutely
right about a third of americans have a
debt in collections and when you you're
getting called by a debt collector
basically what you get is the talk off
and the talk off is the collector on one
end trying to persuade you
to open your wallet and pay your bill
so there's legal talk offs there's
illegal talk-offs and there's kind of a
gray area so the legal talk-off would be
you know just talking through this is
the information i you you paid you owe
this amount of this your social security
number you need to pay this how can we
arrange this you have to do this the
illegal tactics are when you're
basically threatening and lying to debt
to consumers saying
uh we're going to take legal action when
that is not true we're going to arrest
you we're going to seize your property
um
lies and kind of coercion and threats
like that are not legal and that
that happens a fair amount and if you
think about it
it happens towards the bottom of the
debt food chain so if you have this
piece of debt the bank sell off to a
fairly reputable debt buyer
they don't need to do that to get their
money out of it fairly quickly but when
that debt has been bought and sold six
and seven times what you're left what
it's whittled down to are the folks that
haven't paid any of the previous six
owners
and the people that get that debt are
usually the people at the very bottom of
the food chain and that's where they
almost feel that they have to make these
very threatening calls and these illegal
tactics in order to kind of squeeze the
money out of folks and there's
often these are these small agencies
that open up they do it and then they
close back down and open up somewhere
else before they can be caught by the
authorities
um
and i just want to make one other point
which is that
there's not a lot of regulation and law
enforcement that exists it's changing it
is the consumer financial protection
bureau and the state attorney generals
are starting to get more into this space
but within the last bunch of years there
hasn't been much regulation and that ex
helps explain why a banker like aaron
would team up with a former armed robber
like brandon because not only is brandon
getting good paper brandon's basically
offering him a service
that regulators and law enforcement
can't which is when something goes wrong
i will solve this problem for you
because calling the police and calling
the state attorney general and calling
the cfpb is not going to get it done you
need me brandon wilson to straighten it
out and i think that that aaron
saw the the truth in that
and you make the comparison just in that
you've got you've got desperate people
on one side who are trying at the bottom
of their food chain to collect debts and
you have desperate individuals who are
getting these phone calls and they're
paying because it sounds scary yeah um
and you have very little regulation
particularly at the at the bottom yes
part of this chain um so so what
recourse do some of these individuals
have or or what can they do besides
where do they complain what can they do
if they've paid on a debt yeah but it's
gone to
no one i mean it's gone to basically
some of these people right i mean i was
sitting in a shop was sitting in jimmy's
shop one day in buffalo this is a few
years ago and i was listening to the to
the calls between
uh the collectors and the debtors and
the guy gets on the phone and jimmy's
trying to collect from him and says hey
you owe money on this payday loan
and the guy said i just paid this payday
loan off three months ago i paid 900
by the way that was probably a 300 loan
i just paid it off and and jimmy said
well can you can you send me um written
proof with a receipt from that agency
showing that you're proof
and the guy said i never got that and
then jimmy said to a matter of factly
well then sir i'm afraid you still owe
the money
and he turned to me and said i'm
that this is the only way that i know
that that guy is telling the truth like
if i just forgave every debtor that said
they had paid i wouldn't be in business
but you got a sense of the franticness
of the guy on the other line who
who sounded fairly earnestly paid this
off
and he didn't sound like he had much
much recourse i think the calls will
continue until you pay kind of thing now
there are one or two things that are
helpful for consumers to know
one is which is know what the statute of
limitations in your state is for when a
debt is no longer legally enforceable
and it varies from say like three to six
years but if you're getting a call on a
debt that's four years old and the
statute of limitations in your state is
three years old then you have no legal
obligation to repay that debt and the
other thing is after seven years uh most
negative reporting falls off your credit
report the credit reporting agencies so
so is it safe to say that that's that's
very interesting i think information for
for anyone out there getting these calls
is is it safe to say that if you do get
a call yeah on any level of threatening
after five or six years about a debt
back then is it safe to say you should i
mean ignore that call yeah i mean you
may feel that you have a moral
obligation to repay it but
yeah i would be very if it were me i
would probably think twice about
repaying it if i know in a year it's
going to go off my credit report rating
because it's been seven years or if
there's no legal recourse because it's
an out of step stat or beyond the
statute of limitations and the other
thing i would just say is
i would want to make sure the person on
the other end of the phone actually owns
the debt i want to and that's there's
not the problem is there's not an easy
way to figure that out but you could get
the name of the company check them out
on the better business bureau website
and get a sense for whether this seems
like a reputable company or not right
you actually
were on a call
as part of your research for this book
you're actually in one of these
collection centers and you you got on
the phone to sort of feel like what it
was to be a debt collector and have that
conversation with the person at the
other end of the phone what was that
like yeah so i was at brandon wilson's
collection agency and
we were up in in bangor maine and i was
just observing
and
he said to me look you've got to get on
the phones you can observe all you want
but you're not going to actually
understand what this job's like unless
you collect and i was kind of reluctant
for a few reasons one of which is i just
didn't want to like
hound people
but the other collectors who worked for
him started kind of haranguing me and
saying you've got to try this and i said
all right so
i got on they gave me a headset i sat in
front of one of these terminals and they
had it on auto dialer so that
debtors whose um contact information had
been verified would just route to me and
so the first call came to me and it was
a woman who owed i think like 450 on her
cell phone bill
and i said something like
ma'am i see you owe this 900 now with
interest but we can give you a reduced
rate would you consider paying this
and i heard myself saying and i thought
i wouldn't pay me that's such a weak
opening gambit
and eventually we're talking and i'm
trying to brandon's whole thing is going
to marry the debtor which is that i have
to have such empathy that you know like
what's going on with you in your life
you're you're you're working and that
will have some sort of connection that
she'll feel like she can
you know open up and trust me
and i'm trying to do this and at one
point she says well maybe i could write
you a check
and but i don't like seize on that right
away because i'm trying to marry her
and uh
and then she hangs up and brandon is
right behind me kind of playing you know
coach and he's like
look you failed at this not because you
didn't collect you failed on her because
at the moment she offered to make that
check you should have said okay i'm
gonna so you're gonna send me that check
yes and you're gonna send it to middle
of the month yes because in brandon's
psychology the minute that she promised
to make that payment
we had kind of gotten her because she'd
committed to this and now we could use
that the next time we called her
um
anyway so there's a few calls like that
i was a very bad collector but what i
realized at the end was
i could afford to be a bag collector
like i'm married to a doctor i i make a
decent living as a writer but if i were
desperate like some of these collectors
i would have gotten wise quick to what i
had to say and do to make folks pay
because they are desperate they are like
sharks i mean that's basically what
you've
depicted here in in a very clear manner
yeah i mean there's some collectors that
do well for themselves and work at more
of these kind of white glove customer
service type
places but a lot of collectors
are pretty desperate i mean i was at one
agency where and payday at the end of
the week one guy made 115 and another
guy made 85 dollars
and
that's poor
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through itunes and xml visit
booktv.org and click podcast on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
so jake you talk about
this underworld in buffalo and and going
up to bangor maine and getting on the
phones and dealing with that sort of set
of characters
then you also talk about another pillar
of this debt collection world which is
las vegas
and and you went there to do
investigation there and to deal with
some of these individuals and discover
new things there what was that like
right so i wanted to see how
brandon wilson was buying this debt if
you remember brandon is the former armed
robber who works for aaron and is
finding these deals on paper and those
deals are key to making the profit
margin so in the course of talking to
brandon about where he you know hunted
or searched for paper he said
las vegas every february there's a big
debt buyers convention and i go out
there and i hunt for deals
so i asked him can i tag along and he
said sure so in february 2013 i flew out
to vegas and spent several days with
brandon as he was on the prowl for these
deals he wanted to get a few what he
called these buckets of debt that he
could then bring home with him either to
work at his own collection agency or
that he could then flip and sell
to other folks
and
well it was interesting because when we
arrived there that year the the market
for debt was changing for two reasons
one was the regulators were finally
starting to crack down a little bit and
that was making some of the banks
nervous about who was getting a hold of
their debt the other thing is that
during the credit boom of the 2000s
credit was just everyone was getting a
loan and now all of a sudden after the
recession
people are becoming much creditors who
become more careful about who they issue
credit to which means that
the cost of buying these bad accounts
that no one collect on goes up so all
this meant that brandon had to work that
much harder to find these deals
and when he was there he was hunting for
this uh
paper that he called the ringcom paper
do you want me to tell you a little bit
about that yeah that's a really
interesting story okay so
when he gets there
the the word kind of on the street or in
the hotel lobby is that
there's a parcel of debt that everyone
is calling the rincon paper and it it's
it's a debt that belonged to an an
agency out in california known as rincon
that the federal trade commission
actually shut down because they were
doing all kinds of illegal stuff in
terms of collecting and threatening
abusing debtors and after they shut down
this
agency
its assets
um went into a court appointed receiver
the court kind of the same way that you
would seize like a drug dealer's car and
auction it off to raise revenue the same
thing happened but the assets that this
rincon
company had
were largely their paper um the debt
that they were collecting on so now
basically this court-appointed receiver
was auctioning off
this this paper and everyone was trying
to figure out how much is this worth
it's a big piece of debt so i'm going
round brandon he's kind of just doing
his intelligence talking to folks what
do you know what's the word on this
ringcom paper is any good how much would
you pay for it would you pay one penny
on the dollar would you pay a tenth of a
penny on the dollar that kind of thing
and i'm with him one day when he meets
this woman
who is another debt broker
and she
and brandon wants to talk to her because
she used to sell
debt to rincon and she was intimately
familiar with
the workings of the company and she said
don't buy it
and brandon says
i'm i kind of wasn't gonna i had a bad
feeling about it but why you're saying i
shouldn't buy it she said well
i have reliable information from the
people at rincon that some of that debt
was stolen after the offices were shut
down
and what's more that some of the chains
of title proving kind of legitimate
ownership of this debt is not there and
i i have this information she claimed
directly from people inside rincon and
if you buy that debt you're going to be
in a world of trouble because
particularly if it was stolen that means
someone else could be working the same
paper that you own
so i eventually called up
someone at the federal trade commission
i said is it possible that some of this
paper was stolen after the offices were
shut down and they basically said to me
i can't tell you for a hundred percent
certainty that some employee didn't walk
out the door with some of that paper
before we shut that down
so then i went and i did a little more
digging and i looked at the terms of
sale that the court was was saying if
you want to buy this paper this is the
agreement you have to
the paper the contract you have to agree
to it and the contract said
in pretty clear language we are making
no warranties or guarantees about the
accuracy or the validity of this paper
that's being sold so basically to sum
this whole thing up you have a federal
regulatory agency
shutting down a bad actor in the
business handing over its assets its
paper to a court appointed receiver and
there's an auction
and
they're selling off that paper they and
there's reason to believe that at least
possibly they're selling paper that's
been stolen and it was kind of
mind-boggling um you know these people
are meant to be cracking down and
solving problems might inadvertently be
kind of creating problems and in the end
brandon decides that um he just doesn't
want to make a bid on this on this ring
com paper that's that's owned by the
that's been controlled by this court
appointed receiver yeah i i find that
again horrifying that the fti ftc is
closing down a shop
taking that paper
not doing anything with respect to i
imagine the debtors that are involved on
the other side of that paper um because
they don't know what's going on with
their debt they don't know what's been
shut and moved to going to somewhere
else
and they could conceivably whether it's
for that paper other paper
be getting calls from collection
agencies that bought it stole it
whatever that they've never heard of
that they never had a transaction with
you mentioned for example
chase and washington mutual as as two
banks that at the top of of a food chain
sort of right had papers is different
from the rincon example
but at some point chase stops
selling correct it's dead on because of
regulations that have come into effect
after uh the financial crisis and with
the dodd-frank act how did that impact
first of all why did they do it was was
there other motives were the lawsuits
that they could have been dealing with
they didn't want to deal with and also
how did that impact this whole chain of
other characters that were involved in
in debt collection right so so the title
of the book is bad paper and bad paper
is just paper that there's problems with
and that therefore makes it hard to
collect and there's a lot of bad paper
out there because basically what these
big creditors like you know washington
mutuals now but now chase or that or
bank america whatever for years have
just sold these spreadsheets out with in
a not a particularly
uh careful or organized way
um to debt buyers and the contracts that
these banks create when they sell it to
the debt buyers clearly have these these
crazy warranties in them that say we're
making no guarantee about the accuracy
of this information
and there's problems with it there's all
kinds of problems with it and i saw that
firsthand with some of the the people
that were connected to the package that
i looked at in the book
um just to give you one quick example
there was a woman
who's connected to this package whose
debt after going through the whole
circus of what happened in buffalo ends
up in the courts down in georgia
and she's getting um it appears on her
credit report and she's in danger of
being sued over it and i i meet with
this woman and i say
okay
what's the story with this debt and she
said she says i was hoping you could
tell me i don't recognize this
washington mutual debt that i supposedly
owe
so i said okay there's got to be an easy
solution here let's call chase bank
which now bought washington mutual and
we'll just ask them directly
what's going on with this amount and
with this debt that you don't recognize
so i call up a spokesman for chase and i
say i have this woman right here her
name is julie she has this on her credit
report but she doesn't recognize the
debt the amount anything like that can
you help us clarify because when this
was sold off it appears maybe it was
done in a kind of
their mistakes or what
the guy from jace calls you back and
says jake uh we've decided we're just
gonna write off julie's debt as fraud
and i said well why and he said well we
don't have any of the underlying
documentation that would give us
confidence that this is in fact a valid
and accurate debt
they had some statements but they didn't
have the original signed contract or
proof of who was paying the debt i said
what do you mean you don't have it like
you're the bank shouldn't you have it
and he said well
when chase acquired washington mutual
was a very rapid process
and information was lost
now when chase acquired washington
mutual that is one of the largest
financial acquisitions in recent history
and you're talking about a pillar of the
financial world and they're basically
saying
you know what
we don't have this paperwork so
the mistakes that are being made that
makes this paper bad aren't just being
happening at the very bottom of the food
chain the debt food chain where you have
street hustlers in buffalo there's every
reason to believe it's happening at the
very highest levels of finance and our
assumption of my assumption going into
this that oh banks are not going to be
making mistakes like this
is not necessarily a safe assumption to
make
i mean you you're actually coming at
this entire story which is one of the
reasons i think it's it's the writing is
just so
clear you're coming at it not from a
sort of financial
component but really from the ground up
from this underworld you talk about and
from the individual's role in all of
this and how people are are impacted um
the stories that surrounded the
washington mutual chase merger and
everything that was happening during the
financial crisis of 2008 um have come
into focus as being about this sort of
thing happening mostly with mortgages
with with
attachments to mortgage loans being lost
with robo signing and all sorts of those
kinds of things you actually bring up
that this is going on and had been going
on and has been going on not just in
mortgages but throughout this entire
credit spectrum with credit cards and
other types of debt as well that's right
i mean i think at this point people know
that there is a lot of funny business
going on with the way that mortgages
were issued the way they were bought and
sold the way the houses were foreclosed
upon it's been in the press i think
there's been a lot less attention given
to this idea of consumer debt whether
it's credit card debt or payday loans
but they're the same sorts of problems
and
the way where that you see this in some
ways most strikingly is when we get to
the courts which is where we get towards
the end of the book
so
basically all those folks that are
calling the debt collectors that are
calling saying you got to pay this
they're basically relying on the talk
off to convince you to pay but if they
can't
do that then often it ends up in the
hands of lawyers who then sue on that
debt and this is where it goes to the
court and many of the same issues that
they've had with robo signing with the
mortgages um
they're having similar issues in court
with credit cards because basically the
lawyers that are suing on this debt
the evidence they have is fairly thin
it's these excel spreadsheets and
there's problems with the excel
spreadsheets
and
but what happens is is that there's a 90
no-show rate with consumers in court so
if you think about it here just to make
it like
you know simple
i'm a guy jake i can't pay my credit
card a whole bunch of debt collectors
call me up they bought and sold my debt
for pennies and cheap around the dollar
i still can't pay it well eventually
they bring in the lawyers and the
lawyers sue me for this amount and now
most likely what they're saying oh is
much higher than the original principal
balance might be three times higher
because of the high interest rates
so
if i go to court i can challenge that
and say where did you get this number do
you have proof this is really my debt or
what's the breakdown of interest and
principle
but ninety percent of americans don't
show up in court they either don't
understand what it means not to show up
there or they're
they feel there's no point and what
happens is these numbers on the excel
spreadsheet that are highly suspect to
begin with
then get stamped by the court and it
becomes a judgment against you and then
your creditor can now garnish your wages
they don't have to call you up and beg
you to pay they can go right at your
bank account and clean it out they can
get your monthly work check and this is
happening there's a new study that's out
by npr and pro publica that shows that
10 of americans between 35 and 45 are
having their wages garnished every week
so
that's what's happening yeah
that's astonishing so you've basically
given um in this book in this interview
in in bad paper two two very important
pieces of advice for for consumers out
there who are involved in this debt
collection process one
if someone calls about a debt that's
over a certain period of time you should
be very suspect about that call and
likely ignore it um and also as you're
mentioning now you should show up in
court if you get some into court because
you have a much better chance of
writing whatever wrong you've been
involved in than if you simply don't
show up and it goes against you that's
totally true and and i'm not that that
in itself is is a justice you have
provided through bad paper um to i think
the entire american public um so thank
you for that on behalf of the american
public um so you you you were in in
court you mentioned savannah georgia and
the kind of history that georgia has
in the debtors
prison and the debtor's idea of of
and all sorts of things and you actually
stood by some of these people yeah it's
interesting so the history was that you
know originally georgia was conceived as
a kind of utopia that would rehabilitate
debtors they would come from the debtors
prisons in england and come to the new
world and get a fresh start and kind of
get out of the chains of debt and
rebuild their lives it was this kind of
very
upbeat optimistic view of reinvention
kind of getting
but the irony is that
that's really not the case
in america these days i mean we hear a
lot about how americans can declare
bankruptcy and get out of their debts
but there's lots of people who are just
have horrible credit ratings therefore
pay higher rates on all kinds of loans
they take out they're having their wages
garnished their checking accounts
cleared out
um it's quite a contrast to this utopian
vision
um
that originally founded the state of
georgia and then the other part of your
question which is about you know going
to court
and there was a fairly funny thing that
happened to me which was that
i wanted to actually see what this
process was like
so i followed the package of debt that i
followed in the book and i went to one
of the courthouse where some of the
debtors connected this package had been
through
and i just showed up just to kind of get
a sense of it so i'm waiting outside the
courtroom
and i start talking with this couple
who's being sued over a credit card debt
and they don't recognize the people that
claim to own the debt that the
creditor's name doesn't ring a bell for
them and the amount doesn't make sense
to them and there's no documentation
about the breakdown of that amount we're
trying to figure it out and this guy
calls out their name a young lawyer this
is outside the courtroom and he calls
out their name and they walk over there
and he says to them
i represent the people that own your
debt and let's just settle this
basically let's just settle this right
now and we can work out an agreement you
can pay me and we don't need to go
before the judge
and they start he then reaches into his
briefcase and pulls out this
document that looks almost like a credit
card statement but kind of like a
mock-up of a credit card statement all
it has is the amount they owe their name
their address and then the top in bold
print it says this is not an actual
credit card statement okay so they're
kind of looking at this to see what this
is and they start talking to this lawyer
and
at some point along the way i pipe up
and i say
do you have any documentation to prove
that you do in fact own this debt or any
further information that gives a
breakdown of the debt
and he says to me are you a lawyer
i said no i'm just writing a book and he
said well you can't represent them and
in fact as this escalates he says i'm
going to take you in front of the judge
so i returned to the courtroom with this
couple and the woman who actually is on
the hook for the debt the judge calls
her up and then she calls the judge
calls me up as well
and we get sworn in together kind of
like we're co-defendants in this and i'm
it was it was like a kafka novel or
something so
sworn in and the lawyer who's suing on
this debt says precedes his opening
arguments and says
mr halpern here is
appears to be practicing law without a
license in your honor can you please
tell him that he could face criminal
sanctions for doing this
and i i say like your honor i just asked
a question i'm trying to figure out the
process with these folks that i met
about 15 minutes ago so this goes on for
uh back and forth for a little bit and
finally the judge says
to this lawyer
what do you want to do about the matter
of this debt that this woman owes
and he says let me consult with my
client he goes up makes a phone call
comes back and says your honor we're
going to drop the case
so at this point me and the debtor
looking to like what just happened and
we're kind of scratching our heads we
walk out into the hallway and there's a
guy there who's for georgia legal
services and he says basically to us
i'll tell you what just happened
you said the magic words and the magic
words are prove your case in other words
this couple simply by showing up in
court and pressing back just a little
bit asking for the barest thinnest
amount of evidence of legitimacy of this
debt and the detailed information of
this debt was enough
to make the person suing on it back off
and the whole thing kind of just
crumbled
and it was this moment where it was so
funny the whole book i've been chasing
this package of debt this excel
spreadsheet through the streets of
buffalo that i'm down on the courts in
georgia and the moment it comes under
even the faintest bit of scrutiny it's
like it just
vanishes into nothing
that's amazing
now
you mentioned earlier that
the whole chasing of paper and the whole
zealousness of the debt collection
business got to a larger height during
the the great recession after the
financial crisis because people just
simply had less money to pay and they
had more debts that had accumulated and
you talk about the term the shadow
economy um for those people which i find
very interesting because when the we use
the term shadow banking usually it's
it's about hedge funds it's about you
know cayman island tax shelter type
things the shadow economy is is
something different um and it's it's
it's something that you you discuss with
respect to the people on the on the
bottom of this and and i want to know if
you can just talk about where you think
those people and and how that's going to
evolve going forward from from where we
are now right so
this happened the way that i kind of
stumbled into this is when i was down in
georgia and i was looking at the lives
of these
debtors who um had basically were being
sued in court over this debt i wanted to
try to get a sense for what their lives
were like and one of them told me
that she bought her car from a special
car dealership that offered that
catered almost exclusively to people
with bad credit so i went out to this
dealership
and
what became clear was is that they were
paying an enormous premium
for their bad credit and in the words of
this car dealer their money was worth
about 70 cents on the dollar and a car
that was maybe should have cost nine
thousand dollars is gonna cost thirteen
thousand dollars in fact another debtor
who i followed
he actually had his bank account cleaned
out he was one of these guys that there
was a judgment imposed against him they
found him and they cleaned out every
cent they had in a savings account which
was then going to cause him and caused
him to default on his car payment
which then could compromise his ability
to get to work and his particular
situation is he had a device a gps kind
of device on the engine of his car so
the moment that he went into default on
this car loan which he was paying this
premium on boom
the engine would shut off and his car be
stuck at the side of the road
so
this is this is the world that people
inhabit who have really bad credit and i
went and stayed at the i visited this um
housing complex where it was basically
all people who had very bad credit and
um
yeah they live in this world where
they are paying the highest possible
rates of interest
um
and there's basically
no
no trust creditors don't trust that
they're going to pay the bills and so
they get kind of stuck with this and on
the one hand you can kind of understand
it from the creditor's perspective these
are very risky investments but it's also
pretty hard to see people who are so
poor
having much of their income devoured by
by interest and they're the ones that
are getting kind of the most gouged by
this
and when you talk to the ftc or the the
consumer protection board have you
gotten a sense that this is an issue
whatsoever at all that they're trying to
do something about um
helping yeah the people on this side of
the the circuit and also just just
generally you know the fact that there
are such heinous interest rates and yeah
to payday loans
way above user levels on other loans on
credit cards that continue to get
imposed on the people that have the
least ability to pay i think you
mentioned one instance which which is
very logical where one of the people in
your book says you know if i
hadn't been hit with the extra charge
the extra rate
i would have been able to pay this we
could have negotiated everybody you know
this all could have not been this chain
of shadowy underworld financial stuff um
do you sense any understanding of trying
to get to the root of this matter at the
washington level i think yeah i think
the creation of the consumer financial
protection bureau which was the kind of
brainchild of now senator elizabeth
warren
was a good move and they are starting to
make a difference in the space um and
they're going to have new rules coming
on about a year that will affect debt
collections
and they've they've been aggressive i
mean it isn't
if i were in charge i mean i would give
them more funding i mean a lot of this
is going to come down to
how
much resources do they have to kind of
go after the bad actors so the consumer
financial protection bureau might have a
budget of i don't know between four and
five hundred million dollars but just to
put that in perspective if you look at
the amount of money that jp morgan chase
set aside for litigation reserves in
2013 basically the amount of money that
they put aside to kind of
defend themselves the consumer financial
protection bureau's budget is two
percent of that
so you get the sense that they're doing
good work
but
they're kind of outgunned here
and i think that you know
hopefully
if anything comes
the book i mean i i hope it's a call to
arms to kind of give them a shot in the
arm another thing that's i was on the
phone the other day was someone from the
justice department they have this
operation uh this initiative called
operation choke point and the idea
behind this is is to it's hard to go
after these the payday lenders that do
the worst stuff
so what the justice department has
started to do is go after
the payment processors so if i'm a
a payday collection agency and i'm doing
bad stuff
i still have to rely on a payment
processor to take your credit card or
your debit card information and take the
money and the justice department has
started to say
hey
payment processors if you
are dealing with these unscrupulous
payday lenders we're going to go after
you
and there's been pushback about that
because there is a strong payday
loan lobbying uh presence and that that
is pushing back against this but i think
that you need
initiatives like that and we you know on
a larger scale if you're going to see
the kind of change that needs to happen
to clean up the industry yeah and
hopefully yes and reading your your book
that that chain is illuminated so well
and hopefully that can be a catalyst to
at least increasing the funding and to
look at these sorts of things in the end
of your book and i guess towards the end
of
how many years of research did this well
in one fashion or another i would say
it's been about four years okay so at
the end of that time you go back to
buffalo you you kind of do an epilogue
on on the characters the individuals
have been involved on the debt
collection side on aaron and brandon on
jimmy um and kind of see where they are
at the end of or the most recent period
of time what was that like i think the
most surprising thing that i encountered
in writing this kind of wrap up this
epilogue
was that
what i found from teresa who is the
debtor the former marine if you remember
and she's the one that paid
the wrong collector the collector that
had somehow gotten a hold of her debt by
theft so
i was curious about kind of where she
was and how she was doing and just as
the book was about ready to go into its
final version she called me up and said
you're not going to believe this
but i just got a call from another
collector on that same dead which was
puzzling because when aaron siegel who
would was the rightful owner of it had
discovered that there had been fraud he
did the right thing which was that he
retired the debt he kind of he didn't
sell it he put it in a it's a hard drive
and their rest in peace in theory
and yet someone was collecting on this
on this debt still
so i called
um
the agency i wrote them a letter
actually that was that that had
contacted teresa and i said i'm
inquiring about these calls that you're
sending to this woman because they're
threatening to sue her
uh what is your claim to ownership of
this debt and i thought i would get like
i didn't think i'd hear from anyone and
i thought if i did hear from someone i'd
hear from someone in like some you know
chop shop and you know buffalo or
something turns out i talked to a guy
the owner lives in beverly hills
and is doing very well for himself and
when i ask him about this he kind of
says let me look into this
oh yeah
this debt belongs to a portfolio of debt
that i purchased from a debt broker in
florida that was double sold and a lot
of the numbers have been manipulated all
these problems with it and he's and he
but his attitude was not shock but kind
of like
this is par for the course in this
business hey you're just purchasing data
and you never know what you're
purchasing
and it was just kind of chilling end to
the whole thing
because of course you're not just
purchasing data you're purchasing
the right
to collect on people's
debts and profoundly affect their lives
and
somehow or another
the whoever stole it from from aaron
must have sold it to someone else as
well and to this day teresa's debt is
just floating around there in cyberspace
and someone else will buy it and then
try to collect on it
and somehow that that that more than
anything else just kind of seemed to
speak to the to the chaos and the
dysfunctionality of of this
industry
yeah so if you had to give one message
to
consumers and to regulators to to fix
this what is what is the takeaway
i think that the consumers is that you
have to be skeptical of who's calling
you on the phone and you can't assume
um blindly that they have a legitimate
claim to this debt or that the amount
that they're asking for is in fact
accurate and you have to do your
homework and make sure that you know
that there's still a legal obligation to
pay this debt and
and you have to kind of the equivalent
of driving defensively um with your
financial
uh reaction to these calls um on the
larger level there's a few things that
need to happen
one is
um that there needs to be better
enforcement more resources for places
like the consumer financial protection
bureau two is the banks have to be more
careful about what they pass along and
make sure that information is correct
and there's all the documentation
there's supposed to be
and three
i think that there needs to be a change
the way that this court system works
because the 90 no-show rate and these
all these default judgments is creating
these garnishments and all kinds of
problems so there's a there's a there's
a fair amount that needs to be done all
right well i want to i want to thank you
for coming here today for for writing
this book um and for bringing this
information these stories of these
individuals and what happens to the
people on all sides of this debt
collection chain and what they can do
and what should be done at the higher
levels
of the country on a regulatory basis um
i congratulate you for writing it i
loved reading it i read this in a very
um quick setting i couldn't really stop
reading it and so thank you for being on
here thank you for writing the book and
the best of luck with it thanks so much
that was afterwards book tv signature
you can watch this and other programs
online at booktv.org
okay let's do a little test and make
sure the people in the back can hear me
you want to wave at me back there can
you hear me you're okay everybody can
hear excellent
well good evening everybody i'm julie
slavinski the director of events at
warwick's and on behalf of warwick's
welcome to an evening with nomie prinz
before we get started a few housekeeping
things to go over first of all um let me
just thank all of you it's when you come
out of your homes and spend the evening
with us in support of your local
bookstore it allows us to keep bringing
you wonderful people like nomi to the
san diego area so please give yourselves
a little round of applause for doing
that because we certainly appreciate it
um
we have a lot of exciting things still
happening this summer um and we've
already i'm already doing a lot of
things that i've set up for the fall so
if you're not on our email list get on
that
we've got a packed
packed schedule um or you can check out
our website or take one of the flyers
whatever you'd like to do
um
remember to turn off your cell phones so
you're not that neighbor that gets the
dirty look
um
during the q a um sean over there is
going to be handing you guys a
microphone so that microphone is for the
wonderful c-span that's here tonight you
aren't going to hear yourself through
the speaker but you're going to be on tv
so when you watch this you want to make
sure that you're out that you're
actually talking into that speaker so
that they can hear you so just keep
track of that and just wait for sean to
hand hand you that
um but why we're all here tonight nomi
prinz a former wall street executive is
a renowned journalist international
investment banker public speaker and tv
and radio commentator she's the author
of six books including all the
president's bankers her writing has been
featured in the new york times forbes
fortune
guardian and nation among many others
she was a member of senator bernie
sanders federal reserve reform advisory
council and is on the advisory board of
the whistleblowing organization expose
facts
she's here tonight to talk with us about
her latest book collusion how central
bankers rigged the world it's been
receiving amazing reviews and press
i'm going to read a quick one here for
you paul craig roberts former wall
street journal editor and assistant
secretary of the u.s treasury said quote
the us doesn't have a financial press it
has something better
nomi prince
read this book to understand the central
bank conspiracy against the world
economy please ladies and gentlemen give
a warm warwicks welcome to know me
prince
[Applause]
thank you julie thank you warwicks i am
one of the great things about
writing books um is that you actually
get to come into all these places around
the country and around the world and and
see people who who read them or will
read them and be in these amazing
independent bookstores
where
a lot of stuff happens um and they're
super important i i will probably and if
i don't ask me questions about it talk
about how all this global stuff
ultimately impacts
everybody at a local level and therefore
i just always believe it's important to
to to be supportive of local and and
also of independent bookstores and again
i thank you warwick so thank you c-span
for being here tonight you all look
great you look great on camera
um and thank you
so so what i want to do is kind of take
you on my journey um
to this book and while i was writing
this book and from there talk about
what's happening um in the world today
as a result of a lot of the things that
the book talks about that the collusion
talks about and that you're probably
experiencing anyway on a day-to-day
basis in your own personal economies
and then open it up for questions um so
as a going back in time thing um as
julie mentioned i was an investment
banker i'm one of the first things i did
as an investment banker was go to china
this was in the early 90s and china
was not really on the map in terms of
talking about you know whether it's
manipulating currencies or involved in
trade wars or any of the things that are
now being discussed about it it was a
place where um i went with a team of two
of uh bankers from lehman brothers which
is about to have the 10-year anniversary
of its demise
coming in september the start of the
financial crisis and the reason i went
to china was because i had been working
at lehman brothers on something called
the futures and options desk
which was sort of the nascent
type of financial instruments that
ultimately became more and more complex
and more and more risky uh to the global
economy and to end to financial markets
but at the time
i was having this like fight
with the sales guy on the desk because
sometimes in investment banking
people try to take credit for other
people's work people try to get other
people out of their way there's a lot of
sort of heads that that could but and um
i was the analyst i was the one like
writing the code and doing the analysis
and looking at the numbers all that sort
of boring wonky stuff and he was like
this flashy kind of salesperson and
every single time i would come up with
an analysis for a trade he would
basically take credit for it say it was
his and you know try to get paid more
because of it
sales people got paid more than analysts
anyway but but besides that um and it
got to a point where there was a lot
going on um in in the early 90s and i
wanted you know some credit for the work
i was doing i was coming into work at 5
5 30 i was leaving it whenever i was in
grad school i wanted to have what i did
you know
make a point um and so i went to
management and i said i was going to
quit
and manage why do you want to quit
you're doing good blah blah blah i said
i just i can't deal with this like he's
angry he yells at me on the trading
floor i just don't and so what they
decided to do was rectify this entire
situation by sending us on a trip
to asia together
and they decided that this would be a
good idea because either we were going
to kill each other someone was going to
survive or we would wind up friends
which to them meant we could make the
money but the point was that was their
decision so we take off on this multiple
you know city country exposition it
starts basically in malaysia
you have to red eye et cetera et cetera
it winds up in china it winds up at the
the people's bank of china um and a
number of other banks in china where we
proceed to try and sell u.s treasury
bonds which they now have a lot over 1.1
trillion dollars worth to the people's
bank of china
and also kind of to juice it up with
these futures and options that if they
do with lehman brothers lehman brothers
will make more money they'll be able to
sell more treasury bonds um and the
people's bank of china will be able to
buy them and everybody will be happy and
this kind of repeated itself throughout
different parts of asia um we did wind
up being friends but it wasn't
necessarily because we're working on
these products together he was still
there trying to get in front of anything
i said however um we wound up in this
sort of you know death defying kind of
drive from when we got to the
philippines to trying to get to our next
country which i think was taiwan or
something whereby
we were going to be late we were going
to miss the trip trips were day to day
to day to day it was banking it's like
you don't have time for sightseeing and
the taxi guy had to get to the airport
in like 20 minutes it was like you know
40 minutes away um and basically the
salesperson said look i will i will pay
you a stupid amount of us dollars if you
get us there on time so the guy says
okay great he jumps into oncoming
traffic on the other side you know
barrels down the highway i'm in the back
seat doing this uh he's in the backseat
next to me i think i'm going to die um
he probably thought he was going to die
we made it to the airport we made it to
taiwan and and and we did become friends
so that's how banking works um
it is it is a life or death kind of
thing and that was that was ultimately
how i got to china it was interesting to
me in this particular book and if you
just think of circles of life and
finance and just everything is that i
wound up going back to china for this
book i'd been in in between to china but
to go to the same people's bank of china
um many numbers of years later um and to
go to the same
great wall of china and to sort of do
what i had done but in this world where
everything was different yet i was doing
similar things
and as a result of that i was able to
kind of work the book around what was
happening and what had what had changed
in all these years and what had changed
mostly in all these years was was the
power of central banks throughout the
world the influence that they've had in
particular since the financial crisis
which is the period um for which i've
written this book
because they've been able to produce in
different countries for different
reasons
a lot of money in order to subsidize the
financial systems the banks the markets
in those particular countries now china
did it in a different way and we'll get
back to them the main sort of actor in
all of this was the federal reserve it
is the federal reserve it is the u.s
and the way in which i depict the u.s in
the book is not to give the u.s or the
fed its own chapter i specifically had
it as the main character
in all of the chapters and all the
regions that comprise the book which i
call pivot countries or pivot regions
and i analyze them since the financial
crisis to see how they behaved relative
to fed policy whether they supported it
or tried to go against it what happened
therefore to them politically and
economically
and how the world sort of changed around
these pivot countries over these past 10
years with some major ramifications that
aren't even related to monetary policy
but because of monetary policy or the
level of interest rate
that the fed sets the level of interest
rates that other central banks set and
the amount of money that they have
conjured or produced to subsidize
their markets and the countries or
regions or pivot areas that i went to
were mexico brazil china japan and then
different parts of europe including the
uk doesn't want to be a part of europe
right now and that was actually also
part of a ramification
of what's happened since the financial
crisis
this all started
because i was asked to speak at the fed
in
basically the summer of 2015. so before
i started actually researching this
particular book
i had written a book called all the
president's bankers
and that had basically gone into the
history of american finance all the
individuals involved the families
involved institutions involved how they
related to presidents and how they
basically influenced and created
domestic and foreign policy over the
past hundred years for this book it was
it was more narrow and so when i went to
the fed to speak i had been asked
they have this
annual conference between the federal
reserve the imf the international
monetary fund and the world bank all
located in in washington and they they
sort of have this three-day thing where
there's a day at the fed a date the imf
a date the world bank and there's
different seminars and it's it's not
public there's no television there but
there are central bankers from around
the world that come to sort of talk
about the issues of the day and there's
always a sort of main theme that's the
sort of central theme at each of these
given places so the central theme that i
was asked to talk about in 2015 was why
wall street
isn't helping main street and this was a
conundrum to to central banks in
particular federal reserve who had
determined this particular subject
matter when i got
the request to speak i i was confused
because i have been rather critical of
fed policy since the financial crisis
began and how i believe they've
subsidized the banking system rather
than sort of reformed it um but but i
asked them you know are you sure you
meant me
um
and and you know because and and they
said no we we actually do want to hear
hear this other side where you know come
so so i'm there i speak um
in the morning session the first the
first day of these three days um and
janet yellen who was the former chair
woman from the fed at the time had
spoken first and one of the things that
she had basically conveyed
to this room full of central bankers
from around the world was that
everything was fine
that the banks were sort of reformed
that
regulations were in place to sort of
protect the american and by extension
global population um and that there
wouldn't be a crisis again i'm
paraphrasing but this is basically what
she said um and then someone from the
treasury department came and sort of
said the same thing but but more
confidently
and then a cardinal spoke and one of the
things he said to this this room of
central bankers was
i don't know anything about finance or
economics or what monetary policy is but
i do know that there's a world out there
that that could potentially be in pain
and that is your responsibility to
to remember the poor
and that was basically what he said with
that i came on
um in front of this room it's at the
room where the fomc the federal open
market committee gets together to
determine whether they're going to raise
rates or lower rates or keep rates the
same
we were all in there and i said you know
let's get back to the question the
question is why
isn't wall street helping main street i
said that's that's really simple we we
get this right it's because you never
made them
you you you the fed you the major
central banks
around the world never said look we're
going to give you a boatload of money
we are going to reduce rates and make it
very easy for you to access money very
cheaply
for 10 years
at the time it was a little bit less
than that and we're not going to ask you
for a single damn thing in return
so we don't really have the right to
wonder why wall street isn't helping
main street i mean i just explained to
you a little bit about how many years
ago
wall street sort of in the background
was fine you know having people sort of
you know going on coming traffic to get
to the next meeting um to sell some
bonds
that wasn't exactly the business model
but that's pretty much what went down um
and so so wall street given a lot of
subsidies and
these subsidies became a total of four
and a half trillion dollars of something
called quantitative easing which is a
very wonky term and there's a lot of
wonky terms that come out of finance and
monetary policy even monetary policy is
a wonky term it's like how much does
money cost
how much does it cost you to get money
how much you have to pay in interest to
get a loan
at the base level for for the banks in
the country for for governments in the
country um but but when you look at
whether wall street's going to turn
around and say you know thanks for four
and a half trillion dollars where you
basically gave us money i.e the fed and
you bought from us two things you bought
1.75 trillion dollars worth of
mortgage-backed securities which are
basically the things that came became
known as toxic assets which were related
to subprime and other types of mortgages
going into the financial crisis of 2008
and you paid top dollar for them you
know it wasn't like you even analyzed
them you basically said
you the banks have a bunch of securities
that you can now no longer get rid of
because they are completely toxic and
nefarious and they don't really
have anywhere near the value that you
said to anyone that they have and they
certainly don't have it now so we'll
just pay you full price on them
and and that's basically what happened
to the tune of 1.75 trillion dollars
which is a lot um from from the banks
the other part of that four and a half
trillion was that the federal reserve
created or i talked about this word
conjured a lot of the book and some
somebody actually did a mini review of
the book and said if they had like a
drinking game for the amount of times i
used the word conjured in my books they
would just be blacked out completely
before like the end of chapter one it's
used a lot i don't know if that's the
case i didn't try it it's used a lot
because what happened was the federal
reserve was able to electronically
create
money
for which they received bonds including
these 1.75 trillion mortgages and and
the rest of treasuries why do treasury
bonds come from banks they're made
they're basically bonds that are created
by the u.s treasury department they're
effectively the u.s treasury department
saying to whether it's a country or an
investor or a client of a bank who's
selling these bonds we'll pay you a
certain level of interest
in return for you basically lending us
for a particular term a bunch of money
going back to china china has lent the
us through this
process 1.1 trillion dollars for which
the us government pays interest
now what the fed did was it decided to
conjure this money in order to buy these
bonds that the banks were supposed to
sell elsewhere from the banks so
treasury department creates debt for
basically no reason which goes to the
banks because they are the brokers the
big banks that are supposed to diffuse
it to the rest of the world and and
investors and it goes back to the fed
for which the fed pays interest to the
banks
now if you cancel all of that out
you save a few trillion dollars
but that's not what happened it didn't
happen in the u.s and it ultimately
didn't happen throughout the world and
this is one of the reasons i talk about
the term collusion
not in a sort of russian you know voting
sense but but in terms of an actual
collusive effort between the fed and the
major central banks of the world to have
this process work
in such a way that the major banks of
the world can all benefit
um from having money rendered cheap and
from having these subsidies that central
banks create because if it was just the
fed that helped the u.s banks
in the fall of 2008 and the spring of
2009 and going onward it wouldn't have
been enough money it would not have been
enough to have our interest rates
rendered zero percent so banks receiving
money from the fed at nothing and
receiving interest for the bonds that
they were getting from the treasury
department
because they gave them to the fed and
receiving the subsidy of a total four
and a half trillion dollars to to
continue to do what they were doing that
actually wasn't enough
um it wasn't enough
philosophically or ideologically it just
wasn't enough financially and so what
the fed had to do from the beginning of
the financial crisis was ensure that the
other major central banks
particularly in the g7
could be on the same page
and as a result all the central banks
ultimately the european central bank the
bank of japan the bank of england had to
effectively get on the same page as the
fed and render all of their interest
rates zero percent or negative and also
engage in this bond buying process this
quantitative easing
because reducing rates as they do by
setting them wasn't enough they had to
create all this money and take bonds out
of the market to create demand for them
to reduce rates even further and what
that did was it created 22 trillion
dollars worth of subsidies for
the major banks in the major g7
countries of the world
now
it didn't just stay in the pockets of
the banks though a couple years ago when
i did the math banks had on average four
times the amount of cash they had on
book before the financial crisis so
they've managed to take some out along
the way um but 22 trillion dollars is is
more than the gdp of the united states
so so what's happened in in in this
collusive effort amongst the central
banks because the fed needed it to
effectively save the u.s banks and
ultimately keep the rest of the
financial system of the world from
imploding under the guise that it was
the economies of the world that they
were trying to save
is is still out there
it is still sort of the layer now that
buoys all of the major banks as well as
the major financial markets because what
is this cheap money or what does
quantitative easing really allow to
happen it allows banks to say all right
well
we're going to now go and lend this
money cheaply we're getting it cheap
let's lend it out
to companies to people and so forth and
they will in return pay us some amount
of interest and we'll make what's called
the spread between what we lend out
which we are getting at nothing and and
what we effectively take in or the
interest that gets paid to us and they
keep doing and doing and doing um as a
result of that rates stay low the value
of bonds is higher
because the relationship of prices on
bonds to rates of bonds is an inverse
opposite relationship
and then stocks go up stocks go up
because you have extra money that
corporations have either gotten because
they borrowed it so cheaply or because
they have all this extra cash if they're
banks
or because they're leveraging or
effectively borrowing back from the
banks because the money is available
and where do you take it you don't take
it into government bonds because
government bonds are paying like nothing
in the major countries of the world that
are all participating in this exercise
and so you put it into stocks and you
put it into riskier assets and you
basically create all of these financial
bubbles throughout the world where the
economies that this process were
supposed to be influencing at least if
not helping
in in a lot of ways have become
fragmented
between the individuals or companies
that have been recipients of this
process and and the ones that haven't
that's created greater inequality that's
created greater economic anxiety and it
doesn't matter um what one's political
persuasion is it's not a question of
whether the money should go to one place
or shouldn't go to one place the reality
is it's gone to
a system of people that were involved in
institutions that were involved in
wrecking the economy in the financial
system to begin with um and not been
diffused to the rest because if you had
taken 22 trillion dollars now
and given it to the real economy to
infrastructure to development projects
to you know building higher speed trains
to get from san diego to la or whatever
then you would have a situation where
more people were put to work more
engineers were involved in the process
you know more programmers or technical
people were involved along the way more
technology was involved and so forth and
and you would have a different kind of
an economy that was more sustainable
when you just
use capital use you know sort of free
money to speculate with that's that's
what happens um and that's sort of where
we've gotten to now but but what i talk
about in the book is is a bigger
ramification than just how much money
was created to save the banks and the
financial system and has gone into the
markets and and and what happened
politically um and also from the
standpoint of trade wars and everything
else that's manifested since um this
process began and that's that in the
beginning
um and i'll do again a very quick sort
of tour of my book
take a country like mexico you know our
neighbor one of our major trading
partners and so forth mexico went
through something called the tequila
crisis in 1994 where basically its
currency was slammed its banking system
was slammed it was kind of an awful mess
and it got out of that by lots of
different ways which is a different book
um however
the head of the central bank of mexico
at the time of the financial crisis a
man named guillermo ortiz was part of a
sort of family of of mexican officers
and so forth and involved in in lots of
different aspects of history as well as
trying to get out of that tequila crisis
and he went to ben bernanke who was the
chair of the fed at the time in
washington um and he said look you know
if you do this
if you do this process it's gonna
potentially really hurt the financial
system and confidence in the banking
system
and there's going to be sort of major
ramifications going forward from that
and ben bernanke ignored him
um and basically didn't even write about
him in his memoirs i mentioned this in
the book he wasn't like even a footnote
um but but he basically went ahead with
this quantitative easing process ortiz
went around the world at the time trying
to warn um people in the academic
community and and throughout the world
and some of the non-g7 types of meetings
that were happening amongst financial
leaders that look you know if you if you
create a bunch of money and you put it
in this way you're not regulating the
system properly
it's just ultimately not going to have a
good ending now he did not get
reappointed to be head of the central
bank of mexico because he was not saying
what he should have said at the time
which is that what the fed's doing is
awesome and what ben bernanke is doing
is very important um instead he got
replaced by a man named augustine
carstens
who went on to say what ben bernanke is
saying is awesome and it's very
important that unfortunately had the
impact of creating a lot of inflation in
mexico and a real economic uh problem in
mexico because he was trying to follow a
fed that had a very different kind of
financial system and bigger pockets
as they're called on wall street in
order to basically liquefied or provide
money for it
ultimately he came around he's now the
head of something called the bis the
bank of international settlements which
is kind of the central bank of central
banks it was created in the wake of the
crash in 1929 in order to facilitate
kind of communication amongst the
central banks and create reporting lines
and sort of a communication amongst them
just to talk about how different
policies impacted different countries
and whether what was done locally made
sense globally and and the opposite and
he's now kind of more critical of the
fed um in in brazil
um something interesting happened which
is that um going back to the beginning
of 2008 president lula who's now in
prison or
basically indicted in prison but at the
time he was he was sort of a major force
in brazilian politics and he was very
concerned that the u.s financial crisis
would hit brazil which it ultimately did
and so he had an appointee who was
running the central bank of brazil a man
named
marialis and he basically was trying to
also do a little bit about what the fed
was doing and then he tried not to he
tried to raise rates in brazil such that
there wouldn't be inflation people
wouldn't be able to not afford food and
so forth ultimately there were shifts in
government he left etc the new person
that came in tried to do what the us was
trying to do and what the fed was trying
to do and that that hurt brazil even
further now enrique's back he actually
became the finance minister under uh
michelle temer's government he was the
interim gov
president he is of brazil now he's
running for president um so so the other
thing about all of this is some of these
individuals do do resurface
throughout these sort of elite
roles of you know central bank head
ministry of finance president and so
forth and he's actually if he i don't
he's probably not going to win the
presidency but but he's someone who's
been around and had the ramifications to
his career both positive and negative
from both following and not following
the fed in china um going back to to my
friends at the people's bank of china it
was very different because the governor
of the central bank of china from the
beginning said
he was very critical of the policy of
the fed and they didn't try to follow
what the fed was doing instead and this
is actually really a ramification of
what's going on today i think um he got
very public in the non-g7 community and
with some of the g7 allies like japan
and he said um we have to worry about
this whole rate thing because when rates
start to go up it's going to hurt our
countries it's going to hurt emerging
countries and so forth and what he
managed to do more than any other
central bank leader
is get the imf which was a u.s european
construct out of world war ii to accept
the chinese currency to accept the
chinese rent into
a basket of currencies that's supposed
to represent
the major currencies of the world the
chinese currency still represents very
little the percentage of overall trade
of the world but it got jumped in
to this basket of currencies that
included the us dollar
it included well the euro which which
had before that been the french franc
and the german deutsche mark the
sterling the pound sterling from the uk
and the japanese yen so basically became
the fifth member of this of this
four-member group of currencies because
of the criticisms that were made against
this policy
and because other countries were worried
too it goes back to what i saw in that
room that day in 2015 i saw a lot of
central bankers from around the world
that that weren't particularly public
about whether their country was being
hurt by some of the bigger countries
creating money out of nowhere when they
couldn't
um and therefore creating a lot of
anxiety and economic problems throughout
the world um they they believe that
something else had to be done and what
they believed had to be done was more of
a sort of unified approach outside of
the g7 to trading with each other to
developing other currency relationships
and so forth and again that wasn't
necessarily an ideological shift that
was a shift because of money it was it
was to reduce the risk that another u.s
financial crisis might impose upon the
world and it was to reduce the risk of
what will happen when interest rates
rise too quickly or the fed or any other
of the other g7 central banks begin to
really unwind or sell off some of these
securities that they've bought these
bonds that they've bought from both
banks in our country corporations in the
european uh community as well as
corporations in japan and actually ask
for the money back which they're not
going to do but the even process of
talking about doing a little bit creates
instability and raising rates creates a
hardship for the countries and
individuals that have borrowed at
cheaper rates to repay them and that
creates more economic stability in the
world
and as a result of that and the
anticipation of that
china has managed
as well as other emerging markets to
just develop more alliances with each
other um not sort of in in opposition to
a political decision but is in again
a way in which they can sort of
reinforce their own economies um so when
i went to japan from china i'm going
through the order of my chapters um
japan's very interesting because
obviously it's it's a big ally of the
united states from a monetary policy
perspective it was the number two bank
in central bank in terms of creating
money and reducing its rates to negative
and being on board with the fed policy
over the last 10 years after the
financial crisis but um one of the
things that i found there just being on
the ground and doing uh research and
journalism on the ground and talking to
people who had been involved in the
central bank there for years of the
ministry of finance in japan for years
and so forth is that there's a lot of
alliances that have been happening
actually for years
even though officially their governments
might have not necessarily blessed them
but between members of the central bank
community to talk about ways in which
they could
swap or trade each other's currencies or
or sort of help if there is a financial
problem
in each other even though they had
technically been
adversaries really since since world war
ii so some of the shifts that they were
beginning to um to go through were
actually happening because of monetary
policy because of economic um and
financial fears of of what could happen
in another financial crisis they've
become
trade relationships
but they began as as currency and just
transactional types of relationships
where they had no choice but to start to
to be more friends with each other and
this is what's now happened more
publicly
when i went to europe who has just
signed a major trade agreement actually
with japan um third biggest coverage in
terms of economies in the world um you
know they've had a lot of ramifications
since this financial policy monetary
policy has been adopted and um that
could have been a whole book i mean i
could have just spent like years just
just doing
europe or or china actually any of these
these areas but one of the things that
happened there um is that the european
central bank and any central bank made
choices
they made choices to
use the money they were creating to help
weaker countries
or stronger countries
and one of the things the european
central bank did was decide and again
this is this is not a political thing
but they decided i mean it is but i mean
it was a monetary decision and a money
decision as well
um to do things like create money to
help german companies or or french
companies or or the core stronger part
of europe to begin with um because the
argument was that well they're better
bets i mean you know if you lend money
to someone who's good for it um right
then they're going to repay you so so
that must be a good thing even though
this money was created out of nowhere
and if they were good enough they
wouldn't have needed it
but five and a half trillion dollars
worth of money was created by the
european central bank um to help europe
and it chose not to help for example
greece it chose not to really help
portugal when it needed it it sort of
had this like ongoing thing with italy
but that's mostly because the head of
the european central bank mario draghi
actually used to be the head of the bank
of italy right before the financial
crisis and he waited his shot to get
into the european central bank and run
that to get out of italy um and actually
work with ben bernanke on on a similar
policy uh which still exists in europe
um but by making the choice
of providing subsidies for
yeah so that the banks you know ubs um
union bank of switzerland or or deutsche
bank and and the countries and so forth
involved that's taking a pool of money
from nowhere it's conjuring money and
it's deciding um to play favorites and
that has ramifications it has
ramifications in europe between the uh
weaker and stronger countries to begin
with and the fractious nature of the eu
um which has other
issues but but from the standpoint of of
that inequality that's been sort of
imposed upon it
and it also i think manifested in in the
brexit vote
because one of the things that happens
historically is that whenever there is
economic anxiety amongst a group of
people or countries
or people that can look at sort of
immigrants coming in and therefore
damaging their own you know job
potential or look across the border and
see problems or whatever it might be
they want to vote for whatever doesn't
exist
um you know they they want to vote out
of where they are because the
governments involved
aren't listening and and they aren't
helping and so the first thing
you do is you sort of blame what's going
on around you and then the next thing
you do is you blame the government no
one blames the central bank i mean i was
in i was in the uk talking to parliament
a couple months ago about some of this
stuff and
that weekend there were all these people
demonstrating in the streets because
wages had just been registered as like
the lowest in 17 years relative to um
the cost of things so lower than uh they
had been going into the financial crisis
and and there was some other measure by
which they were the lowest in in decades
and everybody's sort of marching outside
of a
part of of london and no one was
marching in front of the central bank
which is a very imposing building in in
you know to to be not you know in in
london but um no one was doing that
because you don't really think well
we're going to march outside the fed or
march outside if you're going to march
if you're inclined to march outside of
these central banks because the the
the level of influence that they have i
think is not really
fully understood um in terms of how what
they do impacts all of these other
things
and so in the case of brexit when when
the uk voted to sort of split they're
still dealing with whatever might happen
from that um from the eu the idea was
that the eu is just basically not
helping them economically
for different reasons because immigrants
were coming in because they're making
decisions that supported the eu
countries rather than the sort of
uk on the outside would it whatever
whatever it was to anyone who voted for
that the reality is there was a lot of
economic instability that was imposed
upon in the uk by the central bank who
did create almost a trillion dollars 800
billion worth of of money out of nowhere
to to not put into the real economy
um and this bothers people i mean i i
think i think here as well one of one of
the things that our election in 2016
showed is that um there there were a lot
of people and there are a lot of people
here who just feel very disenfranchised
economically um and and how they choose
to vote um is is very much a byproduct
of who they think can help them um and
so one of the ways in which government
shift um is because of this in germany
this is happening there's a lot of
swings to nationalism throughout the
world and a lot of the swing to
nationalism from helping everyone is to
basically help yourself it's what's bank
is what banks do all the time um but
when you do it on a country by country
basis or on a people basis
that isolationism sort of by definition
doesn't allow
um you know partnerships to be built
better and and to help sort of everyone
um
gain more economic or financial
stability as a result um so so i look at
um to conclude a lot of how these extra
factors have really come out of
this ability of the fed and and by
demand or collusion or extension
other g7 central banks
to basically fabricate in an unlimited
manner i mean these are people that are
not elected they are appointed
and the money that they've been able to
create and use
is um technically unlimited
they decided the fed to stop at four and
a half trillion i mean they could have
stopped at three they could have stopped
at ten you know and there's there's
there's no actual legal limitation on
any of this which means if there is
another financial crisis it can continue
um and it can continue to have sort of
deeper ramifications and than the ones
that i think are tied to um you know
someone creating a whole artificial
supply of money that goes to some people
and not others um that that has
manifested since the financial crisis
we're now 10 years since that financial
crisis um and and and these types of
issues um and these types of connections
from the standpoint of central banks
creating money not taking it out not
trying to actually restructure the form
reform systems not creating
infrastructure or project or other types
of longer term financially beneficial
and economic growth um
ideas and and sort of actions
really has ultimately very high
ramifications on geopolitics on trade on
people on economics going forward and on
potentially
another economic crisis or financial
crisis around the corner one of the
things i wrote about my first book after
i left wall street after i left um
goldman sachs was a book called other
people's money and in it i said that um
if we don't change what we have
um and this was after a period of a lot
of scandals a lot of corporate scandals
in the beginning of the 2000s that were
fueled or financed by the same banks
that ultimately were at the center of
the financial crisis of 2008 then then
we're going to have a fall there's just
no way around and it's going to be tied
to securities that aren't particularly
understood or regulated by the people
like the central banks that are supposed
to understand and regulate them
we're not really that different right
now except for the fact that there's
more debt in the world and there's more
of a subsidy that's artificially sort of
bolstered the financial system by these
central banks than there was beforehand
and so that's something that it concerns
me it's one of the other reasons i wrote
this book to explain how all of this
sort of connects
and also to hopefully
get more dialogue
amongst
people on you know everywhere um in in
terms of what's actually happening and
um how we can protect ourselves and and
what kinds of
policies should be created um and people
should be instituted in order to to make
those kinds of changes so um with that i
want to thank you
i want to open it up to questions and um
go from there
thank you
and i just want to say that there's a
mic that's um going around that that
allows
your voice to be heard
uh if you were head of the fed right now
what would you do
so
here here's here's an idea
what i would like to do
not just at the fed but with some of the
other central banks
because we are where we are because we
do have rates that are so low they've
come up a bit and we do have this
massive book of assets that if they get
sold out we'll crater everything right
so i think what should happen
is that we should
really do
what these subsidies were supposed to
have done which is to create actual real
growth and real infrastructure
development there's a way to do that
um which is for example to create an
infrastructure bank um it's to take
money that's already there debt that's
already been extended and to use it
which banks do every day as collateral
as sort of um
yeah assurances for other types of
finance that can be raised or monies
that can be raised in order to actually
go through projects in order to actually
you know build trains and build bridges
and build highways and do the kinds of
things that technically
this money was supposed to do if the fed
had said 10 years ago you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna give walls to
four and a half trillion dollars okay
to everyone i mean would that have just
annoyed just everyone
um but if you say okay well now we're
gonna cut some of that because
unfortunately financially we can't
go back but what we can do is we can
divert that capital to the stuff we said
it was supposed to do to begin with
and it's not that hard to do from a
banking perspective
it's it's actually quite easy and that's
what i would suggest doing to the fed um
i have um and to different congress
people um as well as to other
legislators throughout the world because
it's a way to get out of this mess and
get to the thing the solution
that it was all supposed to have been
created to get to
thank you um
thanks for visiting us here and
um
i like that idea a lot we do need um
infrastructure for the future
um
and i'm just
remembering back to the sit there was
also a political situation
after the subprime
crisis which led to the greatest
recession since the depression and we
had 10 percent unemployment and um the
economy was really in horrible shape and
it was spreading around the world
and yet after
an early um 2009 i think fiscal stimulus
of about 780 billion dollars
and congress changed over they weren't
going to allow
another dime of additional spending
in terms of fiscal policy so it seemed
like
the fed whose job is to look after
inflation and employment both a dual
charter
almost had no choice but to start
creating
a big money supply because there was no
fiscal
capability at that point
and so they started
buying bonds
and
so on the one hand people were really
worried that was going to be
hyper inflationary with the 4 trillion
on the other hand
others believe that's what helped us
crawl out of the
what could have been a depression
and
so how does
why aren't we using that i mean that
that's now first of all that a lot of
that money the 4 trillion didn't really
make its way into the economy it was
basically sitting on banks balance
sheets
um but again fiscal wasn't really an
option for you know true government
spending which would be the more
traditional way to do infrastructure
how policy wise would that
even happen where we could because now
they're trying to reverse the
quantitative easing and so how could a
program commence whereby
the banks were somehow enticed or forced
or a combination
to create an infrastructure bank with
all that cash
and and use it for infrastructure for
the future
yeah that that's that's a really good
question so so the banks won't do it on
their own will any more than they've
done over the last 10 years they don't
want to they don't need to however
the way this could work
is for
an actual
act of creating a national bank or an
infrastructure bank and our country
doesn't have one other countries do one
of the ways for example that china even
though it's also done a lot of
quantitative easing in its own way it's
used a lot for
infrastructure building uh not just
within china but um throughout the
throughout its recent regions and with
former partners of the us like it's
doing deals with argentina and brazil
and so forth because it has the funding
and wants to use the funding for that
rather than to put it uh you know into
the financial markets which is what has
happened here so it would have to be
something that's chartered
either through through state
legislations for for a component in in
states but more so at the federal level
um and actually i've spoken um with a
number of senators and congress people
on both sides of the aisle um because
there there's there's positives about an
infrastructure bank for both sides of
the aisle um one is that you're not
creating more debt
um so so from a conservative perspective
of of
acknowledging that a lot of debt has
been created over over this decade
this would be a way to take debt that's
already been created and sort of divert
it um you know not necessarily sell it
off and and hurt the the level or the
value of our bonds but basically to use
it so that has to be an actual act um
and that's something that there's
interest in i think because a that um
and b
on the on the democratic side there
there's there's
not that it's either or but it is just
working out this way um that you know
there's this idea that rather than have
another financial crisis um if if the
fed is going to get back to any sort of
normalcy um you know how do we do that
in a way that doesn't um deflate you
know real economy and sort of real jobs
and so forth so it has to be a legal um
construct it has to be funded i think it
could be funded in different ways but to
me that makes sense by by existing debt
um it has to be something i mean if i
were to structure it tomorrow you know
there's people from uh you know
different sides of the aisle different
sectors different ideas of projects and
there's like a certain amount of funding
and it goes you know this this this to
trains and this to you know bridges and
this to ports um one group that's very
interested actually is homeland security
because they want more funding for for
some of the the the port area so there
there's interest in trying to find a way
rather than have an argument every 10
minutes within the walls of congress to
say all right we want to budget this can
we
you know trade this for this and the
defense part of this for the social bit
of that rather than do all of that is
say there there's an actual financial
construct outside of the private uh
banking system that they can fund
together
private banks are welcome to you know
fund a bridge with this national bank
call you know usnb or whatever um and
and work as they did you know throughout
the 50s to build highways or whatever
together there's different ways to do it
um but it does need an act
thank you
know me your comments are very
interesting and the question i have is
related to
sort of this
question of the proverbial crystal ball
and what you've witnessed in terms of
your life experience working in the
financial sector and based on what
you're seeing currently
given both the political climate and
what's going on with fed monetary policy
what you anticipate in the future i hope
it's not an unfair question
no it's it's a great question a couple
years ago i anticipated you know
a potentially
difficult
financial crisis to occur
when the european central bank promised
it would stop its quantitative easing
which was a couple summers ago after it
had had to do a lot of it um when there
was a crisis in europe that began in
2012 so there's been a lot of sort of
ins and outs over this period on a
global basis it's all really um global
and
i thought that the time at which things
would start to really go on the rails
would be when these banks really stopped
their programs
what happened was they didn't stop their
programs
because they knew this the problem is
they don't have an exit plan you know
the problem is you know short of
diverting and explaining and doing a lot
of things that they don't want to have
to do because they'd much rather
you know get out of their positions go
into the private sector and and call it
a day
um and say well what i did if my time at
that central bank actually worked
because nothing catastrophic happened
during my time
i think that means there's another
crisis brewing but however
the timing i i i don't know because i do
know from my experience over looking at
this stuff over the last 10 years and
not having been available in crises
before that
is that central banks
have become used to their ability to
provide money when they need to
to to you know smooth over any rough
edges and so if the fed now starts to
raise rates i was supposed to raise
rates at first three times this year
then it said four now i believe it's
it's not sure um i personally think
it'll be three but um it's forecast for
if it starts to do things too quickly um
it runs the risk of hurting emerging
markets other types of debt companies
and so forth and so there's this there's
some
i forgot the word someone it's like a
teeter-totter we're kind of in the
middle so there should be another crisis
because there is too much debt and it's
subsidized by not real stuff
on the other hand there's a lot of power
and influence and and desire to keep
things
up and balanced
so as a result
i think there should be a crisis
nothing's been reformed since the last
one it's only been pasted over
but because it has been and can be i'm
not sure when
i'm sorry i'm just
this is not new because we've known to
follow the money for
generations and it always ends up with
the bankers
who's benefited from these trillions of
dollars
where because there's always going to be
somebody
who has carpet bagged there's always
going to be somebody who has
that money is somewhere doing something
i can't i'm listening to you and i love
listening to you but the question for me
is why
why would you put the world's economy
in the tank deliberately and then
deliberately try to shore it up if there
wasn't a financial benefit
to someone somewhere so
this goes back to i'll just really quick
um so
in the wake of the financial crisis i
wrote a book called it takes a pillage
and it was
it was before a lot of the kiwis start
it was like in the beginning it came out
in 2009 so i mean i don't even know what
i predicted i don't remember but but i
did talk about exactly what was going on
and how it would probably grow to sort
of fix uh the system and and the math
was such that the the amount of subprime
mortgages that actually lined all of
these toxic assets that failed and
plummeted some banks and created all
this profit
was was about a half a trillion dollars
so just think a half um the amount of
assets that u.s banks created off the
back of that half
mixing and matching and moving stuff
around was 14 trillion so a half 14. but
it was worth but then what they did was
they lent money to lots of places and
lots of other institutions including
like the ones down the streets the
investment banks bear stearns and lima
my old firms
on top of that so that they could buy
those assets
so the math worked out that that was
about normally ten to one it was much
more than that but just just to make it
really conservative that meant that a
half a trillion of subprime mortgages
was supporting a hundred and forty
trillion dollars worth of
financial
stuff
as a result of that
it was imperative for for the fed to
come up with some way
of sort of riding that
tide by creating enough money and
reducing the cost of money as well
in order not to have all of that
completely implode that meant that some
of the borrowers did implode some of
them could borrow more more cheaply and
sort of pay out what they had borrowed
to begin with to buy that stuff i mean a
lot of things happened and needed to
happen
in order to save the financial
institutions that ultimately were left
standing now you could have done this in
other ways you could have just
paid a half a trillion dollars to the
mortgages that lined all of this stuff
and there would have actually been no
other crisis and it would have been
really much cheaper
but that that was a mentality uh
situation i think a lack of
understanding of how banks operate but
certainly uh that was more of a
political
um ideological decision was to we need
this we need this solution to help
these institutions because otherwise the
entire economy is going to implode
forever
sort of um and and that's that's where
that's why the money went
to save
a lot of the
financial creations of this
pre-economic crisis
in different ways and since then it's
gone into the stocks of these companies
it's gone into the cash balances of
these companies it's gone into buying
other companies
it's gone into creating
the most historic debt that the world
and consumers have faced um since
financialized
institutions were created to to provide
them lending so that's where it's gone
it where it hasn't gone which is why
it's a really good question um is into
stabilizing and growth and that train
and that bridge and that whatever that's
where it hasn't gone
it seems like the last four or five
recessions have been
caused by bank profligacy and no one
seems to pay any attention to
supervising the banks that is there and
now that they've had these you know
some
legislation
you know
watching more closely dodd-frank i guess
now they're talking about easing up
shouldn't they have a program to qualify
people to watch what they're doing or
maybe make the banks a utility and
avoid some of these crises well part of
just even having a portion of debt
become a nationalized bank to actually
do the things they're supposed to be
doing more of um would be at least a way
to defuse some of that yeah we shouldn't
have extra deregulation for the banks i
mean they've paid
you know hundreds of billions of dollars
off of the money that they've received
very cheaply or freely
into settlements and fines for frauds
they've committed in the past i mean if
you look at a bank you know california
if you look at a wells fargo
um you know they've they've paid
multiple billions of dollars including
recently for a portion of which for um
you know creating fake accounts and
stealing money from their customers and
stuff and you know if you do that
including like auto loans and other
things i mean if you're if you're like a
person who steals a bunch of cars off
the street you're probably gonna get
indicted you're probably gonna go to
jail and if you do it over state lines
you're definitely going to have a felony
you know conviction if not indictment so
that hasn't happened and so to
deregulate them further or the idea of
of any
congress person on any side of the aisle
deciding that it makes more sense to
give them more latitude when they
already have like a ton of subsidies
with which to operate um
it just doesn't make sense
and going back to your question um that
when there is a crisis that will be a
part of it the banks haven't stopped
doing what they were doing into the
subprime crisis by sort of rejiggering
subprime loans into other types of more
complex assets they're just doing it now
with corporate loans corporate loans in
these
close or in these these these mechanisms
are uh
being bundled
at record levels so it's not mortgages
anymore it's all the loans they've given
to corporates
and so to deregulate them or at least
not to watch what's going on with these
clos
is really a a crisis in the making
i think you have a couple of questions
the first one is can you give us
uh layman's uh analysis of the pros and
cons of the dodd-frank
right
and uh the second is about the debt
when is
borrowing
when it's enough enough we all i don't
know how many trillions of dollars of
dollar
so dodd-frank super quick is a 2010 act
that was created to
dial back some of the risks that these
banks had imposed on on everyone and and
the idea was that they would have to set
aside one of the ideas more of their own
money so that if there was an emergency
the government wouldn't sort of have to
come in and and take care of it um
it didn't actually get created in the
wake of man of
knowing how much was available from the
fed or how much would be available from
the fed so that didn't uh didn't enter
the subsidy idea but it was the idea
that banks would have to create living
wills they would have to say if you know
if an emergency like the crisis happens
for x y and z reasons um we need to have
more set aside so we'll handle it on our
own um and there was also other things
that came out of that act like the
consumer financial protection board
which um has done a lot of good it's
done about 12 billion dollars worth of
of getting back stuff that's been stolen
well
frauds and different types of activities
that have been committed against
consumers by banks in the year since
2010 that it's been created and so forth
what the dodd-frank act didn't do
um is separate banks by bringing
something back called the glass-steagall
act which was an act in 1933 in the
height of the great depression which was
designed
by
the government as well as by the bankers
to separate the deposits and loans of
people and companies from
all the securities creation and trading
and speculative type of activities so
that our deposits and loans wouldn't be
the collateral for all of the other
stuff and so therefore when there was an
emergency uh
it couldn't be the collateral for the
requirement of extra help in that
emergency that hasn't been done that
wasn't a part of dodd-frank actually the
glass-steagall act of bringing it back
in a modern form was on the platforms of
both the democrats and the republicans
in the 2016 election
but it has not been um pushed and
republicans sort of like dial back from
it and a lot of the democrats also
dialed back there there is an act called
um what uh
um a bill called hr 790 in congress
that's been going around that has about
70 or 80 signatures on it across the
aisle that asks to reinstate the
glass-steagall act there's also a
similar um act going on in a bill in the
senate um that's that's championed to do
the same thing on a bipartisan basis but
it hasn't been done yet so that that's
kind of
what's happened from from those two
things
thank you so much for your excellent
presentation um i just want to
go back real quick to your um
some of the things that you highlighted
in your book about the 1.1 trillion
dollars that we have with china any
thoughts on trade
is there any validity or is it hype that
they might you know be willing to call
in our debt where are we in that so so
the reality of money over politics
um
money i.e the money in in the pocket of
a person or a country
is that
when you
have something that's valued at a
certain level if you sell it
you will lose money even if you want to
do that politically so from the
standpoint of china
um
if they
decided for some political reason to
sell all their treasury bonds or a large
portion of the treasury bonds they would
be shooting themselves in the foot
economically
and that's why they aren't doing it and
that's why they they won't do it they
might buy less in the future and that's
actually i think more of an economic
decision i mean if you if you think that
a country inherently might uh see
another crisis from the financial system
it hasn't rectified or whatever in the
future or you just want to simply be
hedged or or protect yourself from the
risk of that um you might buy less
treasuries um going forward as a
percentage of what we have outstanding
of the amount of debt that that we have
outstanding but you're not going to like
dump your treasuries um i think russia
said something about dumping their
treasuries um just recently um
but you know she doesn't actually own a
lot of treasuries um and and so the
impact to them
um and to the world just just from a
sheer
price level um would on treasury bonds
would would be very limited and the
bigger countries that own them aren't
going to do it for for their own
sake
hi very interesting um we talk a lot
about china we talk a lot about the
united states
but
what economies in which countries really
concern you
let me throw out one venezuela
and which give you hope um let me throw
out one azerbaijan
um
any thoughts
um that's very good i actually write
this um annual uh
ten points to look at over the year
thing on my on my website in in january
um and and and venezuela was certainly a
point of um
problems uh from a financial perspective
and something to definitely look at as
as was argentina
which which has had its problems some
and continues to have its its problems
as well as as does turkey um in terms of
brighter points i mean you know look
look at something like an iceland i mean
something which uh countries which have
when they had the opportunity to
sort of separate themselves financially
from the bankers that had been operating
in their country or from you know sort
of investing in their country into the
financial crisis decided not to and as a
result at least they're able to govern
their country from the standpoint of
their decisions that make sense for the
country as opposed to having to
potentially pay out
money that they don't have to outside
investors that don't necessarily need it
going back to the negative on argentina
one of the problems argentina had
was that a lot of the debt
that it had borrowed
was also entangled in a lot of the same
sort of hedge fund operators that were
involved in the subprime crisis and they
extracted some very heavy tolls from the
country and so what happens when you
when you're just doing a financial
transaction as a bondholder um and you
want your money back and um you know
either a court or a central bank or a
group of sort of
super entities decide that that's okay
ultimately it hurts uh the real people
in the economies of the countries um and
and the financial
elements and people that were involved
just from an investing standpoint you
know don't you know they just kind of
take the money out and come out
thank you can you hear me
oh okay good yeah can you hear me
clearly yes uh
uh two brief questions
i don't remember the author of the book
his name escapes me but it was very
disturbing to me it was the title was
confessions of an economic hitman that's
john perkins
chuck correct john perkins yeah
and the second thing i'm sure
what you're talking ab
about
has very much related to what's
you know what he his job was for years
and so i come to the conclusion that
two or three hundred years things really
haven't changed yet
who's ever in power within flu a lot of
influence a lot of resources usually
money
win
you know
things haven't really changed except for
a few periods of history where there was
some
sanity um actually i'm it's interesting
to say because in my book all the
presidents bankers i um i looked at the
period of the 50s um as as a period of
of that kind of of sanity i mean
obviously there was there was a lot of
problems um but just from an economic
perspective
um
because
the the finance in in the country and
the financiers of the country the banks
of the country as well as the government
were somewhat on the same page um in
that they were actually trying to
collectively build the country and they
actually kind of wanted to do that
today's banks and banks before that
have have this
lack of need or desire or requirement to
actually do that and when there's
there's too much of it which often there
is in history right there's too much of
a separation between the money and
what needs to happen in order to you
know sort of help a long-term type of
growth or the real economy and it's it's
too distorted then that's when you have
crises and that's when you have economic
and you know revolutionary type of
peoples um and and the periods where
it's somewhat on the same page from
standpoint of people too and ideas too
and governments and and financing then
it tends to be more stable but but yes
there's definite creed does have a way
of
changing history and um certainly the
the more money that's available to the
the fewer
uh hands uh the more destabilizing that
is to to everybody else particularly if
they um aren't concerned or just you
know want to sort of take it and play
their own playground which which is
often the case but um the periods where
that's not the case are the periods
where where things actually i think are
better
well thank you
those are excellent questions i really
thank you guys all for coming out here
thank you to warwicks again for for
hosting and to see spen for coming here
and um
i hope you enjoy collusion
thank you
absolutely okay before we go anywhere
you know my routine that i like to do so
you have those of you that have your
books i want to hold them up and i want
people in the back to wave at me
because i like just a picture of our
crowd
that's nice that's so nice okay there we
go and just give me a nice wave all
right guys perfect all right thank you
so nomi will be signing books over here
so um you can just head over there and
have your book signed and we have books
here for sale too so thank you all for
coming out tonight appreciate it
i'm in the search bar at the top of the
page
and now on book tv we're live with
author and journalist nomie prinz her
books include it takes a pillage all the
president's bankers and most recently
collusion how central bankers rigged the
world
nomi prince in your book all the
president's bankers you describe the
relationship between banks and
governments and presidents as
co-dependent what do you mean
well it what i mean changes over the
decades because i all the president's
bankers covered really from the 1890s
until the obama administration but what
it means is that in times of war there's
a certain relationship where the
government turned to bankers to help
finance it in times of peace the bankers
require of the presidents that they
helped them bank more widely um and with
fewer rules so depending on whether
there was a financial crisis or a global
war-like situation the relationship
changed but the dependency of one group
on the other continued it was either
about money or it was about influence
but it was pretty much prevalent in
different ways through the different
presidencies that we've had since well
throughout our history but the history i
cover specifically uh since teddy
roosevelt's administration through till
today is there a reason you picked that
starting point
yes um
one first of all i didn't it was um only
so much time i had in life basically to
do a couple of centuries versus one but
but really what happened was um
as we know there was a crisis a crash
black tuesday in 1929 that's not when i
start the book but what i realized when
i researched that crash
was that a couple of the bankers that
were most connected to the crash and
most concerned about it including
bankers from the morgan bank which we
now know as jpmorgan chase
if you trace them back trace back to j.p
morgan and j.p morgan was one of the
lead bankers in the country from 1890 so
there was this through line of
individuals families and banks that cast
back to that time but also that was a
time under teddy roosevelt's
administration where there was a lot of
kind of recessions going on so there was
times where the country was doing well
and a couple for a couple years and then
it would sort of recede for a couple
years economically to the point where in
the mid 1890s the government talked
about dependency had to call upon jp
morgan to help them finance
the budget
so so that was what happened that was
kind of the gift that jp morgan gave and
in return he he required influence over
his years after that so that's how it
started and then in 1907 that midpoint
was when there was a huge panic
in new york and it required a lot of
banks to close as ultimately happened in
2008 almost 100 years later and at that
point in time teddy roosevelt's
administration turned to jp morgan again
as they had in the 1890s and he said
what can i do to help you help me
basically
and what happened was the treasury
department fashioned 25 million dollars
it was kind of the first bailout
of banks that the government paid for
and said to jp morgan here's 25 million
dollars figure it out
and what jp morgan did is he gathered in
his library the major bankers at the
time and what he decided to do is parcel
out money to some of them they were all
his friends they had shares with him he
had shares with them they hung out
together their families got together etc
and a lot of the other banks failed at
the time
um but that was a situation where he
then became known because he let his
bank survive and he saved this panic um
as sort of the king of banking the new
york times called him that um as well so
the history goes back through that
period between the 1890s and 1920s
because really around the morgan bank
they were um very influential for for
money and also for what happened
politically and how the treasury
department and the presidency ultimately
uh survived their panic at the time but
nomi prince tr was known for being the
trust buster for not liking big business
or
railing against it at least publicly yes
and he was and he is known as that and
he was a trustbuster
what he busted um was non-banks um so at
the time standard oil which was a major
oil company under the rockefeller family
and other types of companies of that
nature he actually did
bust up some of their
more powerful sort of elements to sort
of try to make some more competitive
environment he did do that he was known
as that and other industries as well but
he stayed away from banks
and if you look at the history of why he
did that i think it snakes back to that
1907 panic he needed
j.p morgan to help him basically not
have a larger panic throughout the
united states throughout the entire
country and to keep money flowing
throughout the entire country by not
having runs on all the banks
and i think that element of saving
was something that he required and that
he therefore as a kind of gentleman's
agreement stayed off of busting up the
larger institutions which as a result is
why we have j.p morgan chase today
really i mean the fact that he did not
bust up some of the banks back then
is one of the reasons why our larger
banks in this country today
have been able to accumulate that size
and that footprint in the way that they
have
so too big to fail is not a new concept
no it isn't um it's definitely not the
difference is that more in a recent pass
too big to fail were banks that became
big over this you know this major period
of the past century
and then required help from the
government and the government
provided that help as did the federal
reserve at the time back then
they were either helping themselves
getting some money from the government
to help themselves but it but it was a
bit more sort of limited
before we leave this period there's a
character in your book
that we probably haven't heard of today
james stillman but he seemed to have
this
very influential role
yeah so james stillman was actually one
of the leaders of what was called
national citibank
which now we know is citigroup um so
going back in time he was one of the
major director of that bank and his
family was a very um sort of upscale
blueblood family in in new york city um
in culture and so forth um but he was
also one of the bankers that after this
period of time and he was friends with
the morgans and so forth he was one of
the main people that decided it would be
necessary for there to be some sort of a
central bank in the united states like
what we have now the federal reserve
that would be able to save banks
in a situation where the government
couldn't step in and help those banks so
when there was an unstable period like
the panic rather than just jp morgan for
example
counting on the treasury department
which he had furnished money to in
decades before that
there would be some other central entity
that would do that so stillman was one
of the people that sort of behind the
scenes um started to work with congress
to basically create what became
the federal reserve bank but but his
name isn't really noted for that in in
history so jekyll island 1913 was that a
noble effort
um so so jekyll island um started in
1910 and it was basically um jekyll
island anyway it was like the country
club for all the sort of rich people in
in the united states at the time um they
effectively i i spent a lot of time
doing research down there now it's a
it's a resort hotel in in um
off the coast of georgia but at the time
all of these major families the morgans
the hydes the rockefellers would have
sort of condos there but they weren't
like city condos they were just really
nice and they had lots of servants come
down with them and so forth and they
could only access jekyll island through
the
through the waterways and the rest of
the people had to stay away from it
during the times they were there they
would go down around thanksgiving to
christmas and hang out a particular
thanksgiving around 1910 um
a very small number of them went before
the families came in for the holidays
to ink what became
the documents that ultimately turned
into the federal reserve act of 1913
which created the federal reserve but at
the time it was all very clandestine and
almost didn't happen i i talk about it
in all the president's bankers that's
one of my favorite stories because um
nelson aldrich who was the senator he
was the head of the finance committee
actually um at the time republican rhode
island
that's right rhode island that's right
um and you know he had a bit of sort of
wealth and sort of prestige and stuff
himself and he was on he was on the
finance committee as a banking committee
it was called at the time
and he had a son winthrop eldritch who
was living in new york as a banker um
and he was going to visit him and kind
of talk to jp morgan and others about
you know a central bank and decide where
they could actually have this meeting he
was going to meet in new york
um and then what happened was he got hit
by a trolley car
and so he got laid up he had to
convalesce and during that period rather
than have people know what was going on
it was decided by j.p morgan that
basically aldrich and a bunch of other
people go to jekyll island use his
membership because it was after all a
club um and and convene there and decide
what to do which is ultimately what
happened so all the stories about it
being all secret and whatever they
really happened because nelson aldrich
was in the wrong place at the wrong time
relative to a trolley car so they meet
at jekyll island um they they pen this
these ideas for the central bank based
on their travels based on what was
required based on what they thought
would go through with the american
public if it were voted
and ultimately it was a bunch of bankers
including james stillman who took those
documents back to congress
and and basically brought them into the
senate into wider committee and
ultimately was not passed in 1910 um
under what was in a republican
presidency it passed under woodrow
wilson um the democrat who came in um
after that presidency to take over um
and it was it was basically sold as this
idea that there'd be a federal reserve
that would be a central bank that would
be a bank to the banks to help them when
they needed it but also provide credit
for the country so the idea was if there
was ever to be a panic again like the
farmers in the middle of the country
wouldn't find that their banks couldn't
get money from new york and wouldn't be
able to provide them you know through
that season or through that hardship um
and that was kind of how it was sold as
a sort of people's bank but in reality
it was created together
with nelson aldrich and some senators
and
bankers to provide them an out if there
were to be an emergency
based on the european model
to an extent based on the european model
um with with with a sort of more um
because our country is bigger than say
the bank of england model or the the
bank of france at the time which is now
part of the european central bank um the
idea was we'd have 12 different sort of
entities which were part of the federal
reserve system and that goes back to the
farmers and that goes back to the idea
that if we have 12 separate entities of
which in washington um right here we
have the main one the federal reserve
and we have a new york fed we have a fed
in san francisco and so forth they would
be able to sort of cover the local banks
in that area in terms of making sure
they had credit when they needed it
regulating them when they had to and
making sure that other banks that used
the big banks
to help workers and farmers and other
businesses throughout the country
would have access to credit and access
to money so our system has more banks in
it to spread out through the country
politically and also just because
geographically we're bigger and we have
different
cities that have more banks in them for
more purposes locally and now they're
more national but but at the time that
was the idea were there protests against
it in 1913 today there's still an
undercurrent of
protest against the fed
um
there there were more protests in 1911
and 1912. there are basically more
protests under taft and um the president
before wilson than there were um during
him with him it was much more um yes
there were op-eds and yes there were
concerns that a bank could be too
controlled
by wall street banks but what he did
is decide to use wording and he was even
worried about having a federal reserve
and even was after after the fact but
but he decided to use wording and to
work with politicians throughout the
country particularly in the middle of
the country in those regions to
provide the narrative to the rest of the
country that this money would be good
for everyone you know the idea here was
not to just focus on the big wall street
banks so the big powerful families that
basically ran those banks at the time
but the idea was um it would be a way to
sort of smooth out money for the country
so in that respect um he kind of got
around um any sort of protests which
were limited by the time he was in
office and also got around any sort of
criticisms because he got buy-in
from a number of senators and
representatives throughout the country
that ultimately the system
um by being a system of 12 banks would
work for everybody now no mean prince
will return to the central banks when we
get into
collusion your most recent book but i
want to read two things first of all
from all the president's bankers
quote the political and financial
alliances between bankers and presidents
and their cabinets continue to define
the policies and laws that drive the
economy
and then from one of your previous books
other people's money you write
that the amount of clout the financial
sectors wheeled in washington
can't be underestimated
that's that's true
um those are both true statements other
people's money i i wrote in the wake of
the enron scandal and and the worldcom
scandal which were effectively in the
energy and the telecommunications
sectors after um deregulation in those
sectors but but they
happened really because
those institutions and ron worldcom were
working with the major banks of the
country on all sorts of derivative
structures hiding money off of their
books and so forth so this scandal
situation happened a recession happened
um everybody knew about it but the banks
kind of got off um relatively free from
that none of you know their ceos went to
jail then this was about 2001 2002 um
during when i wrote after which i wrote
other people's money um but their
influence was very high in washington
because what they were basically saying
was look you know this is this is on
enron you know this is on worldcom this
this is on you know they did things
wrong yeah we might have you know did
some paperwork help them with their
banking here and there but the reality
is those kinds of institutions um enron
could have couldn't have become the
major derivatives trader that it became
instead of the energy company it said it
was and worldcom couldn't have become
such a massive organization with so much
stuff hidden um offshore and and from
their books from the public
if banks hadn't helped
create the facilities create the credit
lines merge companies together and
basically do all of that so with respect
to the influence in washington um all of
that comes to bear so all of the bankers
at the time and throughout our history
have been able either through money or
through just having the ear
of presidents being on committees being
major advisors that they've been able to
say look it wasn't us you need us it was
them and sort of i'm summarizing but
work it into that
so in terms of all the president's
bankers it's it's really the same thing
except all the president's bankers i
wrote um
10 years after i wrote
other people's money but but but in that
book i go through specifically
the kinds of relationships and influence
that bankers had in washington and today
we we think mostly of the donations um
and the lobbying which which is immense
compared to other sectors although right
now the tech sense the tech sector is
kind of giving banks a run for their
money but but historically
the influence of sitting down with you
know president obama or president trump
or whomever from a major banker like jp
morgan chase's chairman and ceo jamie
dimon really does have a lot of clout
and also the media it has cloud on the
other side so they can influence
washington through influencing business
media and the narrative of what banks do
and why they're needed
even if they do criminal things um and
why they need to be maintained in their
in their current form
now nomi prinz you come from that side
of the equation as well don't you yeah
so when enron was happening i was at
that time i was i was a managing
director of goldman sachs and i i was
working i i had a team that created
what we're called credit derivatives
which were effectively bets on whether
companies
or any sorts of loans whether they were
attached to mortgages or anything else
would default um basically that's what
a credit derivative is it's like i bet
you that you'll be able to either pay
off your loan or not be able to pay off
your loan or if your company you either
are able to pay off the debt that you
borrowed in the public markets or from
banks or you're not and then i kind of
bet on that and i offset that bet with
someone else who's willing to take the
other side or with insurance companies
that ensure
this bet or this insurance i'm taking
out on the other side to to make this
bet but but they were much more
convoluted than that
ultimately as as we found out in the
subprime mortgage crisis um and the
aftermath in the financial crisis but
but i created um at goldman and at bear
stearns as well where i ran um an
analytics department for seven years
during
a little more than seven years during
the 90s um through for bear stearns the
creations that could enable these types
of credit derivatives to be used for
investors for companies in large
quantities mixed and matched together so
all the analytics for that um i was very
much involved in throughout my career on
wall street
and when i left and actually wrote this
in other people's money i think towards
the end of that book i i said
that and i wrote that credit derivatives
and cdos which to get real technical on
a sunday uh
and then i'll go on uh credit uh
collateralized debt obligations
collateralize just mean i put a bunch of
stuff together and i bet against that
also just in layman's terms um
they were something that i said we
should watch because they'll be at the
crux of the next financial crisis
um that's partly because i i saw where
they were going i saw the sort of junk
that was being put inside of them and
that still is
um and that then they were very small
they're a very small part of the market
and they were very much
in fashion because they could make so
much money for banks like goldman sachs
or banks like bear stearns um and then
ultimately they became the crux of a
financial implosion years later
were you good at your job
yes i was good at my job and that i was
um i was a quantitative analyst
throughout my career on wall street i
started as a programmer
at the chase manhattan bank in the 80s
from having gotten a degree in math um
and that's basically trying to get a job
and work in new york city and uh those
those sorts of banks were hiring and so
from the beginning of
of um of derivatives of looking at
aggregating different types of financial
securities looking at the math looking
at the programming
i did that stuff from the sort of
very initial level
in in the 80s to when i ultimately left
in 2002. but what i also did and one of
the reasons i left
wall street was it was very important
when i was creating analytics or
directing my team
as i was building them in the different
places i worked to
um to analyze the downside to make sure
that if a salesperson was selling a
product for which we were doing
analytics
they were also explaining
what the risks were in that product
and what began happening was
as
things got more voracious and more
competitive and there was more money in
these more esoteric products this idea
of talking to clients about risk or or
funding
risk analytics within the company yeah
just like the budget in washington you
know this money goes for this this money
goes for that um that happens in in in
banks as well um it wasn't kind of
considered a priority it was sort of
down considered and i had more and more
of a problem
just morally on that um because it just
didn't yeah it's one thing to to create
something and there's risk attached to
it and
and if someone understands the risk to
be involved but if the risk is either a
ultimately on the public but but b
can't be explained
properly
then that's a bigger problem and that's
where i started to
divide out from wall street and
ultimately become a journalist and an
author oh and you write about 9 11 and
the impact that had on you
yeah so that was really the breaking
point um i think for a lot of us in new
york i mean i was working at goldman
sachs at the time um very close to where
the towers um had been and in fact that
morning
um
i had a corner office actually on on a
high floor at goldman sachs um
and
the actual planes
went
by my office now when the first plane
went nobody
nobody really noticed that nobody on the
news noticed that i mean it just sort of
happened but we were sort of in the
flight path
but then once all the sort of tickers
and debris and smoke started
accumulating very quickly um upwards um
and it started to be covered on the news
and the second plane came by that that
plane we noticed that plane came came
very close now at the time that moment
of impact obviously none of us knew
it was
a terrorist attack but but what we did
what did happen was everything got very
chaotic very quickly
internally we were actually supposed to
go to an off site to talk about credit
derivatives and all our teams have flown
in from around the world the night
before and we're supposed to go off
somewhere and sort of like you know do a
jekyll island but basically the kind of
thing that happens all the time in
banking and just be somewhere else
obviously we couldn't and my clarity
moment was when one of the people from
uh sort of a major person in the
department said you know well maybe if
we leave now we can beat the traffic out
of manhattan it was like dude there's
there's like no there's something really
big happening here like
it's not about you know that right now
um but then ultimately over those next
few days i spent a lot of time just
thinking about where i was at where my
head was at where life was i wound up um
volunteering to help with the armory
instead of going into work
at goldman a few days afterwards to try
and match items with with people as they
were coming in and just sort of help
volunteer to do that whereas we were
supposed to be at work and so there was
all these moments of of just um
priorities um in terms of what's
happening in the industry in life life
in general um and so yes that was a very
big pivot point for me and i wound up
resigning
um
a few months after that
from it takes a pillage nomi prinz
writes
unless you've been embraced into the
bosom of goldman sachs even for a brief
spate of time
it's hard to fully grasp its culture of
excellence
it's like harvard the new york times the
senate and the new york yankees all
rolled into one
once you drink the kool-aid and manage
not to spit it out you really begin to
think you're better than everyone else
i wrote that yeah um
the
so first of all when i was interviewed
um for goldman as as people were um it's
a it's a very long process um i was
working in bear stearns in london at the
time
i was sought out by goldman
to come to new york and and do credit
related products with them and through
this nine-month interviewing process
there was partners that i met when they
were in london you know i was out in new
york i mean it's all it's it's a
rigorous
um you know getting through of a sort of
totem pole up through um you know the
very senior levels of the company and so
all along the way
um there's this idea not that we didn't
know goldman sachs had this aura um in
in in the industry of being um you know
sort of the mana of wall street or the
mana of like banking because of how it
just
presented itself you know and so the
idea of the interview process kind of
manifested that like if you get through
this
um hurdle and you get through this
hurdle you get through this hurdle it's
almost like this makes you you know if
we like you more this this makes you
better and it's kind of like a weird
cultural
um indoctrination just just from the
beginning um and once you get through
that um i remember i was standing on one
of the trading floors for one of the
sort of later interviews and i was um
being interviewed by lord blankfein who
became the ceo of goldman sachs and he
sort of walks me out after we were
chatting to the the trading floor and he
kind of does one of these
and he says
this is not bear stearns
in other words like we are just so much
better than bear stearns which is where
i was at um you know this is goldman
sachs and it was it was that kind of
um
aura and that moment of you know
presentation of who we are um and the
idea of that culture of excellence um
and and that's what there's a there's a
book about um as well that was written
um not too long after i was there about
goldman's culture of excellence is
something that's discussed internally um
they they consider it that's the word
they use it's it's considered a culture
of excellence and if you are
um like
them um sort of moving up the the sort
of um ladder then you are called a
culture carrier
it's just a thing
um at least when i was there and so this
idea of of being one of us
um and then doing your job but then your
job is about being one of us is is is
very sort of self um enforcing um and
and that's what i mean by that that
there's there's a very strong um sense
of we are really great if you're here
you're really great but only if you
behave like us and if you don't maybe
you don't belong here
what do they do
[Laughter]
um well will they like um
any of the sort of more marquee
investment banks do a few major things
they
put banks together they put companies
together they're they're they're
investment banking
advisors so they they they find
acquirers of companies and they they
basically find companies that want to be
acquired and they work out the details
and and for working out the details a
couple of things fall out uh one thing
that falls out
is
a lot of fees
another thing that falls out of that
deal are
the ability to potentially issue bonds
on behalf of that new company or on
behalf of one of the companies involved
so that they can raise money to either
go on with the next part of their
business or to
buy each other
they can issue shares they can issue new
shares of stock to to do that
and then ultimately once companies are
already merged together or they already
exist without having been merged they're
just corporate clients
they can work on issuing stocks they can
trade those stocks they can work on
issuing bonds they can trade those bonds
and they can effectively create
sort of financial
powers for their clients that they take
cuts of all along the way either through
the initial creation of bonds or stocks
or a deal or through trading it
in something called the secondary market
along the way so they can kind of be on
both sides
of the initial entry of something new to
trading something that's already in
existence
in your newest book collusion
you write
that much of the 20th century belonged
to wall street
the 21st century now belongs to the
central banks
right so along the way
of the 20th century you know as we
talked about the the influence through
through wars through crises through
economic policy through trade agreements
through all sorts of other things was
very much a sort of symbiotic
conversation or relationship that
occurred between
administrations presidencies and the
major banks
of the country so your jp morgan chase
citigroup bank of america goldman sachs
morgan stanley and so forth um as we
went into this
century not so much the beginning of it
but sort of the last decade and moving
forward central banks stepped in to act
as the financers
for everything that banks were doing so
when the crisis happened
in 2008
the fed did this major pivot the federal
reserve the main central bank of the us
did a major pivot and said
well
banks don't trust each other right now
they just created a crisis number one
but number two they don't trust each
other even let alone feel compelled to
give money to like the small businesses
or to individuals at
at the rates we're ultimately going to
give them which is zero um but but into
the crisis we we will come in and help
them and we will create or fabricate
money electronically in order to provide
them with credit
because we can
but
what happened was they didn't just do it
a little bit
they took a situation the federal
reserve in conjunction with the treasury
department and major bankers at the time
and they took something that was
considered to be an emergency i what was
going on in the fall of 2008
when there was
you know basically a complete crisis of
confidence in the banking system inside
it and externally related to it and they
said we're just going to dump tons and
tons of money into the system to make it
right we're going to do it as an
emergency basis first we're going to
give banks loans we're going to give
them low rates so they can basically get
money from us at nothing
and we're going to buy ultimately bonds
from them
that no one else wants in order to give
them more cash something called
quantitative easing
in order for them to continue to operate
so this this entire shift
from the banks having a lot of this
major influence financially relative to
washington to say the fed having it was
because the fed had the money like all
of a sudden it wasn't just the banks
that had the money and had the ability
to raise money
in private markets historically or in
public markets and plus so much of
people's deposits on which they could do
more uh financial activities with
all of a sudden there's this extra
body
it had been there all the time it had
been created ultimately over you know
100 years or so before that to provide
banks help when they needed it but it
went into overdrive and it wasn't just
the federal reserve as i talked about in
collusion it was the federal reserve it
was the european central bank the bank
of japan
sort of on to that ultimately people's
bank of china all the major banks in
different ways throughout the world
decided to find ways to electronically
fabricate money to put into their
systems
and then they're still going
so so this thing that was an emergency
and considered to be an emergency back
in 2008 has become policy
and it's become monetary policy and even
though people don't really think of it
this way it's our economic policy it's
there's this this
this body that can create
funds when necessary and that has no
legal cap
to how much they can create there's a
cap in terms of how much conversation
they might have about how much they've
created or what public opinion might be
or what political opinion might be but
there's no legal cap
to what
any of these central banks can create
electronically
in the guise of helping the financial
system or in the guise of helping the
general economy and that's why they have
so much more power now than than they
have before because they now know this
um and and in different ways over the
last years decade plus since the
financial crisis
that is really how they operate so
whoever's heading the federal reserve
whoever's heading the european central
bank the institutions themselves are now
sort of superseding even their ability
and and what they may want to do by the
virtual power of being to create able to
create so much money
when they want to
here's the warning from collusion
the fed and its allies have created a
shaky monetary system that will collapse
without their manipulation
central bankers for all their meetings
and posh locales the world over
have no plan b to reverse or alter
course without causing massive damage
and financial pain
to billions of people
yes
um so
what's happened and actually we can even
see this with with since since i wrote
the book but but recently um our federal
reserve had an about face in its policy
right so
just just going back really quickly to
what central banks do um
are one of the things they do is they
they
create a level for
interest rates and by virtue of that
level of interest rates that's what
banks basically receive
um that's that's the interest that banks
have to pay in order to receive that
money so when the fed put rates down at
zero percent in the end of 2008 and kept
them there through december 2015 they
were basically saying sort of one of our
tools
is to be able to make sure that the cost
of money over a three-month period is is
negligible to to banks
from 2015 to the end of 2018
incrementally they raised the cost of
that money they raised interest rates
once
uh by just 25 basis points a quarter of
one percent in 2015 and then they waited
a whole year because the markets didn't
like that 2016 was all about turbulence
in the beginning after the fed just
raised their rates after seven years of
being at zero by a quarter one percent
by like nothing by the smallest amount
of margin it could possibly raise rates
by um
and so then they stopped for a year and
they didn't raise rates again until the
end of
2016 in december 2016 by another 25
basis points and then they did some more
in 2017 and more in 2018 but always with
an eye to seeing whether the financial
system the markets themselves
would be okay with that and what is them
being okay with that that means not
having like massive sort of cratery down
turns in the market
um
this year
on january 3rd after there was a fourth
rate hike last year
which was in december 2018
the markets opened really upset
and banks were really upset and as it
turns out there were meetings with
senior bankers and the fed at the end of
december as well sort of going into what
became an about-face the about-face was
the u.s fed saying you know what
we're just going to hold back so first
it was just some language different
central bank leaders from the different
parts of the 12 bank central reserve
system sort of started popping up saying
well maybe the economy is too slow
maybe we shouldn't you know tighten too
much things started being said um and
then a couple weeks ago the main policy
came out that like you know we're not
raising rates at all this year at all
and maybe not even until 2020.
and the reason for that is considered to
be because the economy is slowing
and if you raise rates or increase the
cost of money too much you choke off the
ability of that economy to get its funds
the reality is that many times during
this 10-year period the economy is doing
a lot worse than it's been doing
recently and they've still kept rates
low the difference now
is that the markets have gotten upset
again
and so january 3rd was a negative day
since then we've seen a massive rally
in the stock market because of the fed's
about face
because it wasn't just the fed that
about faced it was all the central banks
around the world who were worried that
if the fed didn't about face
they would have to tighten money they
would have to make money more expensive
they would have to stop buying assets in
their markets to keep the level of
finance
up and the cost of money down
and then they were like okay we're gonna
we're gonna just free the sigh of relief
now because the fed's not going to do it
we definitely don't have to worry about
it and that's why some of their markets
have rallied as well
so there is this dislocation between
economies and markets if the fed were
truly and other central banks were truly
you know getting back to what i what i
said we're truly to say all right well
we're going to normalize rates we're
going to reduce the size
of our books or the amount of money we
put into the market and we're going to
basically sell the assets we bought for
that money and take the money back
there would be
absolute
financial crisis throughout the entire
banking systems of all these major
countries and the stock market and and
that's not like
some you know crazy statement that
doesn't come from the actual data that
that's just looking upon what happens
when money gets too tight too quickly
and the immediate reaction
of the stock market which is a place
where money moves very quickly in and
out so the reactions there are very
indicative of the reactions that are
happening throughout corporations and
banks throughout the world as well
so if you don't understand exactly what
nomi prinz is talking about and need a
refresher the nice thing about your
books is you put in glossaries and casts
of characters as you call them yes
which is very important good afternoon
this is book tv's monthly in-depth
program our guest this month is author
and financial journalist nomie prinz her
first book came out in 2004 after she
left goldman sachs and it's called other
people's money the corporate mugging of
america her next book came out no six
jacked how conservatives in quotes are
picking your pocket whether you voted
for them or not
the trial came out in 2008 but it was
written by somebody named natalia
prentiss who is that yeah that was my
alter ego actually that book it was um
the trail it was a thriller it was a
financial thriller because what i
decided to do when i left goldman
initially
was to
what kind of do a john grisham with
respect
but basically write about my industry
from the standpoint of something that
was palatable
and so actually that book
i wrote as i was leaving goldman and it
came out later and i so i took another
name because i just kind of done that to
begin with just in case it was too close
to home and one of the things about that
book now that you have mentioned it and
just recalling i talk about a character
um who was the head of a company that
was kind of equivalent to goldman i
think i called it silverman very very
very loosely loosely veiled and um
how that character ultimately became the
vice president of the united states and
and in fact it was kind of based on hank
paulson who became the treasury
secretary of the united states um later
but it wasn't it wasn't far off from
that so i i i basically was using that
name for for that purpose
it takes a pillage 2009 an epic tale of
power deceit
and untold trillions black tuesday
another novel came out in 2011 her two
most recent books all the president's
bankers the hidden alliances that drive
american power 2014 and her most recent
is collusion how central bankers rigged
the world this is your chance to talk
with nomi prinz here are the numbers 202
748 8200 if you live in the east or
central time zones 202
748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and western time zones if you
cannot get through on the phone lines
and still want to make a comment we're
going to cycle through our social media
sites as well twitter facebook and email
all available to you we monitor those as
well
so nomi prinz
what
now that we have this 100 year history
100 plus year history that you've
written about
what what has there been a cost to the
taxpayer
there has been a cost the taxpayer payer
also also the voter
um because
when you talk about you know a major
banker who can influence policy and
ultimately um for example in in the case
of of jpmorgan chase um jamie dimon was
someone who was on
uh the new york fed board he was a class
a director at the new york fed board of
goldman sachs today um no he was
actually had a jp morgan chase so jamie
dimon so he happened to have been in the
in the height of the financial crisis
when it first occurred also a director
at the new york fed which is the wall
street located fed of this 12-member
reserve system but he was one of the
people along with hank paulson who at
that time was treasury secretary but who
had been when i came into goldman the
ceo and chairman of goldman sachs
tim geithner who had a lot of
relationships ultimately came in but he
was a new york fed president at the time
and then became the treasury secretary
under obama at the turn of the year
after that crisis so you have all these
individuals
who effectively have the ability to
direct
policy and money coming out of
washington
to their own institutions which are
public institutions these are banks that
trade on you know stock exchanges
they're monitored supposedly by the
federal reserve because one of their day
jobs is to be the regulatory um sort of
answer the oversight body to these banks
um
they're they're monitored and yet their
individuals have such a tight
relationship with
the central political powers of the
country that they are able to get money
effectively to themselves when they need
it and far greater figures than
individuals
are able to galvanize to do that as a
result money goes from
taxpayers to
benefit them and not just when there's a
crisis
but even from the standpoint of for
example
a legal act called the glass-steagall
act which was repealed in 1999 it had
been in place since 1933 specifically to
protect the depositors and the taxpaying
public and voters from any kind of weird
esoteric products or speculation that
banks could do banks could choose to bet
on all sorts of stuff but if they lost
those bets it was on them it was on
their shareholders it was on their
private partners however they were
structured to repay it it wasn't on the
government it wasn't on people
that was repealed in 1999 so all of a
sudden you had this merging of people's
deposits people's cash people's
mortgages into institutions that also
could do all sorts of stuff with that
do badly with it bet wrong and then come
to the government for help the fact that
they had all these deposits
that they could say well we have them
you know atm machines aren't going to
work people aren't going to get their
money back in this crisis unless you
give us all these other things
meant a different way of taking money
from depositors or taxpayers because
they influenced the policy that allowed
them to have all those deposits
so on multiple levels they're they're
they're extracting um by their influence
and when things go wrong and
to remove rules surrounding their their
businesses
from taxpayers into their own pockets
so jim walsh
tweets in to you
could you explain how someone so
brilliant and economically astute
you
supports an economic system that always
fails at tremendous human and economic
cost or devol dissolves into a
dictatorship
she supports progressivism socialism is
that true are you a socialist
um i support certain socialist policies
um because
um
if we think about how
economics
divides
into the needs of society in other words
how money that comes from
society
helps society and how governments are
used to appropriate those funds i think
about things like like how expensive
health care is for for people in this
country
i think about how expensive it is for a
student to go to university
and to come out with 50 60 70 000 worth
of debt which means they can't
ultimately be the kind of participant in
our economy that they could have been
without so much debt when i went to
school
i went i started out in in public
schools and i went to a community
college and then i ultimately went to a
state college and and then i went to
private to nyu for all my education but
i paid for um all of it along the way
and i could pay for all of it along the
way because what i was earning by
working
was enough to allow me to afford courses
and books and and rents on tiny places
at the time um and and now that that's
an impossibility so when i look at the
economy as a whole
and think okay do we think it's better
for an economy to to be more level for
people for more people in order for them
to contribute
foundationally throughout most parts of
the economy in in an easier way
and i think about how we also have
firefighters and now we have post
offices and how we have police officers
and a whole host of elements of our
society that are meant to help
more of society than just their
shareholders or just their banking
institutions so i look at it from the
standpoint of
a healthy society that's healthy
economically
and educationally and and physically and
and they're protected
defense is another um sort of level of
our society which has a lot of money
that goes into it and supposedly to
protect everyone protect the country
all of those things to me are social
good
and
what i support from the economic
standpoint and financially is for actors
within that not to risk
the country's financial health
and be bailed out to the extent that
they were by
the country by taxpayers or help to the
extent that they've been by the federal
reserve so the yeah i look at an economy
as as being holistic in in that respect
so
in today's current political environment
is capitalism
at a tipping point
i think in general we're a capitalist
nation i mean we
we do strive as as a nation to
do um business activities that that
create profits and and those profits go
in different ways um either to the
people involved in creating them or to
society or to tax or to people's futures
i don't think that's going away but i i
do think
that
using wall street as an example and
using the financial crisis as an example
and using the fact that
our federal reserve still has four
trillion dollars of assets on our books
after what isn't an emergency situation
we should think anymore since it
happened in 2008 and it's still
subsidizing wall street and subsidizing
larger banks those are tremendous sums
of money
and so i think that a
healthy capital capitalism has to
recognize that putting too much money in
one place where that one place has
actually been a cost to the general
financial system or to general um the
general economy is is not necessarily a
good decision
um and so i think it needs to be more
regulated i think we have rules in place
that that do that that were ignored
into the the collapse that we're still
sort of reeling from in terms of these
policies um and i think that those need
to be reinvigorated and i think we need
to protect everyone
now before we go to calls finally
the fed is in your view a fed type
bank necessary
is question number one and then i'll
follow up with question number two
um
i think what the fed does
in terms of providing so much subsidy to
so many banks is not necessary
i think the fact that the fed can sort
of raise or lower interest rates in
terms of a monetary policy element is
something that could equally be done
within a treasury department i think
that
the fact that the fed is structured in a
way
that allows
the private members of that bank which
is which is how it's structured the fed
ultimately
does provide credit and does take
meetings with the heads of wall street
firms and stuff because they are the
primary shareholders in the fed and
they're the historic shareholders in the
fed they created the fed so wherever the
fed is today um
there's a major flaw
in how it was created and how it exists
which is that it exists ultimately um to
benefit its members and it says it
exists to member uh to help greater the
greater economy and and sort of the
greater public but the reality is if you
look at the actions um they're very
visceral when it hap when there's a
situation where a wall street large
institution is in trouble
or there's a necessity to help a goldman
or to help a jp morgan chase or to help
someone who has an institution that is
part of the history and the fabric of
how the fed fed was created has
benefited from how the fed is created
and continues to benefit from this sort
of implicit subsidy that not just the
fed but all of the central banks provide
to the largest banks in their respective
countries
and i think that's a flaw
are the u.s and the china central banks
in your view colluding
okay so this is a very interesting
question because
the major collusion i talked about in
the book had to do with predominantly
the g7 countries and what was
interesting after the financial crisis
was that um the methods that they were
using the timing of quantitative easing
of reducing their rates of putting money
um to swap between them to help make
sure that currencies were moving back
and forth between the central banks and
ultimately to the banks of the major
banks in their respective countries
because they work with each other across
borders all of that
happened with phone calls with documents
with things i have in the book between
the sort of major countries where china
comes in where the people's bank of
china comes in is that they actually
were quite critical of this process from
the beginning and it's kind of
fascinating because one of the major
ways i believe that china became such a
tremendous economic superpower
in the decades since the financial
crisis is that initially they were very
public about being critical of the fed's
policy that if you create too much money
too quickly if you subsidize a system
ultimately that system can't sustain
itself however in recent years the
people's bank of china has also been
creating their own sort of quantitative
easing um the difference between what
happens in china and what happens with
the fed so they're not so much colluding
but they're acting in sort of opposition
to in in a world where
if money's cheap in one place and we
have sort of an international capital
globalized system it's going to be cheap
somewhere else people's bank of china
has come in with their own methods but
what they do is they inject them sort of
directly into um
sort of more growth strategies
throughout their country so they'll
actually direct some of the money that
they create into say infrastructure
building um into companies that create
higher speed railroads or companies that
finance them and so forth which we don't
so they have a different just twist
um so it's not so much collusion it's
more sort of the the antithesis but the
result is still creating money um it's
just directed in different ways in the
us and in china right now
nomi prince is our guest and cece is in
portland oregon
go ahead cece
hi um i have a comment and a question
um
you know and if the comment is within
the context of the person
who makes fifty thousand dollars a year
and has a
401k
this whole uh what you've been
describing to me
um sounds like um
that there's no free hand you know as
adam smith theory and the free hand
laissez faire that this is really
gambling that the stock market in wall
street
is the bookmaker like in vegas
and
they're playing around with our money um
gambling
i just see it as gambling i mean i know
it there's no you know way for us it
seems to make money or to advance um as
just a fifty thousand dollar a year for
1k person you know without having it in
there but essentially the the
rules are
you know regular working public 50 000 a
year put all your money in the stock
market and then the people that who are
managing the stock market the wealthy
people
they don't leave their money in the
stock market they move it in and out
constantly with all these reports and
they tell the the person with the 401k
making 50 000 a year just leave it in
there because that's the money in my
mind that they're playing around with
all right cece we're going to get a
response to that are you invested in
these markets
via a retirement account or any other
method
i i am and so what i want to know is
tell me why this isn't gambling
you know and
and how it is
um that the person making fifty thousand
dollars a year
is is post is supposed to trust the
system and uh finally um
is there such thing as the freehand of
the market anymore is that a myth thank
you ma'am
very good question yeah those are
excellent questions cc i mean because
well for a number of reasons one i i
think your question really
gets to the core of so many millions of
people in this country
because the reality is only about
10
of the country owns 90
of the stocks in the u.s stock market so
even
someone like you who has an investment
through your 401k plan in the stock
market the reality is that it is the
people that that are wealthier that have
accumulated more stock that also
ultimately um get the the benefits of
the stock market going up in in
significantly more ways when they're in
it than than you would see um the reason
um it is gambling um is because
um and it's it's rigged gambling in a
way because these institutions you know
whether they're um hedge funds or
whether they're brokers that um and you
should check this on your 401k plan
everyone should um who make a money make
money for for moving um what's in your
401k around so some 401k plans are
actively managed it means that brokers
are moving them around they get fees for
for trading and not necessarily for
performance and that comes out of your
retirement that comes out of the lump
sum that's left at the end of the day
that that's something to take a look at
but but those institutions that do that
and those institutions that manage money
and the fact that there is this
relationship between
wall street institutions that get this
access to to cheaper rates and get
access to federal reserve policy and
influence the policy means they're also
kind of influencing the stock market so
from their perspective if they're
betting on the stock market and i am
using the term betting as you view the
term gambling um they they also have a
sense for whether
it's going to
go up or down more so than you might for
a number of reasons one is they have the
volume
so they can see how much volume is going
in or out they also have the ability
when things go down too much to go to
the you know the federal reserve and and
say look you know there are some
problems going on here or or look at our
books or you know we could have credit
issues going forward and sort of ease
money a little bit and then that money
goes back into the stock market the
reason the stock market rises so quickly
in that manner is because it's easy to
accumulate money into and it's easy for
money to come out with it which also
makes it a very good haven for betting
that's not to say there aren't companies
in there that have real value
and that aren't producing things for the
country and aren't hiring people in the
country and are providing input into the
economy um and and and and buying shares
in those stocks isn't necessarily um a
gamble that's actually investing in in
the growth of that company but where the
gambling comes in is how they're all
um ultimately that their stocks are are
related to money that's coming in from
an outside source so getting to the adam
smith idea you know sort of a free hand
the reality is right now and
particularly in the last year since the
financial crisis this sort of external
artificial injection of money into the
financial system that then gets borrowed
against and leveraged into moving stocks
up moving real estate up for those that
have that money at the top that receive
the bulk of that wealth back and then
re-position it into the market and move
it up even further that
connotes sort of a lack of transparency
and a lack of sort of a full
sort of free market element and what it
does is it shows that there's this
artificial
stimulus to the market
which which has continued to drive it if
you look at the relationship between
bouts of quantitative easing of the fed
or other central banks buying um assets
in their countries you'll see that those
are days in which their stock markets
tend to go up why there's just more
money coming in artificially into the
system and it lifts it up
scott's in new york city you're on with
author nomie prince scott
hi naomi i wanted to
talk to you about an idea i have been a
set of ideas i've been developing
recently
and that is if you were to construct a
global wealth tax
where the 0.1 percent of the wealthy the
large corporations and the large
foundations
had to pay seven percent a year
if they do not pay with bank loans
but they only have to pay three percent
a year if they do pay with bank loans
then obviously to save 400 basis points
on their wealth all these guys would pay
with bank loans
and the banks would get two sets of fees
first they'd be able to charge fees
to the wealthy for uh providing the
loans and then a second set of fees is
the banks would package
the loans into wealth tax collateralized
loan obligation bonds
and the bond buyers would pay a fee for
the packaging
so the banks the wealth tax if you
constructed it that way
the banks could make 200 billion to 600
billion dollars a year
for the 10 trillion dollars a year plus
in wealth tax money and since you were
talking earlier about how powerful the
bank lobby is and since this would be
the most profitable event in the history
of the banking industry
uh
the bank lobby would be the most
ferocious proponent for the global
wealth tax so scott do you work in the
financial industry
yeah i was a i'm a retired jp morgan
banker and i was a hedge fund banker
and i'm i'm an alumnus from columbia
university i'm i was a math mathematics
and what made you come up with this
formula what was the impetus
so i've been thinking about this a long
time and my uh so my i lived with this
woman for 11 years who graduated second
her class from columbia and then she
works at a big law firm
and she there was that one of her
clients went years and years and years
without paying his taxes
and she he's a billionaire guy and she
um
she arranged a hundred million dollar
loan for him to pay his taxes
and of course i look at twitter all the
time and i see these right wing guys are
saying hey you can't have a wealth tax
because all these rich guys will have to
liquidate all their assets
and uh so you know i would always
respond look if you think these guys if
you think a guy worth two billion
dollars can't get a bank loan at low
interest to pay his wealth tax i mean
then you just don't know you have no
concept of reality all right we're going
to have to leave it there scott know me
prince what did you hear
um so scott that that's interesting
because um you know the last thing you
said i'll just start with that it is
true that someone who has you know such
an extreme amount of wealth should be
able to not just figure out how to you
know sort of borrow cheaply in order to
pay a tax but but also just in general
um if there were a tax that was sort of
more related to their actual wealth as
opposed to um you know sort of
leveraging that wealth then uh you know
they they could easily
figure out how to make extra money in
order to sort of cover their tax anyway
whether they're borrowing to do it or
whether that's just you know siphoning a
portion of what they have and just
making more so i agree with you that you
know someone in that position um and
this actually almost relates to cece's
comment before you know the more wealth
you have um the less you'll feel uh a
tax that's true um and if a wealth tax
were created in such a way that it was
connected to banks being able to
manufacture or to securitize as you
mentioned to basically aggregate loans
that go to
institutions or individuals from which
they can pay their wealth tax
yes that would be something that would
be an attractive way for them to buy
into a wealth tax and also make money
out of it i i agree with that on the
other hand i think if we're going to
have
a wealth tax we should look at it um
as as more of a sort of speculation tax
um in that it should be related to sort
of accumulated wealth you know just just
period and yes that is hard to um to
find uh a way to purely get to from a
sort of forensic accounting perspective
but the idea would be if we're actually
taxing say transactions or speculative
transactions or or buying a piece of a
clo or selling a piece of a clo at a
certain higher level than say a capital
gains tax
that would be a way to sort of take some
of that money um back into the system um
and and then and then use it for you
know sort of other things that might be
more beneficial
jay's in asheville north carolina good
afternoon jay
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call i have a question for your guests
about
it's relatively simple question
about these rating agencies like moody
now prior to the
one when the bottom fell out of the tub
in 2008
all these wall street mouth breathers
were taking these so-called
mortgage-backed securities
to places like moody's
who stamped every single one of them
triple a absolutely absolutely brill
can't lose
i mean any damn fool knows that there's
so much so much commercial paper
that's going to qualify as that
that any of these people at these rating
agencies that that
stamped all this toilet paper
aaa
or any of them ever jailed or prosecuted
jay before we get an answer uh were you
affected by the 2008 crisis
no not at all i was lucky thank you sir
know me
thanks for that question jay and and and
and good that you weren't um
yeah well first of all um the way the
rating agencies work as as you mentioned
is that they they get paid um based on
what what they're rating
and the information that they get that
goes into securities that they're rating
tends to come from the institutions that
want these securities rated now they
should also have independent sources and
in some cases they do but the reality is
the payment relationship
has been that
a bank who wants a security rated
goes to moody's or s p and so forth they
stamp it they get paid by that bank for
that relationship and for that stamping
and and it goes into the market um and
and that was definitely one of the one
of the main problems um at the crux of
the financial crisis because not only
did banks have um bad loans coming in
already and i just you know because you
you know we're talking about this i just
want to say just from someone who yeah
programmed that the smallest details of
things throughout my career at wall
street banks have information coming in
all the time they know immediately if a
loan isn't going to pay or if it's in
delinquency or if it's in default that
they know exactly what to pick and and
what happened was and what still happens
um today in creating these
collateralized securities where where
the collateral um you know are the loans
um at the time the collateral were
mortgage loans is that banks are just
picking enough bad loans to add to the
good loans to get the good rating on the
entire package but to give them enough
money
because the bad loans generally are
paying a higher interest before they go
bad than the good loans we're paying
that's why they're subprime their their
their rates are higher uh to the
borrower um and so they're getting juice
out of that entire beginning process of
creating a loan what their the security
they're showing it to the more to the um
rating agency and the rating he is
rating that high and then what happens
is
institutions who only are supposed to
buy aaa rated securities are like cool
we're going to buy a triple a related
security and it's going to give us more
return than another kind of like a
treasury bond that's also aaa rated
that's great we'll buy as much as we can
and what else happened during the
financial crisis which made it worse is
they would borrow money from the same
banks creating these securities
in order to buy them so now these
institutions that could only buy aaa are
buying something that's labeled triple-a
that really isn't and they're also
borrowing money because they have a
triple-a against the aaa thing they just
bought which they also have to pay back
so you multiply that a number of times
it's like going down to vegas and every
time you lose 100 bucks on blackjack
someone else lends you 100 bucks you
think great i have another 100 bucks to
play but in fact you actually ultimately
have to go bus to repay everyone back
that's still the situation today except
for the fact that the rating agencies
now
tend to be rating securities that have
corporate loans in them
as opposed to more of those mortgage
loans or individual borrowers so what's
now happened
in the year since the financial crisis
is because the cost of money was so low
and companies were able to borrow or to
to leverage themselves so much so
cheaply
if any of those go bust it will create a
default
if their loans are packaged somewhere
else and rated high
and then they default
then that package is going to decrease
in value very quickly again so we're
kind of in that situation again with
rating agencies but but to your other
point no nobody
in rating agencies went to jail nobody
in um a ceo running any of the
institutions despite the billions of
dollars they paid in fines to the
department of justice in the sec have
gone to jail for frauds
and you know you have to go back to my
first book you know people like ken lay
who ran enron were
were sent to jail but but not not any of
the people running the the banking
institutions involved in this process
steve's in anchorage alaska hi steve
hello thank you for taking my call
i very much appreciate having the
opportunity to hear miss prince today
my call is two part i'd like to first of
all go back to the point that you made
that about the relationship
between the social goods that provide
the benefits to the society and the
relationship of the economic system
it should be fundamentally positioned to
provide those
those services
in that context
i'm wondering about the social order in
which it is
by law and judicial decision
the obligation fiduciary obligation of
corporations to make solely make profit
for their shareholders
and the need to fundamentally re-change
remake that particular proposition
and let me link that to a second
related proposition which is if you're
familiar with the
governance of ghana you may recognize a
man named jerry rollins
jerry rollins was the leader of the
ghanaian air force
who
carried off a coup after watching years
and years of elite and corporate uh
corruption deflecting monies away from
the basic social goods for the society
after assuming power he passed a law
entitled economic sabotage
and with those laws he indicted and
found guilty those previous owners
why should we not have economic sabotage
laws associated with the manner in which
our economic
institutions function
thank you steve we're going to leave it
there know me prince um so steve going
back to what i was saying before and i i
don't know all the ins and outs of what
happened in ghana but but from what what
you're saying and from your question um
again the the the institutions that were
involved in the financial crisis just to
look at our most recent example of of
just mass fraud um to which some of them
um admitted or settled um to the tune of
multi billions of dollars and and and
for which this fraud still continues you
look at a bank like um wells fargo where
you know after the financial crisis
after paying tens of billions of dollars
worth of settlements for various
mortgage related and other types of mis
statements and and fraud um they they
went about creating fake accounts for
their real customers and then charge
those real customers fees on those fake
accounts which were ultimately uh
discovered to be fake but in the
meantime those people um you know might
just be on the edge of their paychecks
for that month or like 80 percent of the
country is living paycheck to paycheck
and it means something um to have fees
or to have
a credit score go against you or
whatever it might be because a bank is
basically you know committing fraud and
stealing from you
these are all things that none of us
should be proud of economically and we
shouldn't subsidize institutions that
are doing this and we should have real
individuals
made to be responsible and liable and if
there's jail time for those crimes and
they're tried um and and it's discovered
that they're guilty that that should be
done because the net results um
particularly the financial system of
having um
such a link to
so many subsidies or being able to pay
fines so easily
because of the laws that enable them to
function as they're currently
functioning without having real
accountability
is ultimately a detriment on multiple
levels of society because the things
that they do to society affect
incrementally um so many people um in
our society and in our economy so so i
agree we need to have a better way of of
making them legally responsible and
enforcing laws and creating laws that
don't allow these things to happen or at
least have regulators more attuned to
what's going on as it's going on
and not after the damage has been done
to individuals
it was in 2009 that it takes a pillage
came out nomi prince appeared on our
afterwards program
and she was interviewed by this
gentleman
i remember i'm a member of the budget
committee now
and we had hank paulson a couple of
years ago and i said
mr paulson back in my state of vermont
around this country the middle class is
in a whole lot of trouble people are
really struggling people
losing their jobs their income is going
down there's a growing gap between the
very rich and everybody else what's your
sense of the economy and he said oh the
economy is doing really good and year
after year and this is really astounding
and a bit aggravating year after year we
heard from the bush administration that
from their perspective the economy was
doing great
now
explain to me how they could believe the
economy was doing great
when the middle class was collapsing and
we were getting closer and closer and
closer
to the edge of a major global financial
crisis because for them it was great and
that's the problem
nomi prince what's your relationship
with senator sanders
um well since um since i was on the show
which was where the first time that i
met senator sanders was actually was was
um here at c-span
for that interview um i subsequently
served on his federal reserve advisory
council which was a bipartisan
council
to take a look at or at least to talk to
the fed at the time about more
transparency
in terms of what they were doing because
at that time they were now subsidizing
the banks um in a tremendous way
and trying to sort of influence them to
actually use our limited influence to
influence them to think about these
matters and where they could lead
going forward in a better way
i've also contributed to recently
he had a bill out at the end of last
year
where to kind of relate to this too big
to fail question particularly with
respect to derivatives which had been
my expertise particularly when i was
back on wall street
to ensure that banks that have too much
of a concentration of too many
derivatives on their books in other
words their most likely
to be at the helm of
steering us into the next financial
crisis
would have to reduce their size reduce
their footprint by a certain amount so
that the very large banks that basically
were subsidized since the financial
crisis and control uh most of the
derivatives activity that happens um
have to actually
reduce um their size
so it was a different way of getting at
that too big to fail size from the
standpoint of
actual legislation that was introduced
it was not passed
which is which is not surprising because
i think members on both sides of the
aisle
tend to think that when banks say we're
okay now we've got this
that it's true
and um and and that's that's sort of the
situation which we find ourselves today
well folks on the hill tweets to you
please comment on the trump
administration trying to influence fed
policy how much influence does trump
have on the fed is that a good or bad
thing by the way monetary policy set by
the treasury department would be overtly
political
um
so it's it's it's interesting because
just going back to the
history of the creation of the fed um it
was effectively created um as a marriage
between politics and finance i mean it
really was
wall street working with the senate
finance committee to create an
institution that could help them in
times of trouble it wasn't like jekyll
island happened because j.p morgan
decided to send a bunch of lieutenants
to his sort of club area to talk about
how to help farmers in iowa that just
wasn't why it happened um so if you
consider that was the the initial sort
of um mo of the fed and it it has um you
know issued you know it's done monetary
policy and set rates for different
reasons to combat
inflation or sort of price activities
going forward
since then
that that's one element if we look at
what's happening today there is still a
relationship even though it's was
created as an independent body
where it's its members are institutions
and it lives in washington so it's it's
very hard to really think of it um as an
independent body it wasn't created
independently um it's supposed to be
independent but just from the sheer
pragmatics of it
it isn't really that said
i think when when president trump talked
about
that there shouldn't be rate hikes at
the end of last year what he was looking
at i think was less the economy and more
the markets as i was talking about
before he doesn't want the markets to go
down on his watch any more than
president obama wanted the markets to go
down on his watch it's just that he has
a
much sort of more public way of uh
tweeting his opinion um then then
happened under the obama administration
where rates didn't didn't rise at all so
what we have now is him very publicly um
having talked about there shouldn't be
any rate hikes and then it turned out
that that chairman jerome powell and the
flmc committee at the fed decided not to
raise rates for the rest of this year so
there is that relationship is it because
of trump
i don't know but i think what it's
because of is ultimately they're looking
at the same things which is they're
looking at data they're looking at the
markets and they're looking at not on
their watch having another financial
crisis so in that respect um they're
sort of allied as they were from the
beginning into right now uh when trump
said just recently that they should be
cutting rates right now and immediately
um as did economic adviser larry kudlow
and then sort of a week later president
trump did um that's going further and
sort of in the same process saying look
you did this before you should do this
again
and i think again even though the
economy is slowing it's not necessarily
because of the economy it's because of
the easier way to look at how money is
impacting
headline figures which is how it's
impacting the stock market
which i think they both look at
so nomi prince with your background and
your philosophy
what do you think when you see
president trump criticize
the fed chair
well
from the standpoint the fact that he put
the fed chair in his position
um it's just it's it's odd um but i mean
he's he's criticized other people that
he's um he's appointed um after he's
appointed them if they haven't done what
what he's wanted them
to do but
having looked at chairman powell's past
votes on on interest rates in general
until he was in part he basically voted
with the rest of the fomc committee he
voted with janet yellen he was fairly
dovish and in fact
he only had a couple more rate hikes
under his time than janet yellen started
under under her time and and he would
have seen that
before criticizing um his actress his
actual policy so i think it's
interesting just on a personal level
that you know you appoint someone that
you then criticize because they're not
doing what you want them to do and and i
think he wants them to do what he wants
them to do more quickly um as as
possibly with other entities in
washington but i also think that um
but but i also think it's just
an alignment that he has looking at
markets that the fed has looking at
markets and ultimately they're coming
out to the same conclusion which is that
there might possibly be a fed cut
in rates by the end of this year
and if it happens then chairman powell
will say it's because of data and
president trump will say it's because he
told them so it it the net result is
going to be the same
harsh is in lexington mississippi and
you are on with author nomie prince
harsh
thank you for taking my call
my name is harsh doshi i'm a primary
care physician
who happened to come here in lexington
mississippi homes county
and my issues are very complicated i
came here to get my own green card which
took me almost three years to get a
green card because my son is a u.s born
u.s citizen so
what i have seen here which i challenge
anybody in the united states of america
to come and visit and see the utter
poverty and suffering of the american
people in the delta of mississippi as a
physician that's my observation of 25
years a
b
who is going to safeguard
the day-to-day american people who pick
up the garbage who work in the hospital
work as a janitor who take care of our
day-to-day life and if they become sick
there is no
way they can be cared upon a be if they
become sick and need disability it takes
months together c
if something happens to these people
they barely get something where they
have to make a choice between paying for
the medicine or their own food
and d all these philanthropic people all
the government agencies they put money
why don't somebody come and visit here
i'm available to give them a tour i'm an
outsider looking at insider this is a
great country because of a scholastic
fairness i came to america because of
scholastic fairness
if we lose the scholastic fearless and
give people the understanding this is a
free party no it's not a free party i
studied outperformed and then i was
given an education in america harsh
we're gonna leave it there i apologize
um harsh you know what you're talking
about is um
again something that that you know
unfortunately is is
not just the underbelly of of america
which which is great as a country um
on the whole but but it's also prevalent
throughout
throughout the country i remember when i
was writing um
jack my second book i was after um
katrina um the hurricane katrina had
happened and i i spent time um in
louisiana and and in mississippi of
course that was after um a natural
devastation but but it was um apparent
you know sort of then that you know
having just living on the edge to begin
with and then obviously
compounding that with with a natural
disaster creates devastation that goes
past um any of the individuals involved
to their families to to people that work
with them to to companies that rely on
those people for their own benefit and
so forth it's a knock-on effect and i
think what you're talking about um from
a healthcare primary health care
perspective that that you do um is is
that as well it's that i think people
don't understand
that if we don't have a way um you know
from from an economic perspective given
that the mass amount of wealth that we
have as a country um to to support the
people that support um
not just themselves and their families
but but others um in need of of of
medical care um then then on multiple
levels we're we're hurting ourselves if
someone goes into a hospital um and and
and they could be the richest person in
the world themselves they could have
access
to the best private health insurance
that there is out there
but if they are being cared for by
people who can't afford their own health
care
or have to choose between food and that
if there's a situation in their families
or for themselves
then that's a massive hole in our system
so i i believe that there is and
primarily because in in many ways um we
do subsidize so many financial
activities on speculative activities in
this country that we have the ability to
create a a
way
to help through
an extended medicare for all program or
an extended disability program money
that's going into the system people have
already put in um and and appropriate it
in in a way that actually looks
more at
areas such as yours and throughout the
country
and from her book jacked nomi prinz
writes
let's make no mistake about this
insurance companies are middlemen their
sole job is to connect the dots that
stand between you and your medical
treatment more often than not it seems
like their job is actually to create red
tape between you and your wallet
why do we put up with them
right and that was written uh that book
came out in 2006 i think so so this was
before
our conversations about
whether it is you know medicare for all
obamacare whatever you call it the
reality is insurance companies are
private brokers
um and their ceos get paid a lot of
money and their shareholders make a lot
of money in the process of of separating
people
from from their premiums
of raising premiums without a lot of a
limit
or some states
with any limit really just what the
market can bear and ultimately what that
means is people don't get the health
care that they need in order to sustain
not just themselves but all of the
levels
in the country of individuals who rely
on them
tavis eagle river alaska hi tavis
thanks so much for taking my call it's
been a fascinating listening to know me
and listening to the other callers uh
it's interesting when you look at the
history of economics you know i think a
lot of what nomi's touching on from the
free market standpoint a lot of this has
been
presented previously by ludwig von mises
hayak friedman people like murray
rothbard people like hans rum and hopa
talking about the effects of
fiat money on the economy
the effects of too much easy money in
the in the banking system if you look at
the financial crisis in 2008 i think it
i think it's probably a
pretty good case study when you have too
much fiat currency flying around
um i guess uh
i'm just kind of
trying to figure out where nomi sits on
a lot of these issues it seems like some
she's
she's in favor of the free market
not in favor of too much fiat currency
but then she kind of has these
socialistic tendencies i guess my
question
one of my questions would be for nomi do
you think we should tend towards
a
commodity money and perhaps get get back
to a gold standard
where do you think we should continue on
with this fiat
currency that we have and i'll just
leave a quote from keynes
and in the long run
we're all dead
so
i'll just leave it there tavis kind of
stole my thunder i was going to kind of
close with that i like that we were done
but uh i i didn't
i didn't associate you with frederick
friedrich hayek well um what's what's
interesting and um you know about about
your your statements i mean i
i think money is very complex i think
markets are very complex and and what we
do with it um tends to you know get
labeled under under different sorts of
isms and and political um sort of
fights um from the standpoint of the
free market um just just to really
quickly on that i don't think
we have free markets i think it's a kind
of theoretical construct by which and
the i
you know the sort of definition for
which would be full transparency and
full participation ability by all actors
in the market and in the minute and this
sort of relates to my theories about
about the fed or about fiat currency or
about subsidizing um the main financial
actors in in in that environment you you
by definition rig the market i mean if
you're subsidizing one level of the
market and that's the market that has
the most access and volume
and influence and control over the
market we sort of get away from
free markets and in general just just
from a practicality standpoint by virtue
of how
our monetary system has been constructed
that said um you know just just because
you mentioned in terms of my my uh
thoughts about how society um should
have
more of the economic benefits that that
that are produced by that society um to
sort of help it whether that's from a
healthcare standpoint or from security
standpoint police firemen education and
so forth i think that ultimately um
allows people to be responsive into that
economy be responsible to that economy
that helps
from a foundation upward standpoint from
individual to local to small business
and so forth in a way that i think is
more secure for for everyone involved um
in terms of um
the gold standard um because it is a
question that comes up um
from a lot of people that have read my
books particularly the last um for it
takes a pillage um all the president's
bankers in collusion um one of the
things that happened when when the
united states was taken off of the gold
standard in 1971 under the nixon
administration was that all of a sudden
um banks didn't have to kind of reserve
to gold the fed didn't have to reserve
as much to go there was no anchor um to
to to the financial system there was no
there was no currency anchor um to the
dollar and and by subsequent just
definition to other
currencies outside the dollar that were
pegged to the dollar and so all of a
sudden you had the ability to create
more money because there was nothing
anchoring that money and that was a
situation that was pushed primarily by
the banks
and it was pushed primarily by the banks
because they they knew that
they knew that it was much easier to
create money if you didn't have to also
connect it to some hard asset or some
sort of other standard on the outside of
that creation you could you could just
do more it was it was a way actually of
deregulating
the monetary system i don't think just
just from the sheer standpoint of
pragmatism um to throw out an ism at you
that we're going back to a gold standard
um in fact
um ben bernanke and i have a lot of some
of the things that he said specifically
to congress in in in collusion
about the gold standard was he went
actually on a defense on a sort of
defensive movement against the gold
standard being brought back when no one
was even asking him that question when
the financial crisis was at its height
two banks and two congress which is
interesting because it was basically
saying like look we need to create money
right now so this is really just not the
time to be talking
about pegging it that said um
there are central banks who do
stockpile more gold and do think not
that we're going to go back to a gold
standard but that it could potentially
be part of
a sort of more global currency or
benchmark that will include pieces of a
gold standard which would at least also
give some sort of a peg
to simply being able to create dollars
or to create money just
at will
lawrence tweets in can you explain where
the fed gets its initial funding for its
balance sheets does congress appropriate
it
um that's interesting congress
appropriates things like
it's
how it pays its people and sort of
it's it's it's space and and sort of
more alert of logistic types of things
in terms of its actual money it's it's
it's created like um a corporation and
it gives shares out like a corporation
so that the members um or the big banks
um are like shareholders in in this
corporation and based on that and based
on the reserves that they put um onto
the balance sheet of the federal reserve
is sort of how the fed ultimately um
gets the money to be able to to utilize
that said it's also an electronic
process now so it used to be
that there was reserves or there was
gold put against federal reserve notes
which was that basically the fed would
use those as collateral and then issue
fed notes on the back of that now it can
be created electronically and so there's
um actually through 1941 there were
reports that came out from the fed that
talked about how the member banks
actually how many shares they owned and
how much those shares are worth and how
much they were putting in for them those
reports haven't been available for you
know since world war ii um but for the
most part it's the larger banks who have
more of uh the percentage of of the fed
and and sort of also um put in more of
the reserves to the federal reserve to
be able to operate robert temecula
california please go ahead you're on
book tv with author nomie prince
well hi thank you very much i'm blind so
hopefully your book will have an audio
um subscription to it but anyway my i
want to be on the devil's advocate side
here
and the way i look at california
conversely and arguably they say it has
the sixth largest economy in the world
and that's silicon valley's sixth
largest yet we have the highest rate
of welfare and poverty in any other
state even the southern states we have
such
and they say silicon valley takes away
its money and takes it out of country
and they won't even invest it in our
banks and that really worries me and i
wonder as you i
i think you're more liberal i would say
i have no problem with that as long as
the money gets distributed right but it
just seems that silicon valley
and the way they run
out of our country with the money i mean
how do you
you seem
to argue
the point against wall street but you
don't say anything about silicon valley
so
what would you do about that all right
robert thank you very much first of all
the audio have you recorded audio
versions yeah in fact robert there is
their audio versions to
to all of my books or at least the last
three books that i know of um and in
fact the one for uh collusion um
which is the one that the most recent
book um i i think is is phenomenal um
did you do the audio yourself i didn't
but um i know that that um
it was done and because there's a lot of
names in in in collusion a lot of you
know chinese names japanese names sort
of non-american
and um and and that the woman who
actually does the audio spend a lot of
time
on the language on making sure things
were accurate as well as making it of
what could be considered dry
you know the story of central banks in
the last 10 years a very entertaining
topic i think she did a good job on that
so hopefully um you'll be able to listen
to those
um you know from the standpoint of
silicon valley it's interesting because
um
you want to talk about the wall street
banks or the major banks and the
influences they've had it's it's been
over a long period of of our history um
and our evolution as a country the
evolution of our political system um you
know our sort of dominance as a
superpower as the major reserve currency
and so many other things that have
happened um whereas um a lot of the tech
companies are very new to that aspect
although that said
i think last year they overtook wall
street in terms of lobbying money um and
in terms of what they were pouring in to
get um you know what they wanted from a
legislative or policy perspective for
for for their companies as they grow and
certainly many of them don't pay any
taxes and
president trump talked about getting
taxes back on shore president obama
talked about getting taxes back on shore
president bush talked about getting
those taxes back on shore before google
was google and you know facebook was
facebook um and so this has been a
problem in general on particularly in
technology where a lot of the work is is
is kind of done
in in more of the ether you're not
necessarily building the bridge in front
of where the ambridge is about to be
built and bringing all the sort of
construction aspects to it and physical
people and everything else you can
actually do these um
these jobs in in multiple different
places and it's easy to create
different kinds of uh you know sort of
hubs in different countries and and not
pay taxes um and i i do think that's a
problem i i i think if an individual um
is is basically paying um and and this
is data actually from um from from our
last
census but basically if you look at the
number of individuals in the country
what we're paying um in in terms of
multiple taxes so a combination of
income taxes um social security taxes
employment taxes and so forth into the
country what corporations pay
as a percentage of revenue the actual
money that goes to the treasury
department and then ultimately gets
appropriated through the budget process
in in washington is only
um you know pick a year but in the last
10 years somewhere between 7 to 11
percent of all of the money that comes
into washington so on that basis
individuals are paying
a lot more and small business owners a
lot more
than the larger corporations are paying
which is which is a very small
proportion so um i i believe that's
wrong you know i i think companies um
that have the benefit of um you know so
the american population as workers the
american consumers consumers and even
the global
environment to to pick both um should be
paying more taxes to the country um in
which they're actually domiciled not the
country um you know which they on paper
um exist in
nomie prince a lot of email tweets and
facebook comments along this line
as a retiree with investments how can i
best protect myself
that's from george again several
several
comments like that and then a follow-up
from and that's george in maryland this
is george in florida
what do you do with your money
okay
um those are those are great questions
on the retiree side um
or even if you're sort of younger but
looking at the fact that you want to
live
as long as
um into your retirement and as long as
possible we'll need to to finance that
um i think there's a couple of things
one is the the the older you get um the
more secure what you have should be um
so so i think um and it's hard now
because rates are so low right so if you
have retirement money in a savings
account with say jpmorgan chase um
you're now getting like a quarter of a
percent interest on that whereas you
know for example if you if you put that
retirement money that's the savings part
into something like you know an american
express bank online or an aspiration uh
dot com bank online um then that money
is getting over 2.1 2.2 interest so
right there on on a secure basis you
know just on money that you want to not
do anything with or or just keep and i
do this she asked me what i do with my
money i don't have savings accounts in
any of the large
banks in this country because they just
don't they just don't pay enough
relative to other places i could put
that savings um and so that's one
example of what i would recommend for
secure money for retiree as well as what
i do
in terms of 401k plans or or pension
plans coming in
there's a couple of things one is i
think you should always be aware of what
you have and how it's changing on a
regular basis and a lot of people just
kind of look at their statements when
something
bad happens or when something good
happens but you're honestly monitoring
them as they're changing and i think
what you might see if you monitor them
as you change and ask these questions is
that sometimes your money is managed by
companies that
make money off of
effectively trading your money um and
and your 401k plan or your pension plan
has to basically pay for the charge of
executing each transaction that they
execute against your account and it
might not be you individually might be
like where your where your account lives
it could be yours individually so it's
important to have control of your 401k
and if you are having an outside manager
have it be someone who who is a
fiduciary someone who's responsible to
to your money and not necessarily
to a major company they might be working
for um or a bank that might also have a
an asset management element that your
401k is housed with and so therefore it
kind of trades with what the bank wants
it to trade even though it's not
supposed to but that's just kind of what
happens um and and it's more um
it loses less in that process um and and
i think those are two things i do i mean
i look at my money kind of religiously
in that respect because one thing i'll
tell you is that you make a lot more
money on wall street than you make as a
journalist that's just a thing out there
if anyone thinks there's there's a major
difference you're right but what that
means is it's very important for me to
preserve what i have um and and i do
that by being very careful about not
giving it away
first off and money that i know i want
to keep with me have it get rated as
high as it can in terms of interest and
then make sure i'm not paying fees and
all sorts of extra things along the way
because those little adjustments um or
even looking at your credit cards and
not paying any of the higher rates and
getting them down to a zero or getting
that out to nothing or transferring
balances those actually make you money
especially when you compound that
when you look at how your money grows
over time to and through your retirement
getting rid of your costs
is is huge
from nomie prin's book jacked she writes
banks spend hours
determining how to use your relationship
with them to suck money from you
take fees there's no reason banks have
to charge people to access their own
money and yet what happens if you can't
maintain a minimum balance you pay a fee
don't do direct deposit because you need
the cash from your paycheck immediately
pay a fee
next call david hot springs village
arkansas hi david
how do i'm uh
i'm interested in
the history of uh goldman sachs and
therefore i read william goldman's book
and i'm wondering if you read it the
thing that struck me about it was
gus levy your legendary principal
partner there
was able to get on the board of
at least a dozen of the fortune 500
maybe even the fortune 100
companies and then come back and trade
on the information he'd get he'd be
getting at these board meetings and i
just wonder if you had read that book
and what you think of that and my other
question is very simple do you think
thomas picketty has nailed it
thank you
thank you sir um excellent questions i i
actually i think i reviewed that book
for the daily beast back when it came
out um so so yes i did um it's it's it's
a very well researched it's it's it's a
big book i think his last name is not
it's um william
uh anyway we'll get our producers we'll
get it um
sorry about that um however um
yes one of the things that happened
throughout sort of even the initial
history of goldman sachs and i i talk
about this in all the president's
bankers because it's kind of a
fascinating set of relationships and in
particular um was even before for that
um sydney weinberg um who was around the
time of of the crash in 1929 he was
running goldman sachs as it was
participating um in a lot of what were
called trusts back then now they're
called cdos and close and other things
but basically uh you know
conglomerations of of
of stocks and other securities that
might not be doing that well or might
have to have stories be told about them
in order to get people to buy them but
we're put into these trusts which
ultimately lost all of their value when
when the market crashed in 1929 and the
way sydney weinberg who was running
goldman at the time thought he could get
through this was to become friends with
a uh well the
governor of new york
a man named franklin delano roosevelt
who ultimately became the president of
the country um why did president
roosevelt become president roosevelt
well one of the things that he had was
sydney weinberg and a bunch of people in
the business community that weinberg
aggregated um contribute to his campaign
so even though he's considered a traitor
to his class the the reality is just if
you follow the money back to his initial
campaign and his initial coming into
office um is that sydney weinberg and
actually another fellow named joe
kennedy who was kennedy's um father jeff
kay's father um we're helping him to
create money weinberg in new york uh
kennedy in in california and as a result
fdr appointed a new council called the
business council um at the time on which
he put the head
sydney weinberg so sydney weinberg has a
redeemed goldman and redeemed
wall street in the eyes of of fdr in the
country in a way
by
getting his friends
to that he invested with and that
invested with him
to basically support the incoming
president and he saw the writing on the
tea leaves that kind of thing has has
continued um throughout throughout uh
you know time since there's a tremendous
number of what what are called
interlocking board memberships um
between institutions
and also a a vast percentage of people
in congress own stocks
in companies that
doesn't take a rocket scientist to
figure out how they're related to policy
that those very congress people
might be
promoting so that that that still
happens
phil portland oregon please go ahead
with your question or comment for know
me prince
well thank you fans for taking my call
and yeah where to begin after all you
said
um
i'll put it up as a the political
football question of 2020
can a president get the 10 percent
to pay a fair share tax to
restrict america's infrastructure i mean
the mercers the purdue's the waltons the
coax they all laugh in america's face
and
americans like you and me
and try to keep as much money as they
can and not pay anything
how can a president elected get ten
percent from the wealthy without
creating a civil war between the house
and have nets that's phil in portland
oregon so that that's an interesting
question because um you know under this
administration we've kind of gone gone
the opposite
way um
in terms of taxes um there's no
particular reason the math would work
better on on on that kind of a tax
that's that's the proportion it's more
of a proportion tax
throughout the entire country so that so
that the wealthier pay up to a certain
amount um a a higher percentage into the
tax system and beyond that
a different percentage perhaps but that
is a way to bring in money into the the
treasury department which ultimately is
where the money is taken
into the budget process and and
ultimately that money can get
appropriated into things like
infrastructure
we we have a tremendous infrastructure
deficit in this country
everyone who was nom everyone was in in
the process trying to get elected uh
last election including president trump
talked about paying money into
infrastructure um it's it's it's a
problem that we have
you know bridges that are falling apart
and ports that are that are old and and
railways that are slow and you know
hospitals that are in need of of better
equipment or roads to get to them or
whatever it might be that that again
that's a significant pan-economic
problem for the country and and
retrieving uh money from companies or or
the wealthy that use more of those
benefits because they they ultimately
depending on what they're running could
be utilizing more of the infrastructure
that they need would actually benefit
them as well back when president
eisenhower was was president republican
president had a lot of bankers and
company men and stuff around him who
propped him into that position after
having been a general during world war
ii
he came up with a plan to build our
nation's highways he came up with that
plan and he raised taxes and he built
the highways and he resided
over a number of economic booms not just
for the people at the top of the country
getting back to the other caller who was
talking about piketty who talks about
inequality being a problem but but
throughout the rest of the country and
an anecdote that i found going through
um
a lot of the files i spent time a lot of
time in kansas actually looking at
president eisenhower's notes and all the
um documents from that period in history
um is that there was a a person who was
a banker at the morgan bank at the time
so one of the most powerful banks still
and then at the time who said to
president eisenhower in a letter he said
look if you
create a tax system
whereby
those of us who have those are the p and
he was rich so the people that have less
money
actually can keep more of their money
and the people who have more money have
to pay a little bit more of their money
into the system ultimately you have a
stronger economy he was a millionaire he
was working one of the major banks um in
the country and this was in a letter
that he wrote to eisenhower where he
advocated
this kind of a more proportional tax
system because he believed that the more
money was actually in more people's
pockets throughout the country the
better ultimately the entire economy
would be it would lift those people and
it would lift all of the business owners
and wealthy people at the top of that
and that was one of the things inside
the philosophy for um
for the highway programs it wasn't the
only thing but eisenhower did did listen
um to people a lot he communicated um he
a lot um through letters and and he he
took people's opinions um very seriously
and so this was something that worked to
the benefit of the country
and was something that was postulated by
its wealthiest members
this is from the preface of all the
president's bankers you talk about your
research
all of the national archives and records
administration libraries for fdr through
carter have exceedingly accessible and
well-organized information with
consistent classifications they were a
pleasure to peruse and i lost myself for
days in all of them
after reagan took office records became
less available at the clinton library in
little rock i learned that some records
may never be uncovered without the
benefit of a freedom of information act
request not merely for national security
reasons but because the commitment to
organize such a vast amount of material
is not what it was before the 1980s
as such the bulk of information that
might be revealed by the four-year
request that i filed at the reagan
george h w bush and clinton libraries is
not available yet
so it's interesting because since that
time
i
actually did i i did um file foia
requests with the clinton library um and
with the
george w bush library um senior and i
wound up ultimately getting some of
those requests back to me
from the clinton library um and it's
interesting it took a number of years um
and and they they did respond to some of
them they didn't respond to others what
what i what i had studied or tried to
get at um at the clinton library was
what happened into the repeal of the
glass-steagall act in 1999 because there
was an awful lot of activity um that was
that was going on back and forth between
in particular um
the the city bank
had sandy weil and the the clinton
administration and congress and so forth
so what i was trying to do because it
was happening during the time of
clinton's administration
is try to get as much of that as i could
and what i found because the
classification systems in general in in
the presidential libraries became
more difficult
to to access and and the funding to them
became less so the librarians had more
difficulty access them and some of it
was classified a lot of it was
classified it was difficult but
ultimately they got me some material
after the book came out
and i used some of it in in the in the
paperback version and then some of it is
actually still still is coming in
but but not all of it is exactly what i
asked so so i have to admit that even
though i i did get some material back
from clinton's library i haven't gotten
it back yet from from the bush one and
even from the clinton library
it's become difficult and my guess is
going forward in time and i think i
talked about this in the very end of the
president's bankers when you get to the
obama administration or you get to the
trump administration or whoever we have
going forward it becomes harder and
harder to really get access to that
information
because now it's electronic there's all
sorts of national security labels put on
it's all sorts of redactions
and every piece of every email has to go
through analysis as to whether it's a
security risk to even get um
basically the the access that the foia
would would uh would require from it so
it's it's it's difficult times have
changed no me prince i know this isn't
your area of writing but did george
washington have a relationship with
bankers
um that is an interesting question um i
i don't know if he did i know john adams
um did have a relationship with bankers
um and then and that the adams family in
general um in terms of financing their
their own sort of um horizon as well as
what he thought of banking thomas
jefferson as well
i am not entirely sure about george
washington um himself so someone had to
finance you know some of those wars and
and in a lot of cases um even even the
initial war that created our country um
you had to have financing to do that and
and oftentimes it was financiers who
were involved with the army and with
ultimately the government who helped to
provide some of that and during world
war ii were banks important to fdr
banks were very important in world war
ii um if we even look at sort of the
memories of that um in terms of um war
bonds that were issued through the banks
to individuals there were situations i
mean i looked up documents where you
could see um you know ads being put out
by um by say chase to the population in
new york city to say like you know open
up an account get a war bond certificate
there's all sorts of deals
that were being sort of run by by banks
as well as them providing some of their
own
money into the war effort as well as
directing some of that war effort and
different banks provided different funds
to different elements of the war and
also the countries outside to our allies
you know whether it was going to the uk
um going to germany as well on the other
side so definitely they had a role um in
in the financing and the raising of
finances for that warrant during that
period in history where i talk about
world war ii um there's a lot of um
there's a lot of communication going
back and forth between sort of the
people that were running
these institutions like tom lamont who
was running the morgan bank at the time
and the president's
sort of staff as well as fdr
uh before we leave collusion
what's the role of the imf and the world
bank in the world
money
situation yeah so talking about coming
out of world war ii um the idea was and
a meeting was held in 1944 in bretton
woods new hampshire where um sort of
leaders
of the winners of the international sort
of community came together to talk about
how to fund ultimately the reparations
um that needed to be done in the wake of
war um so so so the argument for the imf
the international monetary fund and the
world bank
came out of two things one to have some
sort of a currency element that could
work throughout the world so that we
could basically look at financing what
were at the time a lot of devastations
and money required for those
devastations around the world because of
world war ii for the war and then by
extension
other countries who had suffered because
of the economic
downturns that that were caused by the
war that needed funding to to be
developed now that's changed over the
years since um to having you know
funding that's based on development you
know developing countries and helping
with anything down to you know building
a waterway from a village to sort of a
major river to more complex and larger
funded programs
and these and these um
and these monetary system components are
also run by different individuals from
different parts of the world so the idea
is that they're an international sort of
base of development related money
the world bank was actually run the
second president of the world vancouver
was run by a man named john mccloy who
became the chairman of chase after he
became the head of the second head of
the world bank
and that relationship again had
something to do with chase or or banks
would go out to the public and they
would try to raise money that would then
go back to the world bank that the world
bank could then use for projects
that they deemed
appropriate or necessary and then the
world bank would find the task teams and
sort of work on distributing that money
out to those particular projects
one final character before we run out of
time that you
spend a lot of time with
david rockefeller
so david rockefeller's is very
interesting because he was at the crux
of a major shift that happened um
throughout the relationship between
banking and
washington between wall street and the
presidency and that was that he came
from a time where there was a depression
and and where his family or the
rockefellers actually owned a
significant portion or the rockefeller
aldrich's which was going back to nelson
aldrich and his son winthrop he married
into the rockefeller family so abby
rockefeller and winthrop aldridge had
children etc they became
david rockefeller nelson rockefeller and
other rockefellers so so that the family
itself was fascinating i'm summarizing
but it goes through multiple decades of
this family being involved in elements
of wall street elements of global policy
of nelson rockefeller became the vice
president while david rockefeller was
running chase um which at the time was a
major bank of
it still is it's jp morgan chase is the
largest bank in the united states it was
a major power player um at chase but
david rockefeller during his time as he
was rising to become the chairman of
chase
was also working more and more outwardly
with other sort of foreign policy
initiatives like working more closely
with the middle east and finding ways
for
um
middle east money or petro dollars money
that was made out of oil to be used as
currency as collateral for loans that
that chase could make to latin america
or to other developing countries and
make money off of that so rather than be
fully aligned as they had been
historically to the united states
government for money and therefore a
very symbiotic relationship and
influence chain they now through him
have this ability to access money that
was coming in from an external place
and
lend it to another external place and in
that way to take themselves into
a position where they could more control
what the government was doing as opposed
to have to be a team player
because they had now this extra pot of
money coming from somewhere else he was
also very much an advocate of going off
of the gold standard and everything else
through that whole 1970s period to allow
banks to have
larger access to pools of capital and
just a larger
general footprint so he's interesting
for for for a lot of reasons i mean yeah
his he goes back to having you know
balls with the kennedys in london i mean
lots of things are interesting in his
life as well john mccloy who i mentioned
had worked with doc david rockefeller
throughout his earlier career and had
grown through that relationship
ultimately to become a very you know
become the head of the world bank and
become the head of chase so a lot of
individuals that move between politics
and global monetary systems and banks
and society sort of all tied in somehow
to david rockefeller and she tells that
story in her book all the president's
bankers in case you're interested nomi
prinz in our last minute
let's bring all these pieces together
for the past two hours
what in your view is a solution to this
100 plus years of banking
regulation law
and the government well it's a couple
pieces one is i think that you know we
we do have to reinstate a glass-steagall
because we do have to separate not just
our banking system but globally banking
systems because we you know thanks copy
banks um from the money that's put in
through people's deposits um and through
their loans and through the credit that
they require for themselves or their
small businesses or or what have you
from the more speculative activities
that that banks do because without doing
that and it's important to
to to
make that split we will have a situation
where the federal reserve and other
central banks will be have no choice in
their minds and in their policies but to
continue to subsidize the very risk and
the very bets that these institutions
place upon society while they're saying
everything's okay they always will say
everything's okay particularly if
they're not the ones holding the bag at
the other side and there's some other
resource or pool whether it's in the
government or whether it's at the fed
that can help them in that time of
trouble so i think that's that's one
major thing that needs to be done and
from that
everything relates author and journalist
nomie prinz has been our guest on
in-depth thank you thank you so much
thank you for all the years
and if you missed any of today's program
we're going to re-air it right now